go ahead and try again
how about now
can you hear me
excellent that's what we want no echoes
good morning everyone and welcome to the
science technology and
energy committee
session for friday the 12th of february
please mute your microphones
and stand and join
me and the rest of the committee
in the pledge of allegiance led by
representative troy mirner
[Music]
which stands for nation under god
indivisible with liberty and
thank you and good morning again
as chair of the house science technology
and energy committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the coveted 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the science technology and
energy committee
executive session on pending legislation
may be held at any time
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting
also by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been available made available in the
house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting should call 271
or email hcs
ledge dot state
dot nh
s
in the event that the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled
we have a staff member with us today
that's jennifer four our committee
researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let us start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also indicate whether there is
anyone in the room with you during the
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
so i'll now ask our acting clerk troy
murder to call the role
representative thomas
oh
here here here
wow
representative harrington
here
representative
representative sausage
uh i'm here at home uh and i'm alone
representative callie pitts
um
alone
representative man
home and alone here
representative oxenham
present and alone
representative
vincent
representative mckee
uh present
representative williams
i'm here my daughter will be in and out
representative
i am representative kate murray
substituting for representative
christian is this when i should say that
i'm here
yes you murray yeah
i am home alone my husband are not alone
my husband's in the house i'm in
newcastle
representative
here home alone
glad to be here and i'm alone
okay and cheer
here in the committee room
okay so we're listening too so we have
19 present right now
so we have a quorum which uh is adequate
to
conduct our business for the day and
before we start that business for the
day
i would like to
congratulate
governor sununu
on his budget address yesterday
and his uh introduction of the idea of
creating a department of energy for the
state of new hampshire back in 2018
or 2017 i don't remember exactly
which day
there was a proposal for a study
committee to
investigate starting a
department of energy
and
i remember saying at the time that
that should be the prerogative of the
governor just the department of energy
and then in 2019 a study commission was
formed to study that issue and
it came to no significant conclusions
because the rightful place i believe for
starting the department of energy is
with the executive
branch of the government so i
congratulate the other governor on his
innovative plan to
abolish the
office of strategic
initiatives and merge it with certain
portions of the public utilities
commission
to form the department of energy i'm
looking forward to
learning more about the details
i would also like to thank publicly uh
representative mirner for being our
active acting clerk
since the start of our sessions uh
earlier this year
uh thank you troy for doing it i know
it's not a pleasant job or a fun job but
we really appreciate
taking on that
while our representative
is uh is out
so thank you for doing that
representative platt is fully restored
as a member of the committee as of
monday february 15th
and he will resume
or pick up
the duties of
clerk when he returns to
committing work
shortly after that
so with that
uh i'm now
going to
uh mr mr chairman can i can i have a
moment
yes you have a question uh
sausage uh
yes i do mr chairman but first of all
i'd like to join you in
in uh congratulating the governor uh
democrats have been supporting a
department of energy for many years we
think it's a great idea this state needs
the department of energy to consolidate
all the efforts so i too join with you
and congratulate the government for
doing that
i do have a question however
if you can answer that for me and that
is are you planning to have any
executive sessions today and what bills
would that be if you do it
we don't have any
plans to have an executive session
but
we are operating opportunistic about
executive sessions if we should
uh conclude a public hearing with time
left in the hour then we may have one if
we did have one we would exec
hb
three five one
bill that we would attempt to exact
today
if we had time
but i'm not expecting that we will have
time
okay thank you mr chairman you're very
welcome
okay so with that let's uh start the
day's activity
i will open the public hearing on house
bill 172
and that is a bill that establishes
greenhouse gas emission reduction goals
for the state and establishes a climate
action plan its prime sponsor is
representative weston who apparently is
not available
we're going to ask uh representative
mcgee
well i'm sorry we're going to ask uh
representative oxenam
to interest introduce the bill to us
now before you start representative
oxendine
i have to inform the entire committee
that we have 15 people who've signed up
to speak on this bill therefore we're
going to have to strictly limit
the time that people are allowed to
speak in addition to that we're going to
have to
strictly limit the amount of questions
that committee members can ask so we're
going to have to enforce the rule
that if you are a sponsor or a
co-sponsor on the bill you're not
allowed to ask questions
so with those ground rules in place we
can now ask
representative occident to introduce
this bill
and don't forget to unmute
representative oxman
thank you very much sir i have a
question before the timer starts um
i
am now presenting for representative
weston who has a five minutes as the
prime sponsor then i would have had two
minutes as the the next person up could
if i combine those and get them into
just a little bit over five minutes will
that be possible
uh
possible but you have to be very careful
about making sure you don't exceed
your time limit could you give me the
30-second warning that you were giving
uh people
recently
absolutely that that would be very
helpful and and i had another another
point uh senator sue prentice is
wishes to speak to this bill but she's
not available between 9 15 and 9 30. so
if you could call on her outside of
those parameters that would be very
helpful
okay
let's start the clock
go ahead hb 172
is a bill that calls for planning
preparation and protection for this
residents of new hampshire if we turn to
the bill itself and look at the findings
it lays out the plan very very
succinctly
scientific evidence for the warming of
the climate system is unequivocal this
warming is overwhelmingly attributable
to human activity and development
particularly the combustion of fossil
fuels left unchecked the climate crisis
will continue to have real and possibly
catastrophic impacts on new hampshire's
residents economy and environment
it will impinge on the health and safety
of all our families
new hampshire will see longer and hotter
summers shorter warmer winters more
frequent and more extreme precipitation
events
more flooding more drought
climate impacts will endanger the health
of new hampshire families by
facilitating the spread of vector-borne
diseases as well as increasing rates of
respiratory and cardiovascular disease
imposing mortality and morbidity burdens
on our citizens
increased warming and more extreme and
more frequent precipitation events will
also negatively impact key sectors of
new hampshire's resource-based economy
harming agriculture tourism and outdoor
recreational activities
a warmer and more acidic gulf of maine
will see increased coastal flooding
harm our seafood production
and endanger lives homes and productive
properties
taking proactive measures to mitigate
the climate crisis also presents
opportunities for new hampshire and with
proper planning and possibly a
department of energy the state should
more quickly be able to move to maximize
those co-benefits that exist in
mitigating the disruption
as renewable resources like wind and
solar increasingly replace fossil fuels
manufacturing businesses should be po
poised to reap the benefits
the state should act to ensure new
hampshire is well represented in any
multi-state efforts to harvest those
wind resources in addition to helping
reduce the greenhouse gas emissions of
our state replacing fossil fuels with
zero emission sources of energy will
improve the health of our families by
reducing pollution that degrades our
air quality and also help with our
tourism-based economy
producing energy from local resources
will keep billions of energy dollars in
state instead of sending them out of
state to fossil fuel producers and
sometimes out of the country
this will create a virtuous in-state
development cycle
a more renewably based and energy
self-sufficient government will save
taxpayers money retain more of that
money in the state and help grow new
hampshire's economy
it is incumbent upon us to take prompt
proactive and continuing action to
protect our residents from the
anticipated consequences of the climate
crisis
to mitigate those harms to the extent
possible and to safeguard new
hampshire's resources for generations to
come
in view of the um time constraint i
think i will leave my comments there and
take questions
okay thank you uh
representative oxendine do we have
questions for representative oxendine
mr chair
yes representative um i i meant to uh at
the end of my remarks and inform you
that our scientific expert
dr cameron wake of the university of new
hampshire will not be able to be here
today so after my questions could we
actually call on representative
mcwilliams to read his testimony into
the record it's brief
okay we'll consider that if we have time
any questions for representative oxnam
who did an admirable job by the way
introducing this bill in three minutes
and 37 seconds
seeing none we will call on the next
speaker
who is a senator both i'm very sorry for
interrupting but i just wanted to bring
to your attention that representative
weston is is available now
representative
oh okay
all right well
in that case why don't we call on
representative
weston to present
[Music]
okay representative weston you are on
and i will give you
four minutes
okay chairman vos members of the
committee thank you for letting me come
on i'm not sure what the confusion was
because i came into the meeting five
minutes early but here i am and i want
to thank representative oxenham for
doing a wonderful job
uh of filling in
she did mention a lot of the points i
was going to make so what i will do
is skip to an aspect that i don't think
she mentioned and that that is this
is not just a climate action plan it's
also an economic development plan
um
oxenham mentioned a lot of the things
about the the dangers of not paying
attention to this and the cost of doing
nothing
but i think right now we have to
consider the fact that we are in a
situation where we have a new
administration in washington i read a
result of a poll just yesterday that
stated climate change is the number two
concern of citizens across this country
and with the change in our leadership we
have an administration that's now
responding to this concern
i predict that there'll be a lot of
programs coming out soon from washington
that could help us with the transition
if but if we don't start this process
now we'll not be ready we won't be able
to hit the ground running when these
these opportunities come through this
bill empowers des to do that so this is
absolutely the right time to be making
this change
in the senate hearing there's a lot of
discussion about a cost-benefit analysis
in the
2009 task force report there was a
excellent cost-benefit analysis and
these analysis had always are also being
done in states around us
in massachusetts in vermont
and the state of maine has just filed a
terrific report that's available online
that has a whole chapter about the
benefits
of um of making
uh
of initiating a climate change action
plan
so um
as i said i'm a little reflux because of
the cha the um mix-up but i do hope that
you'll consider that this would be an
economic benefit to the state
and um i'll be happy to take questions
if there are any
thank you representative any questions
for representative weston
seeing none i thank you representative
weston and i will call next on the next
speaker who is
senator tom
sherman who represents senate district
24.
senator sherman are you uh
are you out there
okay
senator sherman you're on for
three minutes
uh thank you so much mr chair and
hopefully i won't need that much time
um so for the record my name is senator
tom sherman i represent 11 towns along
the seacoast
and
i just wanted to bring up a couple of
points i'm also a practicing physician
and i was chair of the ad hoc commission
on uh admissions we were known as the
emissions commission we met over the six
months come and finished our report in
december
and i bring uh two different slightly
different perspectives to this uh
discussion the first is
as the uh seacoast senator having all
the waterfront from newcastle down to
seabrook
as part of my district
i would like to underscore the concern
that we have on a regional impact
which has to do with sea level rise and
storm surges uh these are well
documented we just had a meeting last
week of
actually this week of the hampton beach
area commission
and
that group was talking about how do we
respond to sea level rise and as
we're aware the sea level rise is a
reflection of climate change um and
warming
so that's one concern but on a public
health standpoint we had a wonderful
presentation by dr katie bush from the
department of health and human services
in our ad hoc commission on the public
health component
the not only the health side of
emissions and pollution
not only is that critical but the fiscal
side
uh
is also
an important consideration here
emissions reduction goals
have a direct impact on on patient
safety and on disease burden for the
state
especially in patients with asthma copd
and other pulmonary diseases or lung
diseases
so i would encourage you all to think
about that as you're crafting
your this bill and working on this bill
the other is i absolutely applaud the
governor's
decision to start the department of
energy and i would think that there may
be a
need to look at the bill and whether
there would need to be any amendments
that would dovetail this not only with
des but also with the department of
energy
and
finally i'm offering my full support to
work with you all as this comes over to
the senate
um to make sure that we have a
coordinated effort to ensure its passage
and i'm happy to take any questions
okay
you did it in two minutes and 50 seconds
well done sir brevity
any questions for senator sherman it
looks like representative samsich is
recognized for a question
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question
um
i wanna could you elaborate a little bit
more about the health impacts that that
are connected uh as you see to this bill
yeah so um
i think we've known for a long time the
impact of pollution on health
weather but we tend to think of that as
something that happens in the cities you
know new york boston and other big
cities
but in fact in parts of new hampshire
particulate pollution is
critically
impactful on people's health
most of this is on lung disease but we
also see it on
when you think about how the body works
if you breathe something in
that will eventually come back up and
well actually i'm a gastroenterologist
it will eventually impact your gi tract
as those
particles are moved through the system
so in terms of a cancer impact
pollution has impact on lung cancer has
impact on
all of the elimination
roots uh which would include the gi
tract and the uh
and the kidneys
so
decreasing emissions um
would have real-time impact on pediatric
diseases like asthma
there are studies that have been shown
through harvard that actually looked at
pregnant women
and monitored their air intake by
putting basically what's called a nasal
cannula by their nose and measuring what
they were breathing in also looked at
the cord blood
to the fetus
and those particular matters that
pollution was getting not only into the
woman's lungs but also passing into the
cord blood
so we know that these are impacting even
fetuses in development
and so
reduction of emissions reduction of
pollution
from public health standpoint is
critical
i would be happy to provide the
tape of katie bush's uh presentation if
that would be helpful for the commission
i'm sorry for the committee in their
deliberations but it was compelling now
not just on the public health standpoint
but also on the fiscal impact if you
think of the burden of
lung disease and cancer in the state and
and
remind us that we are we have some of
the highest rates not only of pediatric
cancer in the state i'm sorry in the
country new hampshire does but also
esophageal cancer breast cancer and
other cancers
so
we do have a public health
imperative uh which and one component of
that is air pollution
thank you
uh senator sherman follow-up
questions i would uh no other raised
hands i would like to
call on our next speaker
representative kat mcgee it's all yours
for three minutes
thank you mr mr chair
um
after hearing what's been mentioned
today i think i'll just
add around what was said i actually was
one of two house representatives who sat
on the admissions commission with
senator sherman senator waters and
senator bradley
and in addition to the health effects
that were covered in that commission
we had a wonderful presentation from
chris skoglund over at des
and he basically chronicled for us what
our plans had been when we had a
department of energy and he talked about
how that downward trajectory was going
to level off if we didn't have
additional policies around uh our
emissions
in 2021 so this would be that year
and so i signed on to this bill when i
saw it i asked to be a co-sponsor
because i recognized that there was a a
a missing piece in having something to
focus on in terms of a plan my
background is as a as a project and
program manager and so i know that if
you're trying to do anything
uh ambitious and you don't have a plan
you're you're not going to succeed
i'm also very happy to hear that the
governor is planning to put a department
of energy back in place
but i think we've lost four years and
that would be my recommendation for hb
which is that
at least if we have some focus and move
forward as a house to say
that we would like to
get to work on it rather than have
further delays in the setup and the
funding et cetera et cetera of having
that energy department come into being
uh then i think we would be
that much further along
uh the bill asked both parties to come
together and acknowledge that the
planning is the thing
that gets us to the right answers
together
if we continue to ignore the effects to
discuss what is possible
um
and what is realistic short and long
term in terms of the trade-offs and the
costs then we're really shirking our
responsibility
um at the expense of those who elected
us so it's our responsibility to figure
out what makes sense without
anyone in charge of energy policy so if
that's going to change it's great but i
don't know what the timing is going to
be of all that so i would recommend that
we move this forward
in order to help us make better
decisions and in order to make sure that
the conversation is furthered sooner
than later because i do i do feel like
we've been delaying a lot of this for a
long time without anybody in charge so i
was very excited to see uh
to see this bill come forward to just
say it's it's time for us to put the
effort in 30 seconds yup i'm good
thanks
oh okay well thank you uh take the 30
seconds
representative mcgee
all right well i don't see any questions
for representative mcgee
so we'll move to our next speaker who is
uh suzanne
or sue
yeah suzanne prentiss
you uh
are recognized to speak
good morning um
chairman vos and members of the uh
members of the committee and thank you
for recognizing me to speak this morning
my name is sue prentice i am the state
senator for district five
here in the greater connecticut river
valley and uh representative oxenam is
one of my my colleagues here and i also
want to say hi to representative murray
we are leadership uh
leadership new hampshire class of 2014
best class ever so i i have briefly i
actually think that representative mcgee
covered really what i wanted to talk
about in terms of a plan and not waiting
and so i'm just going to add a few extra
points to that um and thank you so much
representative mcgee
that i i introduced this basically the
same bill in the senate because i think
that this is and that's senate bill 115
such an important um pro such an
important plan putting greenhouse gas
emissions
uh the goals for them
into statute a new
climate action plan into statute giving
due regard um to the you know the
finances the the financial impact as we
move this forward
not only to local municipalities but to
businesses considering that
you know having an annual inventory is a
way of being accountable to not just the
present but to the future
and that this is amongst a number of
things it encourages private and public
investment opportunities um talks about
workforce development which is key um
and that is this engages state agencies
um in who work in this and with
greenhouse gas emissions projects in
incorporating this and integrating it
into all that they do
some of those are just the key pieces of
why i support having a comprehensive
plan putting it in statute and moving
forward i too am excited um and
impressed with bringing about a
department of energy but as
representative mcgee said
you know the time is now we can't wait
and i will i will close by saying
that there are parallel pandemics
happening not just in our in new
hampshire but in our nation in our world
and we in no way am i um lessening the
impact of coven 19 and how we face that
every day but climate was here before
that and our vaccination and our
strategy to mitigate
um you know the impacts of climate on
on our on our families and on our future
and our businesses is really a
comprehensive plan integrated into state
government i so i applaud the work of
the sponsors i'm taking this up in the
senate and
i look forward to getting this work done
this year so thank you very much happy
to take any questions you have
thank you senator apprentice and i
apologize for not recognizing you
recognizing you as a senator
no problem i've never met and uh
i did not actually recognize you as a
senator apprentice
i look forward to meeting you
any questions for senator francis
uh yes mr chairman representative
yes
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my call my question
um
can you tell us a little bit about how
you believe this bill would impact
positively your district economically
uh
both
from the environmental perspective but
also from the job perspective
thank you for the question and i think
i'm going to focus on the job
perspective
we have a number of opportunities at
here in terms of
you know not just construction but in
bringing when we bring about action like
this and promoting
um the building of solar arrays um
actually new construction on homes and
on businesses we're bringing about green
jobs and it incorporates a workforce
development track which in in this
district in district five um this has
been a conversation that i've had with
many who are interested in terms of
keeping our
our youth
developing the trades for our youth and
seeing the green side to that um is is
an incredible value to us economically
so if we can keep the youth here build
the green jobs and we'll have a positive
impact on this is we're not just
building homes but building out other
you know other capacity and solar would
be one of those areas where whether it's
on a home or we have a project here in
this district it's over in on the
enfield lebanon line where a
solar array has been put in place and it
provides power to a mobile home park
it's a third-party not-for-profit
project and brought about jobs so
that's how i see it impacting the
economy here positively and it's wanted
thank you
thank you senator seeing no additional
questions for the senator i will now
recognize our next speaker who is chris
skoglund
from the new hampshire department of
environmental services mr skoglen you
have the floor for three minutes
are you there
i am i'm sorry uh
chairman votes i had myself on backup
mute if i could have mike fitzgerald
elevated as well we will be presenting
uh for ges
um and using only three minutes between
us
would that be possible
yeah exactly yes i just uh elevated mr
fitzgerald so you are both set together
good morning mr chairman thank you very
much i appreciate the uh opportunity to
uh
to speak on this bill um
and chris goglin is also he uh our
climate programs manager here at des
so thank you for allowing us both to
speak
uh des takes no position on this bill um
but by way of uh background
context um there has there has been
similar legislation that was uh
presented last year that i believe it
died in the
covid
uh situation that
affected all legislation last year
um but uh
des
[Music]
has several activities that are required
of us in this legislation and while we
certainly recognize the need
uh and the importance of planning to
address climate change
here in the state um and our agency was
the agency that
uh
uh coordinated and ultimately produced
the climate action plan uh of 2009 uh
under governor lynch's um executive
orders and
and uh with the uh 29-member climate
commission
um that plan and the plan that's
proposed here would require significant
effort on our department
um i'd just like to state that
yes currently receives no
general funds state funding
to uh support climate activities all
those activities are funded via two
mechanisms one is
federal funds uh epa
that uh
[Music]
funds our general air pollution
activities and climate activities um
that we work in coordination with epa on
and another is a large environmental
settlement that occurred more than 10
years ago
and a national environmental settlement
with a major
polluter
and
new hampshire benefited from some of
those funds and we have applied those to
climate planning those funds mister
scotland
he's the only employee in the department
that has direct
uh
full responsibilities for
climate planning activities
back in 2009
those federal funds funded 20 people
today they fund 12 people we've been
we've been level funded by the epa for
more than 10 years which is actually a
cut given that obviously every year
there are increases in salaries and
benefits and so on
so
um that climate plan that we worked on
in 2009 we were able to
utilize at times more than 10 department
staff um
that uh not all at the same time and and
so on but um certainly the equivalent of
two or three full-time staffers uh for a
significant amount of time we no longer
have those resources and so i think it's
important to recognize that again we
fully support and understand that this
uh planning is important and needs to
occur
that we do not have the resources
necessary to implement this plan
um as proposed right now
and
so
we also feel that we would benefit
this legislation would benefit from
funding for a consultant to address
economic impacts
planning for climate the 2009 climate
plan did
uh conclude that there was
as was mentioned by representative
oxenham in the beginning that there are
significant economic benefits that can
be realized from
from implementing climate planning and
focusing on renewable energy and other
other activities here in the state that
that can address climate
and um as was mentioned um
by representative sherman we do see um
in the coming years the state of new
hampshire is plateauing in terms of our
emissions
we
we will stay fairly level without new
any new additional policies or planning
so um
we we we think uh and also i would just
quickly address um the issue that was
raised with regards to the department of
energy and i would suggest suggest that
as this legislation goes forward um
that uh
there being it's an addition online uh
page three on line 27 and 28
that uh talks about des consulting with
other agencies and it repre it mentions
puc and osi
um you might want to consider adding
something to the effect of and other
state agencies as appropriate
um because there could potentially be a
department of energy uh as has been
mentioned and also probably bea would be
um an agency that would be of interest
for us to consult with in terms of
of uh jobs economic impact and that that
sort of activity um so with that uh
i will conclude if uh there are
questions for d yes either mr skoglund
or i would be happy to try to uh
try to address them
thank you uh mr fitzgerald the chair
recognizes representative knotter for a
question
thank you mr chairman good morning
i'm hoping you can do anything um
that i have i should have asked this
representative dr sherman um he said
that we have the
cancer
in the country and i'm wondering where i
can find the facts to back up that
statement
quite alarming and i want to see the
proof
i i'm sorry it was somewhat difficult to
hear i i
i believe you were asking about um
increased cancer risk
is that the question
um
yes it's it's a little
a little difficult but go ahead
okay
dr sherman when he testified
representative sherman uh said that new
hampshire has the highest rates of
cancer in the country
and i wanted to see
look that up for myself i want to see
the proof of that statement because
that's very alarming
and i i know you can direct me
um we certainly can
i i don't have information right now but
uh as as uh senator sherman mentioned
the emissions commission the ad hoc
emissions commission that convened over
the summer and the fall
did address public health impacts to
climate change
um and received information from dr
katie bush and other representatives
from dhhs um that would be their purview
um and but i'd be happy to uh
to direct you to
the most appropriate source of that
information
thank you
and the chair recognizes representative
thomas for a question
thank you
okay thank you mr chair thank you mr
michelle for taking my question um i'm
just curious with century with des how
would you currently characterize uh
new hampshire's contribution to the us's
uh carbon emissions
uh president in terms of percentages do
you have any fingers on that
well generally uh
i i would say we can certainly provide
you with some information but generally
new hampshire
you know
carbon emissions uh climate greenhouse
gas emissions are somewhat proportional
to population because it's it's uh
um
a uh
you know an
uh an impact of of human activities and
so it's cars it's it's businesses and so
on um we may have somewhat higher
emissions uh or did have somewhat higher
emissions
as a result of uh significant fossil
fuel
energy production here in new hampshire
that was actually exported outside the
state for many years
that has that has reduced somewhat
um but we'd be happy to try to address
that and send you some information chris
i don't know if you have any other
thoughts on that um
yeah having looked at that pretty
recently due to senate bill 71
and senate bill 115 which both address
uh greenhouse gas emissions the per
capita emissions for new hampshire are
significantly lower than some states in
the u.s because that accounts for
uh the large amount of
coal oil and that and yes gas extraction
that's occurring in those states such as
wyoming and some of the midwestern
states compared to the states in
new england
i think we actually are just behind
almost all of the other states with the
exception of maine
but i can pass that along but compared
to the rest of the other states on a per
capita basis new hampshire
is probably in the top third
in terms of performance
thank you
thank you for that information so um
what would be your uh suggestion on how
such a climate action plan for new
hampshire
um
would be effective
given information that i'm aware of at
least
as of since 2000 since the year 2000 up
to 2017
it appears that the us
as a nation had a 10 reduction in carbon
emissions
europe had mine had a 16 reduction but
at the same time
china had 208 percent increase in carbon
emissions and india had 155 increase in
carbon emissions so how would you
characterize a climate action plan for
new hampshire um
in terms of its effectiveness for
reducing carbon emissions given that the
u.s has apparently done a fairly decent
job so far since 2000
and certainly um i'm i'm not sure of the
source of of the information and and i i
won't question it certainly but um
i think that uh uh you know one of the
things that we look at is regional
activity uh and that and national
activity and we certainly um
believe that uh new hampshire needs to
play to play a role in uh the united
states continuing reduction of emissions
uh i
i do believe that the paris agreement
that
um
the united states was part of until
recently
uh and and most made
almost all every major
uh country and developing country in the
world as part of
does require certain reductions we may
have made reductions sooner than
than others but um reductions are
required uh of of those com countries i
i think it this needs to be looked at as
kind of an all hands on deck situation
every nation needs to
to do their part and we knew the united
states has been a major emitter for many
many years way beyond our and you know
on a per capita basis
um and
uh
so i think that we need to uh uh every
state all the new england states do our
part the the northeast as a region
represents about the 10th largest
economy in the world
um maybe even higher than that so
um i think i think it's a situation
where everyone needs to contribute
so thank you i just might add that that
data came from the global carbon budget
2018 report
yeah
again we don't question it i just i'm
not familiar with that particular data
okay thank you representative uh
samsic is recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you uh
mr fitzgerald and mr skoglen uh
uh
is is it your estimation uh based on
your your knowledge of this topic that
um
places like china and india that are now
big emitters of greenhouse gases
are also among the
the forefront now of developing
technologies to reduce those things in
the way of clean technologies uh is
isn't it true that a bill like this
would help us focus opportunities
business opportunities here in new
hampshire that we could make use of uh
to address these issues
well certainly the 2009 climate plan
that was developed by a bipartisan
commission of 29 members from around the
state with academic
leaders and
and
business and industry and
legislative and government
representatives and environmental
representatives it was quite a
cross-section and and very well
represented
the uh of the state came to the
conclusion that um there were
significant opportunities in addressing
climate change and the policies
you know in terms of developing
renewable energy
energy efficiency
other other types of programs presented
significant business opportunities
and i think i i i would agree i'm not an
expert and perhaps chris could could
address this a little bit more but i do
think that countries such as china um
are doing significant amounts of work
and
and working towards
significant
um
uh
you know plans for significant uh
uh climate emissions reductions
we we certainly have led the way at this
point in time chris do you have any
other
context for this
yeah and i can do a little bit more uh
digging into this but it is my
understanding that while china did see
considerable growth and overtook the us
as the largest
uh gross emitter of greenhouse gas
emissions as representative
thomas mentioned between 2000 and 2018
it's now currently uh the
the
growing and largest market for electric
vehicles in in the world in part because
of the size of their population but also
uh their significant investment um and
innovation occurring there there's also
a great deal of solar deployment
occurring there as they're ramping up um
so they also recognize that there's a
public health component there's been
reporting on the impacts of
the that growth from 2000 to 2018 which
was coal based and the impacts that had
on air quality public health and they're
now moving more towards
cleaner cars and cleaner energy
generation um and i believe their
five-gear plan that they released pretty
recently
is focusing on de-carbonization heavily
it does take a while to move an economy
that size
but they're moving towards plateauing
and then declining
follow-up mr chairman
all right follow-up
uh can you just confirm to me my
understanding of especially china that
china is currently the number one
producer of solar panels the number one
producer of electric vehicles and many
multi-million
population cities now have electric
buses
so the word confirm makes me a little
bit nervous um
that sounds consistent with what i have
been reading and i can look into that
and get back to you
thank you
okay representative mann is recognized
for a question
don't forget to thank you mr chair i
just finally figured that out
um i'm actually i'm going to make a
comment i guess i would ask
chris about what his feeling is about
this i'm surprised to see the concept of
energy efficiency
were missing from both the um
the aspect of
reducing greenhouse gases and also from
the
economic impact of so many jobs that
would would entail
and
also um
i had thought hopefully i guess
that
any department of energy would be kind
of merged with
the department of environmental services
since uh
energy issue um
i don't think is about having enough
energy it's really about what source of
energy we
we need to
switch to
so i'd be interested in your comments
um representative man i'll i'll address
that um
first uh
um you know i'm not sure
the first part of your question i
sounded to me like you were
asking why energy efficiency wasn't
addressed in this legislation is that
no no i'm just there was just i'm just
referring to the discussion so far we
haven't had any much mention of that
well we certainly see energy efficiency
as being being a critical part of
climate planning um
uh and
any climate plan including the one
produced in 2009 certainly significantly
addressed
that need here in new hampshire
um and uh relative to the department of
energy i think we uh we will not comment
on that that's the governor's as was
mentioned by representative votes that's
the governor's
purview um
as to uh how he wants to organize us
other states massachusetts and
connecticut in particular have emerged
uh environment energy department um but
that apparently is not the governor's
plan and and
i assume he'll be taking uh taking input
on that as that as this
that was an announcement in the budget
address and i'm not sure that
everything is fully fleshed out there
but that would be
certainly up to the governor's office
and how he constructs his budget
thank you very much
thank you the chair recognizes
representative callie pitts for a
question
don't forget to unmute
this is along the same thing but do you
believe that perhaps these goal settings
would be
better served in an energy commission
but that's where they should be
for the time being
i would
are you referring to the climate goals
that are in this in this bill yes sir
yeah
go ahead uh again that would be a policy
call uh for the legislative
uh legislature and the uh
uh the governor if he chooses to uh if
this bill moves forward and he chooses
to sign it um i think certainly um there
was as senator sherman mentioned uh over
the course of the fall and summer uh
summer and fall there was a uh
an ad hoc climate emissions commission
and there is legislation i believe over
in the uh
senate that would
create a a commission to
[Music]
address
the adoption of climate goals so
there would need to be some
reconciliation between this legislation
and that if they both move forward
and mike if
yes
could i add um
in the states like that have just
completed their climate planning uh such
as maine they established goals they
undertook a climate planning process as
is laid out
in i believe section
three
and four
but it was after they released the plan
just the in the past couple months
they're now
looking at that plan to determine
which policies does their legislature
need to put in place to actually move
forward that the plan itself has no
teeth and it's just a
process for considering what are the
opportunities what are the costs what
are the benefits how does it all fit
together to benefit the economy improve
public health and reduce greenhouse gas
emissions but it ultimately comes back
to the legislature for that
final implementation in statute to
determine um
which direction they ultimately would
like to move on based on what's in the
plan
okay thank you um
so seeing no more questions that will be
allowed for these two speakers i would
have my hand up the whole time
that's true but as i indicated at the
beginning of this public hearing if
you're a co-sponsor of the bill
um you won't be
unless we have time and right now we
have nine other people
signed up to speak and we have one
minute left in this public hearing
so
if we have time representative mcgee i
will get back to you
but right now we need to call on our
next speaker but before i do that since
the
clock just turned over to 10 o'clock i'm
going to
officially open the public hearing
on house bill
and then i'm going to recess that public
area mr chair before you recess
may ask a question how many people do we
have signed up for the next public
hearing the one you just opened
signed up to speak on the next public
hearing i think there's two
perhaps we could
with that in mind we could give a little
extra to this hearing and recognize that
the next one is going to be short but
just pay attention
thank you
all right so the next person that i'd
like to call on to speak is karen luther
she is a member of the public
representing her association which is
ehpba.org and i'm sure she will tell us
just exactly what that is
so
ms luther
thank you very much for having me today
i appreciate your time and attention
um on behalf of the northeast hearth
patio and barbecue association i'm i'm
here to testify in opposition as drafted
this house bill the northeast hearth
patio and barbecue association's a trade
association representing
40 individual more than 40 individual
members retail and related companies
through new hampshire supporting 350
families the vast majority of our
members are independent mom and pop
small businesses
who are significant community
contributors in the markets they serve
across the state
these are independent family owned
hearth shops in our there are regions
chimney sweeps installers maintenance
companies and any other entity having a
commercial interest in hearth and patio
barbecue
we recognize the changing landscape of
the energy and fossil fuel industry and
we're committed to working with
government officials and regulators at
all levels to increase access to more
sustainable and climate-centric fuel
sources
however moving quickly and rationally to
net zero
that eliminates fossil fuels could
result in skyrocketing electric rates
and potentially inhibit access to more
affordable sources of fuel and power
negatively affecting the most vulnerable
around us
nepa is very concerned with the
statement replacing fossil fuels with
zero emission sources of energy already
has already this season we've had three
weather related power outages that have
had homes and business owners relying on
gas and wood more importantly the
elimination of fossil fuels will
eliminate the last of these
aforementioned mom and pop family owned
and operated small businesses in the
state
the possible new jobs that may be
created are not transferable and would
not be available to these business
owners who rely on the sales and
installation in service of gas and wood
fueled heating and decorative appliances
the elimination of home heating oil
would be particularly burdensome and
expensive to taxpayers
we're concerned on multiple levels about
the hyper focus on electrification
currently in new hampshire 51 percent of
homes rely on fuel oil as the primary
heating source the second largest after
maine i have that source 19.8 percent of
homes are heated with util utility gas
and many homes in new hampshire use wood
heat as supplemental heating i also have
that source
allowing homeowners energy choice and
energy diversity
is important in the northeast where
below freezing temperatures and power
outages as a result of winter weather
are very common additionally natural gas
renewable natural gas and properly
burning wood can decrease emissions
allow for energy choice and keep costs
down
i also have the source regarding the
electric vehicles that was mentioned
earlier today in tesla volkswagen and
renault are the three high
largest manufacturers of electric cars
in the world and i can give you guys
that source if you're interested that
was just a side note
i thank you very much for your
consideration of my comments today and i
very much appreciate your time and thank
you all for what you are doing here
okay thank you very much mrs mister are
there any questions i see uh
representative samsitch has a question
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
miss luther for your testimony
as someone who actually has
grill and barbecue equipment that runs
on electricity
i don't see this as being that dangerous
for a business association
affiliated with these things but what
i'm curious about is you mentioned
that you expect skyrocketing electric
rates to happen uh because of this
legislation can you explain why that
would happen
well sure if there if there's an
elimination of fuel source right if you
go only to one fuel one
one seller there's that eliminates
competition in in the marketplace and
additionally
um it there's there's an enormous uh
fees of tap taxes on electricity at this
point
um
but but it
it's basically based on the fact of
eliminating competition right and also
municipalities and states devise their
own electric plants and can then control
the cost of of that electricity without
a competitive market
follow up mr chairman
uh well
i i hear what you're saying but you know
our utilities are regulated utilities
they all get their electricity from a
wholesale market in new england uh those
rates are
the ultimate rates are going to be
determined by the cost of energy and
that doesn't look like it's going to
skyrocket anytime soon i i'm kind of
surprised about your comment uh that's
that's that's a that's a comment that's
a consideration across the country with
the with the um concern for
electrification and i would be so happy
to um to to give you to just be able to
send you some resources and some some uh
some some information that we have on
that with sources
okay thank you very much
how how can i i can find your your email
address
website correct
that's correct happy to get back to you
and thank you so much for the question
thank you
thank you the chair recognizes
representative thomas for a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um
i guess my question uh
filter to
further your point
uh
your
statement about
rising electric costs would be cost
prohibitive to certain people
um
just like would you would you
my example that i'm going to give you is
this the type of example that that you
refer to for instance a month and a half
ago
i tried to heat my home with more of my
electric heaters and electric um
baseboards to see what would happen and
i came out with a 510 electric bill
following month i took them off and went
back my propane heat and i was paying
about two hundred dollars for my
electric heats is this type of example
that you were referring to about the
huge cost of electricity that could
occur that's exactly correct um because
the it's
it's well known that electric heat is
just not as efficient and below 30
degrees i also have these sources for
you if anybody is interested below 30
degrees heat pumps
are are very inefficient without an
alternate and or a supplemental source
of heat
and is very expensive to heat a home in
new england in these cold temperatures
with only electric
thank you representative partial was
recognized for a question
yes i do need to ask your source for
your uh heat exchange i got my heat
exchange unit works down to 13 below
and it heats my house efficiently
for equivalent of what representative
thompson
thomas says his house heated for
i would also question you lumping
bumping a wooden uh with your other
fossil fuels as what is generally
considered to be carbon neutral
yeah it is i thank you for saying that i
appreciate that um and i'm glad that you
understand that a lot of legislature i
did put i did add that in and you're
right
and um because a lot of times when this
conversation starts uh it ends up
eventually evolving in in including wood
and i'm i'm very happy that you that you
said that and i thank you for making
that point
and the point about your heat exchanges
i i i can't i can't even imagine that
that heat so i i want to know the the
manufacturer but
it's it's well known i mean in new in
burlington i'm suspicious of well-known
i have to say no listen uh sorry i
didn't mean to interrupt you uh in in
burlington vermont they built a an
apartment building that relied solely on
heat pumps it was all electric and in
december they couldn't get the interior
temperature above 30 degrees fahrenheit
and had to evacuate the apartment
building
last last year
okay thank you very much see no further
questions for ms luther i'd like to call
on the next speaker
oh i'm sorry
uh representative pleasure has a
question
thank you mr chair uh
through you mr chairman could we ask mr
luther to send me your
information i don't see i have any
information i i actually just emailed
you um
my written testimony
actually i did not hit send house
science technology
lead
yes that's the address perfect i just
hit send you're all it should be there
okay thank you
thank you very much for your time i
appreciate it
thank you we appreciate it too thank you
very much for uh talking to us today so
we'll call on our next speaker now who
is
justin cates a member of the public
who's representing the city of nashua
and the new hampshire office of energy
management
that seems like a lot of
a lot of folks to represent but mr cates
go ahead you have three minutes
thanks uh just as a clarification of the
city of natural office of emergency
management not affiliated with the state
energy management
so my name is justin kates i'm the
director of emergency management for the
city of nashville and my area of
expertise is in dealing with the
consequences of the extreme
precipitation events flooding drought
heat waves
many of the other perils that are
discussed in this bill
there's many that are more qualified to
discuss the sources and impacts of
greenhouse gas emissions as well as the
health and financial benefits of
reducing these emissions but what i want
to comment on today is the opportunity
to use greenhouse goals in conjunction
with a robust climate action plan that
invests in strategies to promote a more
disaster resilient new hampshire
in 2018 in the city of nashville we led
a community-wide resilient nashua
initiative which updated our hazard
mitigation plan and identified long-term
strategies to prepare for future climate
risks while reducing greenhouse gas
emissions and this plan recommended the
adoption of the nashua energy and
environment committee's goals which
included a reduction of
school municipal building and
infrastructure greenhouse gas emissions
by 25 by 2025 the reduction of municipal
vehicle emissions by 25 percent by 2025
and the school municipal system will
derive 100 of its energy from renewable
clean energy sources by 2050 and these
goals were adopted by the mayor and
board of aldermen in 2019 and we're now
working towards the city's master plan
update which includes an overarching
priority to protect the climate
when we look at this topic we typically
break the strategies down into two areas
climate mitigation and climate
adaptation and climate mitigation looks
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions while
climate adaptation looks to adjust and
modify our behaviors and built
environment to deal with the coming
health and safety hazards exacerbated by
climate change
climate adaptation has been and will
continue to be very expensive there are
some benefits to adaptation especially
when considering the use of natural
solutions such as green storm water
strategies to support our aging storm
water infrastructure but overall it's
challenging to get an immediate positive
return on adaptation investments when
you think about it you're replacing
retrofitting and even removing
infrastructure and buildings
that may function perfectly fine under
our current normal conditions something
that many are going to have heartburn
over
that's why during the resilient natural
initiative we discovered that the
majority of our adaptation investment
would likely be on new and end-of-life
span construction projects or during
reconstruction after a disaster and the
common example is when a culvert has
reached the end of its life we'll see if
it needs to be built to pass more water
through or if it's damaged during a
flood we'll see
if that's an opportunity to build it
back better and adaptation is necessary
but we'll continue to build stronger
buildings and infrastructure to deal
with these hazardous conditions
on the other hand climate mitigation
does have the opportunity to provide
significant co-benefits particularly in
the creation of a secure and resilient
energy system here in the granite state
the new hampshire climate action plan
could leverage substantial opportunities
to mitigate emissions using distributed
renewable energy
and energy efficient appliances and
services
and when we think about if we look at
the construction of renewable energy
sources plus battery storage there's an
opportunity to create distributed energy
so that we're less reliant on uh the
normal energy systems
thank you do we have any questions for
mr cates i see representative sams that
you're recognized for a question
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
mr kate for taking my question um uh i
i'm really impressed by the the the um
forward movement that the city of nashua
is doing and i can understand how you
have uh you have to make some priorities
of what what you can and cannot do could
you explain to us a little bit of how
the city of nashua is funding these
efforts
so it depends on the circumstance and
what type of investments being made for
many of the renewable energy sources
solar panels on roofs of municipal
buildings
that's being funded through city funding
we would expect that in the
coming years there may be additional
federal grant opportunities to pay for
some of these types of capabilities but
right now we're funding this through
municipal budget
thank you
chair
uh
chair recognizes representative homura
for a question
yes thank you chair and uh thank you for
presenting your information i'm actually
a hazard mitigation plan reviewer so i
appreciate what you do as an emergency
manager very much uh the one question i
had is that you had mentioned that
nashua actually contends obviously with
precipitation issues i'm assuming
flooding issues can you tell me if the
city of nashua has been able to
utilize any projects through the hmgp
program the grant program federal grant
program
uh we have we have not um we've applied
in the past for funding through hmgp
that has a mitigation grant program uh
but the the challenging problem that we
deal with is in many cases the areas
where we're seeing impacts to culverts
and other um infrastructure around
floodways uh the benefit cost analysis
doesn't allow for us to replace those
components of infrastructure uh with a
significant benefit to uh the financial
impacts of the city so we never
typically are able to
to receive those grants because there
are other projects around the state
that are are better investments for that
grant program
thank you chair and thank you very much
for answering that question um if you
haven't really seen a positive bca on
some of these hmgp grants i'm just
wondering
how you see
more long-term esoteric
mitigation through this bill
well i think the number one area that we
would look at when talking about in my
case distributed renewable energy is uh
there's an ability to leverage
uh
as an example solar plus battery storage
at our critical municipal facilities
that have a daily financial
uh as well as
resilience impact
those systems would be used every day
in comparison to something that might be
funded through a hazard mitigation
program like this standby generator
which would sit there and not be used
unless there's a power outage so
the the reason we're focusing on on
concepts like we're talking about today
is is there's a benefit
daily that we can leverage these systems
uh the co benefits are significant in
comparison to
uh tearing out a component of
infrastructure to replace it with
something that will deal with
hazardous conditions in the future
thank you
thank you representative samsich is
recognized for a question
i'm sorry mr chairman i didn't take my
hand down
okay thank you all right well we thank
you mr gates for your testimony we have
six more people to go
and the chair now recognizes
and i apologize if i mispronounce your
name
elenka grondo
member of the public representing new
hampshire high school democrat democrats
miss rondo you're
recognized to speak
thank you all
my name is
16 years old and i live in bedford your
volume is very very low is there any
chance you could get closer to the
microphone or increase your volume
is this any better
not much keep trying
um let's see
i might try to connect a speaker let me
see if that will work
well give it a shot we'll give you two
minutes and uh hopefully we can hear
some of what you want to say
can you hear me better now oh much
better much better oh wonderful thank
you okay you have two minutes
my name is alinka i am 16 years old and
i live in bedford i'm glad to be here to
voice my support for hb172
i'm representing the new hampshire high
school democrats and my full testimony
has been emailed to you
it is extremely concerning for our state
that data from the national oceanic and
atmospheric administration shows new
england to be one of the fastest warming
regions in the country
new hampshire's average temperatures
have increased by nearly 3 degrees
fahrenheit in comparison to 20th century
levels
changing climates have enabled invasive
species to migrate to and thrive in new
hampshire's water and land disrupting
the balance of our ecosystems and sea
level rise due to climate change is
posed to ravage our sea coast
the good news is that we have the
frameworks the plans the technology and
the science to address the climate
crisis
i want to emphasize that climate change
is more than just a political issue
it is an issue impacting what kind of
future i and all other youth will be
able to aspire to
the science has been clear for decades
exxonmobil knew about the severe
environmental dangers of fossil fuels
long before i was born they commissioned
a study on it in 1979
and yet though we know it is effectively
a death sentence for our planet
eventually we have continued to allow
emissions to go unchecked at the
unprecedented global rate of 40 billion
tons per year
if we neglect to take action i will be
only 25 when it is estimated that the
damage from climate change will be
irreversible
by the time i'm old enough to run for
office myself it could be too late
30 seconds this is my third year in a
row testifying for environmental
legislation and my second year
submitting testimony for a bill creating
a climate action plan i will keep coming
back year after year however long it
takes until i see action because i know
that passing legislation like this as
well as increasing funding to relevant
departments will enable the change we
need for our state my generation and our
planet thank you
thank you very much we appreciate your
testimony here today
uh representative thompson you have your
hand up is that for real
yes it is mr chairman you're recognized
for a question
thank you very much
uh and uh thank you and miss andrando
for coming to testify
um
it's always refreshing and uh
encouraging for all of us to hear from
young people testifying and making this
effort um
however it's also important that
everybody take personal responsibility
for these things so i'd like to ask you
whether what you and your peers are
doing to take action on your own
uh
talking to your parents or making
improvements in your home or doing other
behaviors that will benefit our
environment
absolutely thank you for that question
my peers are all very concerned about
climate change and we've been organizing
particularly on the legislative front to
make sure our voices are heard
on these bills i've also organized two
climate marches in the past years that
have brought hundreds of people from
across the state together to advocate
for the climate
i personally have switched to a lot of
zero-waste alternatives i carry reusable
alternatives to things like straws and
bags with me wherever i go and have also
been discussing with my parents about
energy efficiency alternatives for our
house in the future
i think one thing that we've all really
been focusing on is
learning more ourselves because
occasionally
the climate crisis is not taught in
school so
this is something that many of my peers
are passionate about and educating
ourselves and others about and hoping to
see action on in the future
uh follow up mr chairman
thank you uh miss strondau are you aware
of the fact that everyone including your
parents or any resident in new hampshire
can now choose
to get
energy supply that is 100 renewable by
choosing an energy supplier on the pucs
website
i have heard of that and i've actually
brought it up to my parents it's
something we're looking into
thank you thank you
thank you uh representative mann is
recognized for a question
[Music]
thank you mr chairman um would you
believe
i have two grandchildren about your uh
probably about um
linka's age and i would just want to
make the comment
because you believe that i take uh
i take the future for people that have
to live in the future which i
representative man at the beginning of
our session we talked about
not allowing would you believe questions
if you have a real legitimate question
i will allow you to ask it but would you
believe questions are not
acceptable
you have to unmute yourself i can't do
it
i just wanted to say i take uh because
of my grandchildren on their behalf i
take this issue very personally thank
you
okay
all right so you know further questions
for this uh
testifier we'll move on to our next uh
speaker who will be
yes our next speaker will be kendra ward
kendra ford i'm sorry
a member of the public
representing herself so miss ford you're
recognized to speak
thank you for recognizing me
i'm rev kendra ford and i serve the
first unitarian universalist society in
exeter
that is a congregation that has been
working on climate issues for
well for as long as i've been there
which is 19 years
and this morning as i'm talking to you
the solar panels on the roof of my house
are humming along creating the
electricity that lets me
talk to you today
and i
so appreciate the climate science that
has been
read into this hearing
it's
so important to hear all of that science
but i want to talk about love and how
much this bill is about preserving the
world that we love
preserving
the new hampshire that we love
preserving skiing in new hampshire
preserving the beaches that we love in
new hampshire preserving the apple crop
in new hampshire
preserving the blueberry crop in new
hampshire
all of those things have been harmed
already by climate change
we love those things where
we need to take this action
i live in portsmouth and i walk by a
tidal pond
many times a week and i
and i can see as the sea levels rise
um the businesses and the homes that
will be affected by that rising water
and so
this bill
says that we love this coast in this
town and that we want to take action to
change that and i think that we need the
discipline of um and the accountability
of shared laws
to help us mitigate that damage
in our state and in our world we're
hearing more and more climate events
around the world and we want to be part
of solving that problem
i am keenly aware that one of the things
that will have to happen for us to meet
these carbon goals is that we will have
to stop burning coal in new hampshire
15 seconds
thank you
and that that will mean creating good
jobs for people
for the future
i appreciate your consideration of this
issue
okay thank you very much are there any
questions for ms ward i see one
representative sampson you recognize
this question
thank you mr chairman and thank you miss
for testifying
uh as a pastor
do you think there is also a moral and
religious obligation component
to this issue
uh that
all of us should consider
absolutely
i think the the moral and religious
issue
comes down to love which is why i spoke
about love
um i think
all of the world religions teach us to
love our neighbor and to love the world
and if we're going to do that we have to
take good and thoughtful care of it
thank you very much
thank you um
[Music]
representative
jackie kelly fitz you're recognized for
a question
i wanted to ask quickly was
i understand your uh
point on stewardship but what will this
do to people who cannot
reduce
carbon emissions
such as people in apartments and
where there's going to be no will this
have an effect on them
the goals we set
the goals we set will have to affect
absolutely everyone and that's why we
have to do the work together we can't
send people off to solve problems
individually and that's that's why we
make laws so that we do things together
and make the choices together and
support people who will have uh meet
more challenges in making this change
okay thank you
uh see no more no more questions from ms
ford
i will recognize the next speaker okay
this can't have her hand up
who's speaking
this is jacking does cat have her hand
up
all i can see is a big letter j i can't
uh no no that
well that's me and and you know
this cat have her hand up
i do i'm leaving it up i'm a co-sponsor
he's going to let me speak about you're
just leaving it up okay
okay so we're ready to move on i guess
so i'd like to call on our next speaker
who is judith som a member of the public
representing herself so miss some the
floor is yours for two minutes
thank you chairman vas good morning
to you all for the record my name is
judith psalm
i am a voter in romney and i do not
represent any organization
my husband and i consider ourselves
climate migrants
we locate relocated from new hampshire
to new hampshire from reno nevada in
2018 because of the increasing climate
change related wildfires
and because the associated smoke was
impacting our health and our quality of
life
sometimes there were weeks at a time
when we could not spend any time
outdoors
because of the smoke
i suffered from sinus infections we had
difficulty breathing
and
after living decades in the west and for
my husband he left lived his whole life
in the west we decided we had to leave
while we did not expect to escape
climate change entirely by moving to new
hampshire we are alarmed
to see climate climate change happening
so quickly here
during last summer's drought
we became aware that wildflower
wildfires are a significant threat in
this state as well
we also understand that the new
hampshire moose population is
sadly diminishing due to a tick species
that thrives because of climate change
local farmers who serve our community uh
such as our neighbors
down the road at longview farm now are
struggling to grow produce with the
climate change-related weather extremes
like drought flooding and the terrible
hail storm that occurred last summer
my husband and i recently viewed the
beautiful netflix documentary called the
life on our planet by david attenborough
the famed naturalist
in which he explores the mass
destruction of species during his
lifetime in relation to the increase of
atmospheric carbon
mr attenborough's take-home message is
that the issue is no longer about saving
species saving the planet
the primary issue is about saving
ourselves
as he points out
we must take action to drastically
reduced reduce greenhouse gas emissions
while we still have time
therefore i urge you to support hb 172 i
would point out that comparable
legislation has been already passed in
other states with bipartisan support
including in nevada which made it a law
in 2019.
so again please support this legislation
and move it forward thank you for your
time
okay we'll now move on to our next
speaker who is
joseph krasnick
you have two minutes
you need to unmute yourself yes i'm
there can you hear me now mr chairman
yes
thank you um i'm today offering oral
testimony to uh
in support of house bill 172 i've also
submitted written testimony
my reason for support of the bill are as
follows house bill 172 requires new
hampshire to establish a climate action
plan that will reset
public policy among other requirements
to reduce statewide greenhouse gas
emissions
the plan will also set goals and
actually inventory greenhouse gas
emissions will be key which will be key
in reducing greenhouse gas emissions
saying these reductions are necessary if
there's any chance for new hampshire to
begin to meet the climate change
emergency of the state of new hampshire
now and will face into the future
failure to meet these reductions within
the prescribed schedules will certainly
present our citizens with a
progressively degraded environment
research by our university scientists
indicates that we're currently
experiencing climate change with shorter
winters warmer summers
rising sea levels and unpredictable
rainfall and drought conditions
all these factors contribute to a
degraded environment here and now
the impact of these changes currently
cause adverse impacts including
financial on new hampshire's
agricultural production
tourism industry and our seasonal sports
attractions
and these adverse impacts will continue
to worse into the future
after a number of fall spa starts over
the last decade it is time for new
hampshire to begin to take meaningful
action to meet the challenge of climate
change
this legislation is desperately needed
especially in light of the current
proposals in the legislature to either
delay or dilute rational and worthwhile
initiatives such as the energy
efficiency resource standard in the
renewable portfolio standard
thank you for your time today and this
bill is needed now and should pass thank
you i will take questions
thank you
you succeeded in testifying in a minute
35 seconds
practice makes perfect
okay thank you uh representative samsich
is recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
kwasnik for your testimony
uh can you tell us uh in any way that
climate change has impacted you directly
uh yes from the recreational point of
view it has i'm a skier
both cross country and alpine and we're
finding that the winters winters are
quite becoming shorter
the ski season is starting later in the
year and ending earlier in the year
so that's an impact on me i also um
do quite a bit of hiking and i am
terribly concerned about the infestation
of ticks and other invasive species that
have now invaded our our state uh as a
child that never occurred or even
came across these types of species
before so we're seeing just an
incredible migration of invasive species
not only plant but also animal
and insect into our communities so yes
had a lot of impact on me
thank you very much thank you
okay see no
further questions um
we will move to our
last speaker of the day
or the last speaker of this bill anyway
there were two people signed up
a sheila vargas and a
mary dean
who don't actually appear to be
available mr chair i believe elinda
terwilliger is also standing by
linda terwilliger
she's not on my list of speakers
so i'll recognize the last speaker of
the day that's um
mr gage
representing
i can't remember the name of the
organization but he'll tell us and mr
gage you have two minutes and two
minutes exactly
thank you chairman and thank you
committee members of the science
technology energy committee for hearing
my testimony in favor of hp 172. i'm
here as a private citizen but i'm also
the state coordinator for new hampshire
citizens climate lobby a grassroots
nonpartisan organization working to help
create the political will to enable
congress to legislate cash back carbon
pricing to efficiently and equitably
reduce climate pollution in the us and
around the world
i'd like to provide some insight into
national and global factors that provide
support for this bill
to help avoid government waste
we ignore the changing global energy
market
at our peril um we will make bad
decisions and poor investments if we
don't pay attention to major changes
that are happening beyond our control
that will affect us but first i would
like to respond to representative
thomas's question about what would it
matter if new hampshire goes to next
zero
or not
while it's true that our emissions
are a small percentage of the whole
um if everybody thinks the same way
noble nobody would reduce their
emissions so
ignoring your own pollution is called
free loading or free riding
it's just not a responsible way to
behave um
but even more than that the us is
responsible for 25 percent of global
climate pollution that's in the air
right now
we developed our industry burning fossil
fuels
the world has paid from our pollution in
his pain
but we have a bigger than average
responsibility
per capita uh the u.s is four times more
polluting than average um comparing us
to climate china is interesting the
average american pollutes twice as much
carbon pollution as the average person
in china
and then there are 100 million people in
china that still don't have any power so
while china plugs those power into the
grid um they are trying to reduce
emissions but they obviously have a
different problem than we do
the ipcc world bank world economic forum
all say a carbon price is needed to
address this global pollution problem
that is moving forward rapidly
james uh
janet yellen the treasury secretary
says we need carbon fee and dividend
thank you mr gage we appreciate your
testimony and uh we will read your
voluminous written testimony as part of
the
record for this
for this public hearing
and so with that seeing no more uh
speakers lined up mr chairman i have my
hands raised
uh of course representative uh sans that
you recognize for a question
uh thank you mr chairman
uh mr gage uh and thank you for taking
my question uh i if i'm not mistaken
your organization has been affiliated
with a
a carbon pricing plan that is bipartisan
on both political sides and economic
side can you say something about that is
that correct
that is correct thank you very much for
your question
um yes so the organization is 14 years
old they found this policy called carbon
fee and dividend with board adjustments
about 10 years ago we've been lobbying
congress to introduce it
it has been introduced as a bipartisan
bill with 87 co-sponsors it will reduce
u.s emissions by 40 percent in 12 years
and 90 percent and 30 by putting a
steadily increasing price on carbon
emissions at the source by charging
fossil fuels thank you you answered
representative samsich's question so
thank you
thank you mr
okay
so having exhausted our list of speakers
for this public hearing which is now
38 or 39 minutes
beyond its end date or it's in time i
will close the public hearing on hb 172
and announce to the
assembled multitudes here that 296
people signed up to support the bill 13
signed up
in opposition and two
were signed up to be neutral
and uh so with that we closed the
hearing on hb
and we moved to the next bill
which
whose public hearing i opened at
ten o'clock and then recess we will now
come out of recess on hb
487 and i will recommend recognize the
sponsor of the bill
which is about establishing an
information technology supply chain risk
authority
nice representative samsich to introduce
the bill
mr chairman can i have a point of order
please
certainly what's your point of order
my my question was not to add any
testimony to the bill my question was
whether there needed to be an fn on the
last bill which i think
i was going to pose that question to the
department of environmental services
because their testimony included not
only a consultant but three ftes so my
question is a really a process or
technical one which is whether or not
house bill 172 requires an fn
thank you
thank you to that question
i can't answer that question typically
ols
is the agency that decides whether a
bill needs a fiscal note or not
uh since they did not make that judgment
on the bill when they drafted it
i assume it doesn't really need one but
i appreciate the question
so now i'll recognize uh representatives
sausage to introduce house bill 487
uh thank you mr chairman
and uh
thank you committee members for allowing
me this opportunity to introduce hb 487
my original intent for this for the
introduction of this bill was based on
my concerns regarding the security of
our state's state government's networks
as well as the products and services
that the state of new hampshire is
procuring
uh approximately two years ago i worked
with the state's director for it dennis
goulet
on a bill
since passed by governor sununu and
signed
that prohibited the state agencies from
using software developed by kaspersky
lab
kaspersky lab software is most
frequently used as an antivirus and
cyber security protection
at that time many state agencies
throughout the country as well as
the us government were in fact still
using that software
recently i have been become aware of a
number of products and services being
offered by companies
associated with governments that have
been accused of cyber security and
hacking threats against the u.s
government and governments abroad
such countries include the people's
republic of china russia north korea and
iran
the main attraction for such products
and services has been the fact that they
are offer often offered at a
considerably lower price than their
competition
um
i i discussed these concerns
i discussed these concerns with director
goulet who confirmed who informed me
that his department had been working on
these issues and would be willing to
suggest elements that they felt were
important to include in any such bill
his department worked with the ols to
draft the bill before you today
however upon closer scrutiny and based
on more recent cyber security threats it
is the opinion of his i.t department
that the bill before you today is not
yet ready to be acted on uh director
goulet will be testifying and explaining
his reasoning for this today
however based on his recommendation i
i'll be asking this committee to vote to
retain this bill until further
improvements can be made to it
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you today
thank you representative samsich for
introducing the bill
i have a question for you you said that
you
wanted to
request that the committee retain the
bill
um
while we haven't heard yet from mr
goulet
about it the bill's shortcomings and
what kind of improvements could be made
is it possible that it might be
better to ipl the bill and then bring a
new bill forward in
um
well mr chairman i'm not sure about that
i'd like to hear also from uh director
goulet
uh he was the one who had suggested the
retaining motion but uh i i can see your
point
okay i will ask that question of mr
goulet and i will now recognize mr way
to speak mr delay you have the floor and
welcome to ste
good morning uh mr chair and members of
the committee um
it's great to be with you virtually um
looking forward to doing it in person
soon
um i will first want to thank uh
representative samsich for his
leadership in this important issue
um i t supply chain issues are
are
with us and look like they will be with
us for the future
the
kaspersky legislation that we worked on
together
was
you know a true example of a contained
i.t supply chain issue
and when representative samsift came to
us we we talked about what we're doing
in the state already in this space
and we have been for about six months
now working with the department of
administrative services and the attorney
general's office
to work on um changes to our procurement
methodologies
that would allow us to filter out um and
manage to uh against supply chain risk
as part of the technology procurement
process
and although that's a good step and we
will keep doing that
i think we you know in the end we should
have legislation
and i thought that at this time was the
right time to do that
and was looking forward to working on
said legislation with uh representative
samsich however since then the solar
winds attack has happened
we are still at this moment learning
about how that was executed
and
but there are significant parts of it
that are not yet public they're being
withheld by the federal government
under top secret status
so
we're thinking that um you know the
world that we thought we lived in isn't
the world we actually are in with
respect to ig supply chain risk
so at this time
it's my feeling that we could retain or
itl
that i'm ambivalent on that whatever the
committee would would
prefer
and that i continue to work with
administrative services
in the
ag's office on language in requests for
proposal and final contracts
that
begin to address this issue but we also
work on language we i will take
responsibility for
working on an evolving language over the
next year or so so in the next session
perhaps we can have something we'd be
comfortable with that would would better
address the new realities we live in
as it relates to the new kinds of
threats we're seeing from foreign actors
as it relates to i.t supply chain risk
that concludes my formal testimony and
i'm ready for questions
thank you mr goulet we really appreciate
you being here and testifying today so
if i understood what you said correctly
you think that it could take
as long as a year to get the language
for this bill correct
and therefore you wouldn't
object to an itl
motion on this bill for this year so we
can bring a fresh bill forward next year
that is correct sir
okay well good i appreciate you being
candid about that uh we do have an
extremely
crowded
schedule for dealing with retained bills
we've retained quite a few already
and i know we will be retaining several
more so
we have to be very very careful that we
don't
retain so many bills that we get totally
overwhelmed with work
during a fairly short
period of time that we have allocated
for doing that work so we appreciate
that
and
i asked the committee does anybody have
any additional questions that they would
like to address through
mr goulet or to
mr
representative sausage
seeing none it looks like we can
call this public hearing to a close
before doing that i'll report that
11 people signed in to support the bill
two signed in to oppose it including mr
lay
and daniel wolf also signed in an
elected official
[Music]
and with that we'll close the public
hearing on hb 487
since we have approximately 10 minutes
before the next public hearing
i would like to take
a five minute break
so
we'll see everybody back here in a few
minutes
oh you did
that's got to be the quickest five
minutes in the world
richardson
i'm glad i know i have a boyfriend since
valentine's is coming up
jewelry will do
make sure
are you okay
representative vincent
everything okay now
i had technical difficulties yes
yeah
everyone
everything okay with the house and then
you and
well we're still working on the house
i gotta tell you what i think you came
in
i had some people come in on monday and
work and they left the door open
today the guy died and now you know
that's why
[Music]
the hand of god popping up in your
mountain
oh
[Music]
i can't control that but oh is that you
in the green screen i see a green
screamer no that's you know what he is
that little birdie seen this guy in the
screen in the background
that's representative
i went by a house yesterday
i was here
yeah i went by a house i went over to
see um
sherry marquis mother that lives down
the street
okay
it is now
11 o'clock
and so
i will call
to order the public hearing on house
bill three
niner six
relative to credits for certain energy
production not issued renewable energy
certificates that's an awkward sentence
so we would like to call on the bill's
prime sponsor who is representative
oxidom to introduce the bill
representative
before is yours for five minutes
thank you very much mr chair thank you
colleagues renewable energy certificates
known as rex represent the energy
generated by renewable energy sources
one wreck represents one megawatt hour
of electricity generation
wrecks can be bought and sold but once
sold the renewable attributes of that
energy production are transferred from
the seller to the buyer
purchasing rex supports the renewable
energy market by providing a demand
signal to the market which in turn
encourages greater supply of renewable
energy
in this way wrecks not only help towns
businesses and individuals meet their
greenhouse gas emission goals they also
encourage the generation of more
renewable energy
however in new hampshire we have enabled
a unique and i would suggest a uniquely
perverse mechanism to operate and that
is known as wreck
sweeping
rec sweeping allows new hampshire
electric providers to seize without
payment and without their knowledge the
renewable energy attributes produced by
other new hampshire businesses and
residents
and to use those wrecks to meet the
utilities or the generators own
renewable portfolio standard obligations
this practice constitutes a government
seizure
and transfer of private property without
just compensation and therefore violates
the fifth amendment of the u.s
constitution
and also part one article 12 of the new
hampshire constitution
passing h.b 396 would abolish the rec
sweeping provision currently in rsa 362
f6
and it would put an end to this serious
infringement of new hampshire's citizens
constitutional rights
so-called rec sweeping allows the
electricity producer to claim the wrecks
of renewable energy self-generation
from those residents and businesses who
choose not to register their wrecks
this means new hampshire residents
cannot claim or represent their
self-produced electric energy output is
renewable
not even the portion they physically
consume for their own use behind the
meter
this deprives the wreck markets of their
largest source of demand the utilities
and electricity generators who have rps
obligations
so as a result not only are our citizens
our towns and our businesses losing
their property rights but we've also
wrecked the wreck market
because we no longer have effective
demands and sometimes these wrecks sell
for as low as five dollars a wreck
whereas in other markets they've ranged
of course with market conditions prices
fluctuate but it's not unknown from them
to be in the hundreds of dollars
depriving private persons and entities
of the renewable energy attributes of
their own renewable generation deprives
them of a property right with real world
financial value indeed the federal trade
commission regulations make it illegal
for businesses to market themselves as
using renewable energy if they do not
keep control of the renewable energy
attributes associated with the wreck
this is true even when the business uses
the physical electricity from that
renewable generation to power its own
operations
if that business sells or otherwise
loses ownership by sweeping of its
renewable attributes it loses the right
to claim it's using renewable energy
so this rec sweeping provision actually
exposes new hampshire business owners to
legal jeopardy
in addition to depriving them of their
property without their knowledge and
without compensation
in summary
by seizing the renewable energy
attributes of new hampshire residents
and businesses own renewable generation
the current version of the statute
deprives them of their property rights
to their own renewable energy and bars
them from legally marketing themselves
as renewable energy users a valuable
attribute in today's market
worse it deprives them of these
financially valuable property rights
again without their knowledge and
without compensation
this is an uncompensated seizure of
private property affected by state power
under the statute and it's a blatant
violation of both our state and
constitutional rights
the general court should pass h.b 396
and abolish this unconstitutional
practice of wrecked sweeping
in order to protect the property and
constitutional rights of new hampshire
residents
thank you very much
well congratulations representative you
did it in five minutes and three seconds
congratulations last time was three and
a half minutes
i wasn't going to cut you off because we
have no other speakers uh registered to
speak but
i'm i'm impressed that you did it so
accurately
thank you very much mr chair uh
representative homila is recognized for
a question
yes sure thank you and thank you rex
representative oxenham for taking my
question
i just want to make sure i understand
what you said correctly were you saying
that these unused wrecks
are
available
for sweeping
because the individuals did not choose
to register these wrecks did i
understand that correctly yes indeed so
i personally have a solar array on my
roof i do not choose to register those
wrecks because i have them because i
want to keep them as my renewable energy
i
until i got an electric vehicle i was
able to meet all of my electrical needs
from renewable energy that was something
i felt was a worthwhile investment i had
since discovered that my renewable
energy attributes have been likely swept
up by someone else who's been
using them for financial gain without my
knowledge without any compensation and i
am by no means alone any person
not registering their wrecks who seeks
to keep them themselves for their own
purposes as is their right they paid the
money they invested in the equipment
it's theirs
yes
okay
the chair following follow up uh the the
only other comment i had to that is that
if
if that's if the system is in place
where people have to register them
then isn't that when they choose not to
isn't that sort of implicit permission
that things can be done with them what
they're done
let's see if i had a cattle ranch and i
didn't register my cattle and somebody
came took my cattle
would not would i be remiss and not
having registered them well if there's a
program i'm just asking because i again
there's no we're not talking about
cattle registering we're talking about
this i'm just curious again i'm just
trying to understand so i appreciate it
thank you
but if a part of the program is that you
have to register
these wrecks in order to not have them
swept then people who choose not to do
that are
in some ways implicitly giving their
permission to have them
swept
i
i i hear your words but i i don't it it
makes no sense to me okay thank you so
much for your time okay thank you
representative cam grills is recognized
for a question thank you mr chairman and
uh thank you representative oxenham
is there a reason why you wouldn't
register your ex i'm trying to
understand that why wouldn't all the
individuals
register their wrecks
the when i
again sorry for falling back on my
personal experience when i purchased my
system i was told that i could register
my wrecks if i wanted to participate in
the wreck market i had no interest in
participating in a wreck market so i did
not register my system it
this is you know it was a voluntary it's
open to you to register if you so wish
why would you do so to participate in
the wreck market if you don't want to
participate in the wreck market no one
is there's no one is telling you that
you are at risk
of losing your property rights to your
renewable energy production
there's no government program that's out
there telling you there's no private
solar developer that's telling you you
don't find out about this it's going on
without your knowledge and other people
are
making a financial a substantial
financial gain
the other part about this is that the
renewable energy fund is solely funded
by the alternative compliance payments
alternative compliance payments are what
the utilities and the electricity
generators have to pay if they can't
find enough wrecks well guess what
they're not finding any problem finding
wrecks because they're sweeping them and
not paying for them
and as a result our renewable energy
fund has been steadily
year after year uh diminishing we have
fewer dollars available to provide to
businesses and towns and individuals in
any incentive mechanisms because we've
allowed our wreck market to be wrecked
by this
as far as
unauthorized seizure of private property
follow-up yes mr chairman thank you i i
thank you for
i understand your point what you're
saying
my question to you is
uh is there any negative impact to you
using yourself as an example is there
any negative impact to you
for registering your own um your own
credits
i know that there's
in fact i if i could hand that question
off to someone who i know has sold his
wrecks and has gone through the process
which is uh representative samsich
to me it it's it's more of a
you know when i was studying economics i
used to teach economics we called it a
psychic quasi-rent you have a
you you experience a benefit
by
it's like living in new hampshire we
we derive psychic quasi rents from the
beauty and the wonder of living in new
hampshire can you put a price tag on
that no but you receive a value by
living in new hampshire that's what
renewable energy production is for me
that's the value
okay thank you um we'll allow
representative samsich to share his
experiences in the rec program in just a
few minutes but first i recognize
representative callie pitts for a
question
representative i'm having a hard time
understanding
i remember this discussion clearly when
we
we voted that they could aggregate
we call it sleep we'll call it vacuum
we'll call it whatever you want the
wrecks from people who have not claimed
them
do you know
now
how many
wrecks
your system produces
yes
i have a 6.9 kilowatt system
and
because it's facing more
west no more south
it's facing more west than it is facing
south it doesn't have the world's
greatest production so i get i would if
i were involved in this market i would
be entitled to about five wrecks
even though people with smaller systems
are entitled to more wrecks but if we
ever get time of used pricing
my system is going to
function better because of that westward
angle
can i follow
sure go go ahead
no i was asking the chair well he said
yes
i didn't hear
um
if you haven't
i don't understand
how an intangible thing
can become
property
and that's where i come with the
constitutional question
if i decided to suck the oxygen out of
your yard
would you say i was taking your property
i
i wonder
how we can say that this intangible
wreck
and assuming a system
or anybody system operates at top
top production
and
be considered
property
and
if they want if somebody wanted to
follow up with that somebody want to
sweep you
how do they know how much your system
produces if
at those two points if i could take the
last question first uh the utility knows
when my system was interconnected to the
grid what was coming on so they know
um
as far as the value
we put a value on reputation people can
sue for millions of dollars if harmed to
their reputation that's an intangible
um
there are many other things in the
business world you know copyrights for
songs i mean there are many things that
are intangible but you know somebody's
taken your creative endeavor
um in my case yo i invested real money
in
in that system it produces value for me
and for somebody to be taking that value
and wrecking our
market-based system which provides the
funding the only funding for our
renewable energy fund
i think that's outrageous and i have a
lawyer's i have a legal opinion here
that it's also unconstitutional
and as representatives of the state i
think once informed as we now are
that there is a unconstitutional
provision in our statutes it is our duty
and obligation to remove it
thank you thank you
thank you uh before i recognize other
people for questions and there are quite
a few people here who still have
questions
i want to inform the committee that
karen crampton
who manages the rps program
here in the state
is
on uh
online and i have
permitted her to speak
and it might be useful at this point if
miss cranston could
uh address a couple of issues
to help people as they form
additional questions
for example
how many wrecks are we talking about
every year
get swept
if representative oxygen has five unused
wrecks approximately what would they be
worth
if the rec price was twenty eight
dollars would be worth 140
uh but miss crampton if you could just
give us a quick
maybe two minute overview of the wreck
sweeping situation
and give us some statistics about it
that would be very helpful as we
ask additional questions on this issue
so go ahead ms crampton and thank you
for being here
hi good morning um
members of this uh st e committee um
i guess thank you for your questions
representative or chairman vos i will
try to i guess start with just a quick
overview of how
this um policy mechanism is implemented
so what happens on an annual basis
and um this is a calendar year annual
basis so we're actually going through
this process right now
is that the commission
uh sends a request to the utilities
to let us know all
systems that are net metered and this is
both class one and class two so class
one is new renewables although i will
tell you if that's a very small
percentage
um
and then class two is our solar we send
a request to the utilities to understand
and get information on all of these
systems that are interconnected and net
metering in new hampshire
we then also
because we do this part the commission
does this part we know all of the
systems that are
registered for renewable energy
certificates or wreck what we call rec
eligible
and what we do is we go through a
comparison
of to determine which systems
are interconnected
and not
registered for
uh wrecks
once we have that that then subset
of wrecks well systems that are not rec
eligible
we go through and we
add up some the capacity for those
systems
and then we apply the capacity factor um
currently in statute that's 20 percent
and we apply that to estimate the
generation out of those systems and
you'll probably all remember monday
there was a public hearing on
changing that capacity factor from 20
uh down to the
uh
capacity factor that's determined by iso
new england
so
we go through an estimation calculation
so we again we take that subset of
systems that are not registered
or eligible to generate rex
we apply the 20 capacity factor
that gives us an estimated generation
for the year
we then can divide that generation
estimated generation which is in
kilowatt hours for example you divide it
by a thousand and you get your megawatt
um equivalent megawatt hour equivalent
each megawatt hour as we know is is
equivalent to one rack
so it's the commission that's doing that
wreck estimation so out of that
calculation we determine there's
x number of um
class two wrecks
that would have been available
had those systems gone through the
certification process
then what happens is we convert that
into a credit
and that credit is
posted to the commission's website
and all electricity suppliers are able
to take that credit
against their rps compliance for class
two
so in past years for example
and i can tell you um
give me one second
in 20
oops sorry
uh in 20
uh 2019 uh 2020 which is the most recent
um year that we've done this for
uh the class two
requirement is 0.7
for compliance
and the credit that is given against
that compliance mechanism is
and i'm sorry
uh
here we go it's on a different web page
the compliance that was determined or
the credit that was determined out of
that was point
four seven nine four
so
what what all of the suppliers are
allowed to do is when they file their
compliance reports with the commission
by july 1st
they can take that 0.7 percent
class 2 requirement
and they can subtract
0.4794
now you all know i've never been good at
math on the fly
but i think that's approximately their
new obligation for class 2 would be
approximately 0.22
is met with the swept wrecks
three quarters
so that yeah so i mean i'm explaining to
you how it works the same exact thing
happens on class one
but you will see that the compliance uh
or the credit that's given against the
class one obligation is point zero zero
five four percent out of uh
oh golly um let me go back
out of a compliance requirement of
uh
8.9 so it's a it's a
yeah it's a very small portion of it
class two as representative oxenham um
noted is a very large percent of the
overall obligation
so
um
i won't take any more of your time i'll
just stop talking but i hope that
provided at least an education on how
we implement the policy
well thank you mr
and i would ask that you stand by in
case
we have other questions that you could
uh shed some light on i now recognize
representative bresny for a question
i think my question was answered
okay representative rezny's question was
answered
i'll now call on
representative pementel for a question
uh one of my questions i think you said
that uh
thank you mr chairman that uh
uh representative samsich is gonna talk
later so i think he's gonna answer that
question but the other question i have
is
if
if the electric company is sweeping
these reps
do they know who they're sweeping them
from
representative
do you want to answer that or should we
ask no they don't as ms
crampton said it's a
it's a total times a factor it's
anonymous
they're just dealing with kilowatt hours
megawatt hours not individuals and names
or companies
yes that's that's absolutely correct it
is all an estimation we we take the
total capacity of just everybody is one
group we apply the capacity factor we
are estimating the generation
and and yes as you said it's all in that
unanimous or it's all anonymous man i'm
anonymous thank you
and um yes that's how it works
okay thank you
uh
representative thomas is recognized for
a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question representative um
i admit you you raised an interesting
argument i was curious if you were aware
of or have you attempted to
actually take any legal action or are
aware of any particular court cases that
other people may have tried uh to bring
this to attention reports are you aware
of any legal action whatsoever anywhere
involving this subject
this is a question to me
yes thank you very much um this this
mechanism only exists in new hampshire
and it has existed i
i'm sure mrs crampton can tell us how
long it's been existence but it hasn't
it's to my understanding it's something
that's fairly recent i think it's in the
last certainly in the last decade
um
i think most people are unaware of the
actuality of it i mean if the ftc was to
come in and sue someone for claiming
that they produced their product with
renewable energy and they're green and
they're a good
neighbor and people should buy their
product
that's then then we'd know about it then
someone could um you know
raise it as a court action but at this
point it's in statute and because it's
in statute it's legal for them to do it
so you wouldn't have any grounds
to stand on you'd say well you know
ignorance is no excuse you're supposed
to know the laws of your state and if
you weren't aware of it
you're out of luck so i i think anyone
who turned to a lawyer would be told
no it's his statute that they can do it
chair
uh representative pomela is recognized
for a question
thank you chairman and thank you
representative oxenham
if the issue seems to be notification so
that people are aware
why not put that into statute then
you know when i
i shouldn't assume who brought this
statute forward but those who
created this mechanism
certainly were not
again i'm i'm this is supposition i i
don't think they wanted people to know i
think this works very well to their
advantage without people being aware of
what's happening
so why require people to know about it
then somebody
might actually try to change the statute
so it is illegal to deprive people of
their private property in which they've
invested their money
to meet somebody else's legal
obligations
thank you chair can i have a follow-up
okay thank you follow up yes yes ma'am
um then why not propose a bill that
requires notification
because i do not want the renewable
energy fund to be depleted i don't want
our wreck market to be ruined i when
people invest their money we'll hear a
lot about this when we get to hb213
people invest in renewable energy under
the assumption that they're going to be
able to
gain back
over time
the benefits so you know the payback
period is usually about seven years for
investment in the solar array
but they also are told by the individual
or the company that they're buying it
from that hey you know there's a wreck
market and you can also
create an income stream from the wreck
market and that's part of how businesses
and towns municipalities make their
determination to go forward with the
renewable energy investment because they
are told they will be able to gain a an
income stream every single year every
megawatt hour you produce there's
there's a possibility of a
money back to you
well with a wrecked market
you don't you don't have an income
stream
thank you
okay thank you representative mick
williams i notice you have your physical
hand raised
um and i am going to call on you but can
i suggest that in the future you use
that raised hand function of zoom
because raising your physical hand is
uh haphazard as a way to gain attention
but i do recognize you now for a
question thank you chair bose i do not
have a raise my hand function on my zoom
i actually logged out and logged back in
because i thought it was a bug but for
some reason i don't see it here on my
screen i can't raise my hand so thank
you for calling on me for the physical
hand this is trying to get around a
technical issue
question can i just ask you did you look
at the participants panel
did i look at the participants panel um
the link that i used was emailed to me
from my legislative email it said one
hour warning
science and technology will begin in one
hour on that's the link i clicked on but
straight at the bottom there's a little
symbol for participants
on my screen anyway
if you move your cursor down to the
middle different systems operate
differently and
i see
had a difficulty previously
i just did this because i don't have a
raised hand and i'm sorry if i did i
would raise my hand yep
okay well if you can't find it
we'll i'll try to recognize you i'll try
to look at you more often i would hate
to interrupt but sometimes it's under
reactions as well go down to the bottom
of the screen
i have reactions on my screen okay i'm
sorry then i'm sorry
i use zoom all the time i i promise you
i'm not missing something this is a
technical issue
okay so my question here is um i think
this is for uh miss crampton actually
but um
what i'd like to know is
um
is there compensation
is there some kind of compensation
for the utilities using these wrecks
and the reason i'm asking this is
because it sounds to me like this is
money
the wrecks equal money that belonged to
whoever installed a solar system on
their home and they did not register the
wrecks but there's still some money
floating around which sounds like
unclaimed property
which technically would go to the state
rather than to a utility as a bonus so i
just want to get a sense of what is the
compensation for these wrecks if there
is some for the utility
if i if i may chairman votes would you
like me to address that that question
was directed at you ms crampton okay
thank you um thank you for the question
representative
um
there is no
money
going back and forth for that credit so
again it's a computational
mathematical
function that happens at the commission
so we're estimating that generation
converting that estimated generation
into and in a way theoretical racks
and we're applying
a calculated percentage
against
the overall compliance requirement so
we're taking that point seven percent
and we're saying
it your obligation is 0.7
but when you file your report you can
subtract out 0.4791
from that output from your obligation
and your new obligation is
0.22
dot dot
so then what they do is they take that
new percentage against the
and again those percent
obligations are computed against then
the suppliers total sales
right so instead of saying i sold a
thousand
kilowatt hours to all my customers and i
my rps obligation is a thousand times
point seven percent
what they can do instead is say i sold a
thousand kilowatt hours
my
obligation or requirement to the rps is
a thousand times point
two two and i probably should do the
math so i can give you the right number
but that's that's the way it works so
it's
it is
it is just a reduction in the compliance
requirement there is no actual purchase
or selling of wrecks
because these aren't wrecks
but if they didn't meet their
requirement they would have to pay real
money in
in an alternative compliance payment
would they not miss crampton
that is correct so if the obligation if
their obligation
either way with whatever your obligation
is
if you cannot purchase rex on the open
market
then you do
cut you you you balance out you meet
your compliance by making alternative
compliance payments so yes your
compliance obligation is met through a
combination of two things a wreck
and your alternative compliance payment
so yes this and this is reducing that
overall compliance so you would in
theory purchase less racks or make less
acp payments
could could you i'm sorry
can i follow up on this yes um
so i understand what you're saying in
terms of there being a penalty for the
utility not meeting this requirement
can you give me a dollar value as to
what that penalty would be if we were
excluding these um swept wrecks
yeah it's very difficult to do because
it is a market so it's all based on
supply and demand um what i can tell you
is
the alternative compliant payment rate
for
2020 i think i got you right was 57. and
61 cents
so
this comes down now to it's a market so
it's all about supply and demand
so
they would either meet that compliance
through rex at
57.61 i'm sorry acp's at 57.61
or by purchasing rex which we generally
say
the acp is setting the ceiling price so
the rex would be less
but you're right that point forward
because i believe this money should go
to the state
fundamentally i think that there's a
cash value that's being left out that
the state should receive compensation
and i'm trying to find out what the
dollar value is
and i because nothing's actually being
transacted i guess that's where i'm
having difficulty
um
miss crampton if you're looking at the
2020 figures
i believe in your latest report there's
a graph that shows what the payments
were for the last decade
if you were just to take say 2014
and tell us how much money
came into the renewable energy fund in
that year
i mean we're talking millions of dollars
here
this is this is the all the all these
little point percentage oh
you know
this is
this is real money which matters to
real people
and real companies
nice try representative oxenam but 2014
was a particularly high acp year in
subsequent years it's been much much
lower
because of the wrecked red market where
you
isn't it true that if the utilities are
obligated to buy fewer wrecks because
they've swept up some of these existing
wrecks
that their costs are lower and therefore
rate payers costs are lower
nice try i'm a rate payer who's been
been scammed and i'm not i'm not getting
a benefit i'll tell you that question
was for miss crampton
um
it is again because we are
calculating
a percentage
based on estimated generation and again
they are these aren't these aren't
wrecks we are literally taking that
calculation and subtracting it from the
overall obligation so we're reducing the
rps obligation
um
which does mean
utilities and suppliers have to purchase
fewer wrecks or make fewer alternative
compliance payments
which ultimately lowers the cost of rate
payers
so
representative resny is recognized for a
question thank you mr chairman you asked
the exact question i had
sorry i didn't mean to stand here for
thunder i'd like to hear
right now
representative sausage's experience with
the rack market
um it was alluded to earlier
representative samsich that you've had
quite a bit of experience with the wreck
market could you share that with us
uh yes uh thank you mr chairman and uh
thank you uh ms krampton also for being
here um
yes i i had uh solar collectors
installed five years ago and
approximately the same size as represent
oxenham
and when i inquired at the time of my
installer about this idea of getting
wrecks
i was told that
it was a very complicated system to sign
up for and therefore
for ordinary so uh solar collectors on
residential roofs it was not worth the
effort
and so i kind of ignored that hearing
that advice
but then a couple years ago when i was
in the legislature and i heard about
this i looked into it
and it turns out that the the main issue
is uh registering your your facility as
an energy generator
and being able to uh confirm how much
energy you're generating
and how much and therefore allowing
those wrecks to be sold into the wreck
market
and i found out that it was not that
difficult uh once i registered with the
puc
which was a little bureaucratic but not
very um
all i then had to sign up with a auditor
who could confirm
uh the generation that i was having
and either i put a electronic monitoring
device on my system at a cost of maybe
three hundred dollars a unit
uh or i sign up with an auditor
uh
for ten dollars a year
and i'm required every month to report
to him how much what what the reading on
my production is so he can record that
and then that auditor
would would be a aggregator
that passed on my rex
to the the a company that would be in
the auction market to sell those wrecks
so i've been doing that now for a year
and a half
and uh it's working pretty well and so
like i said i paid ten dollars a year
for the auditor
um
i i don't pay anything else but that and
uh i only generate about six
megawatt hour wrecks a year
uh and i've i've
received payments uh between
22 and 38 dollars per wreck over the
past year so maybe 130 a year
but to do that i just paid the auditor
10 a year and i report every month my my
recorded numbers
now uh so it is a little convoluted and
i did it because i heard about the wreck
sweeping and i felt uh unlike a
representative oxenham who wants to have
wrecks and wants to keep them for her
personal gratification
i felt one way of combating the wreck
sweeping was to register and stop people
from sweeping my wrecks
and i'm i'm a little bit shocked to hear
from
miss crampton that something like 68
of the requirements
for class one wrecks
for the utilities is being met by
credits
from people who
don't register
and are being used by the utilities as a
substitute of course that will drive
down uh somewhat electric uh rates
however it's stealing those wrecks from
people
and using and having the utilities not
have to pay for those wrecks that
they're obligated to do so i encourage
everybody actually to sign up uh and
register if they're generating renewable
energy
so that was my experience
thank you for sharing that experience
with us uh representative samsuch
representative murray i i see that you
would like to ask a question so please
go ahead thank you very much yeah just
as a newbie here and trying to follow
all this can i just get confirmation and
i'm very close to having that with um
representative sumsitch's remarks but
the crux of the matter here aside from
all these numbers which really don't
matter you know they really don't
resonate with me the utility takes up
these swept wrecks so they sweep up
these wrecks for their own financial
benefit without paying for them in any
way and they can do this because of the
way this law is written is that
basically the issue that we're talking
about here that you get utilities are
taking advantage of unregistered wrecks
for their financial benefit
with no financial
cost to themselves am i on the right
track here
yes not not only at no cost to
themselves but at a substantial
financial benefit to themselves
thank you
uh representative bresni is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman this question is
for karen crompton um
at what point do rex come into existence
in in the case where uh an individual
generates their electricity
mrs crampton
thank you thank you for the question
uh
very similar to what representative
sanchez samsich was um indicating is
that your solar for example is is
generating electricity um on an hourly
minutely basis
on a monthly basis you report uh that
generation to an independent monitor
and
on a quarterly basis
kneepool gis which is the new england
power pool
they
administer
the wreck market they what they call
mint that generation
into wrecks so it happens quarterly
um for every 1 000 kilowatt hours that
are generated that have been
certified in the sense by an independent
monitor
those kilowatt hours are then minted
into a wreck
each wreck gets a a unique identifier
and then those racks are traded uh on
the g
through meeple gis in that open market
uh thank you for that uh my follow
question is if if you don't register and
you don't report the amount you're
generating then when do the wrecks come
into existence
um thank you i guess
i would say technically they
they're not ever a part of gis if you're
not reporting that
production
up through gis they don't ever
they're not minted
um
thank you
you're welcome my follow-up question to
that miss crampton would be well if the
wrecks are never really created then how
can they be swept up
i
yeah i again we're we're create weird as
we are
at the commission calculating
a credit against the obligation um i i
think it's a policy discussion on
whether you consider those wrecks or not
wrecks that estimated generation that
we're creating and how so i
i will i guess leave my comment at that
my response
okay thank you representative partial is
recognized for a question
yes i do understand how when you are
estimating the cost of
of these undeclared energy i don't care
if you call it rex or not it seems like
it's a matter of semantics but you are
getting your credit by paying your
numbers you're saving
your your utility money now a statement
was made earlier that this money is
being passed on to ratepayers
do you have any evidence that that money
actually goes to ratepayers and not to
shareholders
and that was for karen crampton okay
thank you for the question um
from the perspective of the right
regulated utilities
um as part of the
pucs
um regulatory obligations
we do make sure
and and this is done through the
electric division so i'm probably not
going to use all the right words and i
apologize for that
but this the cost of compliance with the
rps
is a cost that is allowable
to be recovered uh through electric
rates
um
and it is the electric division that
does take a look at that and make sure
that the utilities at least the
regulated utilities
are
meeting that obligation in the most
cost-effective way possible
which generally means you know that
they're purchasing the wrecks uh over
acps provided they're available and
those the cost of compliance is part of
rates and you'll see that when we
present to you those pie charts of
you know what what is in the energy cost
you'll see a little sliver that is rps
and that that is that rps sliver
is or slice of the pie
is the cost of rps compliance so it is
the rate payers that are paying for that
compliance not the shareholders
okay thank you um
representative thomas is recognized for
a question
thank you mr chair uh thank you mr
crampton for taking my question
uh just to be clear
um as i understand it
to be clear
the
wrecks that the wrecks that are swept up
are used by the utilities
that
lowers their
acp activities their their alternate
payments
the often compliance statements which in
effect when it comes to rate time
effectively
lower the rates for the for all of the
people within the the utilities
uh area which in in essence
benefits all of the ratepayers
in their area in much the same way as
when people use solar power
that the solar power by a few
benefits everybody in the state even
though people do pay a small percentage
from your electric bill even though they
don't have solar power on
their house
is the type of
benefits can be looked at both ways it
benefits everybody
i think that was for you miss crampton
um thank you for the question
i i guess i would say that um
in that the credit reduces the overall
compliance requirement
yes it's reducing the overall
cost but again remember that it's it's
it's racks and acps so it's
it's not that they're saving alternative
compliance payments necessarily they
could have also purchased wrecks to meet
that compliance but yeah you're all you
are reducing the overall requirement
as part of this
i i think they answered your question
but if not
please ask
again
okay thank you uh representative mcgee
is recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman
um i have a couple i have two questions
the first is does the reps wreck
sweeping depressed the wreck market in
terms of the cost per wreck
because i know we have a very low cost
per rec and that affects all of the
other uh math
so uh that's question one
um and i think if
if miss crampton if you could
ask uh if you could answer that one i
can put the other question to uh
representative oxenom
thank you representative mcgee
the market is a supply and demand market
so you could in just basic economic
terms say that if
the obligation is reduced there's lower
demand and generally when there's lower
demand that does
depreciate the price or make the price
of iraq less
then that's
market principles
thank you yeah
uh i was making that assumption but i'm
glad you clarified it for me and then
the other question is for representative
oxenom
um we've talked a lot about you know the
uh uh the obligation of the person who's
doing the job generating and
creating the value and having to
you know step forward maybe say i want
credit for these wrecks formally so that
they can't be swept from me that's one
way to solve it but i wonder if you
could speak to how
hb 396 actually addresses the issue so
that we understand what we're voting for
in terms of the change to the statute if
you could just tell us how you propose
to solve the problem in here
and unmute
yes and done mute well while i try to
locate uh my text of the bill which was
i believe i have it here
nope that's 172. got too many bills all
at the same time
um maybe it's over here
[Music]
basically it eliminates the provision
that allows rex sweeping if i may be uh
that's 213 which is about to come up
um
do you happen to have the bill in front
of you i do i do and that's what i see
is that it's not added language except
for at the very end where it says the
total yearly production for such
customer
cited sources the rest is all deletions
of the part of the statute that says
that wreck sweeping kind of can occur so
so that's what the bill does right it
makes us like every other state in the
united states of america
this provision
is unique to new hampshire
and it has
damaged our wreck market it has damaged
our ability to finance renewable energy
in the state it damages our ability to
deal with things like the climate crisis
we need to remove it from statute so
that like other states we have a
functioning market where supply and
demand rules and where corporations that
have requirements have to meet them on
on on the terms of which the legislation
was originally drafted
okay so i do apologize i don't have that
in front of me
we did
it seemed as i recall in the drafting of
this we made sure
that a problem that the puc had
previously had was addressed i i know ms
crampton had told us that when she goes
to the executive council and tries to
explain the value of her programs she
doesn't have the numbers available to
her because of those of us who don't
register and so
i there is there is a provision there
that meets that issue so that that she
will be able to
have that number available when she does
go to the executive council
okay thank you so there are there are
multiple problems that could be
addressed but this bill is attempting to
address the intent of the original
language of the rps
that you are either creating value in
the system or you are paying for the
value
that you are um
you know that you're responsible for if
in in
um in the case of the utilities
very well put thank you
thank you uh next step is representative
pimentel
thank you uh mr chairman this is a
question for uh representative oxenham
i'm just trying to get my handle on
besides the what this does to the
average
person who might have solar panels on
their house
if i were
wanting to produce electricity
commercially
on a large scale
and
i had the option of
installing
having
that system installed in new hampshire
or
massachusetts
would there be
an incentive for them
choosing
massachusetts over new hampshire
because of the wrecked
market we have a regional um wreck
market so um i believe that at one time
representative sampson actually sold his
renewal his wrecks in connecticut so i i
i it's my understanding um and you know
it's my understanding that that would
not enter into the decision as to where
you would locate your system
thank you
okay next step is representative thomas
next step is representative rezny thank
you mr chairman my question is for
representative
uh if you do not take the steps to cause
the wrecks to be created how can the
non-existent rex be considered your
property
according to
case law
i think
i'm not a trained lawyer
i think that there is an issue here
as to
the severability of property rights
um
in my case i have a renewable energy
facility and i use renewable energy
representative samsung has a renewable
energy facility but he does not utilize
renewable energy
he has lost his property right to it
because he sold it he he yes he took
affirmative steps to make it possible to
sell it but the two systems are
practically identical
he he you know invested the money in
that meter and monitoring and pays for
someone to to take care of it
but but he sold it
my store down the road which has a
renewable panels on on on its roof
doesn't realize that they have been
swept that they can't claim those and
they could actually legally be sued in
federal court for misrepresentation
because their attributes
are they no longer are there they've
been taken
thank you we appreciate your speculation
uh representative claudia is recognizing
the conclusion and not speculation sir
thank you mr chair uh
this is to ms crampton
if she's still available
yes i believe she's still here go ahead
yes miss crampton uh if i have a system
and it's not connected
how many reps
i'm not sure if she heard me
go ahead
question
so if i had a system
um
miss crampton
and it's not connected
how many wrecks
if you did
yeah
if you're not connected you're off the
grid there's you're not producing wrecks
uh excuse me mr chair
um yes this was to
ms crampton
she's not here oh
okay oh sorry she still is here still
here
i i mean
representative claudia
thank you
thank you mr chair uh miss crampton
if i have a system that's not connected
do i get any wrecks eligible to me
so
when we say connected i guess we we have
to understand a little bit of what that
what that means but assuming you have a
system and it's it is producing
renewable energy
and
for every every megawatt hour that that
system generates you could be creating
one renewable energy certificate
the way to get that renewable energy
certificate though is by registering
your system with the public utilities
commission and participating in the
kneepool gis market
is that answering your question
um
thank you but i might have used the
terminology my system is not registered
so
what is what is uh the rex i would be
eligible for if it's not registered
so if you if your system is not
registered
personally in value of something i could
sell
right so if your system is not
registered
again you're still you're you're
producing that renewable energy and what
the commission is doing is the
commission is estimating what we think
your generation is and applying a credit
against the overall obligation for that
for that generation
thank you so there is a number so i come
back in the next annual year and i would
like to
claim those wrecks that you have
uh generated by your calculation
am i
tuning for that
and no the wrecks have to be again once
we we estimate them and compliance is on
an annual basis so once that calendar
year is closed
it's done um and again the that's why
the wrecks are being minted on a
quarterly basis through kneepool gis and
then traded for compliance again on that
annual basis
so once that calendar year is closed out
from a compliance perspective those
wrecks and and or that generation is
is in the past it's over it can't it
can't be used for compliance again
okay i think that answered my question
um
is why
is the way i understand it is if i
didn't
register
the
calculated wrecks my system
producing
are only eligible for that one year
and only if i was eligi uh registered if
not
there's no way for me to claim a value i
think i have is that correct
okay thank you
uh
representative samson did you have
something else
uh yes thank you mr chairman uh and uh
i i wanted to uh uh uh follow up on on a
couple things that uh first of all and i
have a question but first of all
represent thomas mentioned about the
benefits that people uh induce for
everyone
uh when they have solar energy in the in
the grid and that is that is true
because basically we're helping to
drive down demand on the grid when we
have solar installations
uh just as a comment to uh
represent pleuge and and uh rep ms
crampton can correct me
if you are not connected to the grid
then there is nothing that's happening
you don't get credit for your own
credits that you generate
and uh the
puc cannot issue any credits on your
behalf because you are not on the grid
uh then the other thing is uh
uh and and let me just make sure i
understand uh miss crampton's
calculation here i think it's pretty
simple simple
basically what you're doing is you're
estimating the people putting into the
grid who are not registered you're
estimating that based on the information
you have from the utilities and based on
the registration database that you has
at the puc
then you're taking the difference
between the two
and you're normalizing that
to virtual credits
and they are in fact really credits
because the utility equates them with
the same obligation for credits that
they have
so even though they are not the actual
credits they are virtual credits and
equivalent in value to those credits
because they're being used against their
compliance
is that correct miscreant
okay
thank you representative sanchez uh
first of all yes you are correct in that
systems that are off grid in other words
not interconnected not net metering
would not be part of any of this
discussion
because the utilities don't have them on
their list and and and they can't be
certified uh or rec eligible if they're
off grid so that is correct
um the second part of your question
dealt with um
the calculation of that estimation and i
guess what i do want to make sure that i
that i point out is that we are looking
at
the the percent of the credit is the
same for all utilities so and and for
the competitive suppliers as well
so we're not calculating an estimate for
eversource and saying that eversource
gets to take this percentage away
it is a it is one number so it's total
for the state
um and we are not looking at us at
actual generation for
for that
percentage we are actually using that 20
capacity factor so we're taking again
the total megawatts
that are interconnected but not rec
certified
and then
using a 20
capacity factor to estimate the
generation to then estimate
the the offset to the compliance
obligation
okay thank you ms crampton we really
appreciate you being here today and we
really appreciate you taking
questions i'm going to call a recess on
this public hearing because we have
several members in attendance who have
obligations during the lunch hour
therefore including myself therefore we
will now adjourn for lunch and we will
resume
at one o'clock at one o'clock i will
open the public hearing on hb 3
9 9 and recess it so that we can
continue the public hearing on hb 396.
so thanks everybody we'll see you at one
o'clock
uh
representative parshall i think you
should play as a tune take yourself off
mute
oh sometime maybe not today but thank
you
and i'll sing along
oh what do you
got how many you got i know a few tones
i think you're probably from the same
period
you know what i mean
i'm sure i'm sure that
you've heard your father play some of
the songs that i would play how's that
no no no no no no no you are incorrect
i am a boomer i can i was singing songs
in the 80s i i started singing at 11 so
i was actually singing in the 70s
i i know i know a lot of old songs
yeah
strange for me to say that i've been
playing guitar for a half century now
i'm not getting any better
[Laughter]
that's the best part
hey i got a question for lee i think
she's listening he is
okay so maybe you can answer him
i sell i i put a solar uh station in my
roof and i sell rex
i no longer own that installation
i can
oh you're on mute sorry lee
you own the installation
you don't own the renewable attributes
of the energy you produced can i sell
but if i'm generating power
can i still sell that power back to
the power company as well
[Applause]
that's that's selling the energy that
they're
selling the energy
and having the erection
are two different things
you have a property right
to the renewable attributes
and you have a property right to the
actual physical facility that generates
energy
so
with direct sweeping you lose one but
you maintain physical possession of the
facility
and if you were actually generating and
selling your electricity you would still
be able to sell that electricity you
just couldn't advertise to anyone that
it was created by renewable energy
lost the ability to claim that i just
want to remind everybody that the
session's still being recorded even
though the chairman isn't back online
yet
hey uh but uh incidentally news just
there are companies that will say we'll
build this we'll we'll build the solar
collector on your roof and it's ours
and we're going to generate wrecks but
we'll compensate you in some way
and that church did that very same thing
they own it
you know but but you're getting some
compensation they also own the wrecks
usually so they're giving you some
compensation for that
but if you own your own facility
then like lee sang that's your own
property
now when you generate wrecks
whether you use them yourself or not
they're still your property
the question is do you want to sell it
into the into the grid or not if you
don't
you don't have to or if you're off the
grid it doesn't matter
okay and right now i had a i by some
people from uh i get one one of the
companies here in new hampshire give me
an estimate on a payback for me to
install the solar system
under the current caps and all that
i don't know if they included directs
that i would receive back as that
estimate but i can't imagine those
wrecks would add up to a lot under the
current system
and that's because of the depression of
having so many of those wrecks being
right well value
yeah okay
i learned something this is great every
day you have to learn something new
every day
you do
well
german votes if you just said something
you're on mute oh
okay
okay good afternoon everyone
uh jen if you could restart the
recording so that we could resume our
activity
already you did okay
good
in that case
since it is now
102 i will
open the public hearing
on
hb
which is
relative to the energy consumption
reduction goal
and the prime sponsor of hb 399 is
representative harrington
who i will turn the turn
[Music]
turn the meeting over to in just a
minute but first i want to point out
that we have
four people signed up to speak on this
bill in addition to
representative harrington
we have
mr fitzgerald
leslie anderson from the propane gas
association
mr scott skoglund from des
and then karen luther who i believe we
heard from mr chair you said we would
resume the former at one pm
the former bill hearing which was not
completed i totally forgot about that
thank you for that reminder
okay so
we will recess hb 399
and return to
hb
okay
so
uh is there anyone who would like to
speak about hp 396 representative oxenam
i guess you
would like to continue
i'm happy to continue i don't want to
take up time unnecessarily but i know
there are people waiting to speak um one
in particular is my son ian oxenom
right
so let me
recognize
mr oxendine
you are given two minutes to speak
okay
my name is ian oxton i'm a practicing
new hampshire attorney and i have a
degree in both energy regulation and law
so i do have some expertise on this
matter and i am of the opinion that
uh
rex supreme provision is
unconstitutional
now
i one thing we want to correct is a
misunderstanding i think some
representatives have
that this property interest only is
created when the record is registered
that is incorrect the property interest
direct represents the renewable energy
attribute
exists independently of the wreck and
has created the moment the energy is
created and the original owner of that
property interest is the person who owns
the system that created that renewable
energy
the
that right gives you the ability to
claim that you are a renewable energy
user so when that right is taken away
via wreck sweeping a person loses that
right for an individual this may just be
a quasi psychic event for business this
actually matters quite a bit because if
you do not maintain ownership of
renewable energy attribute you cannot
legally market yourself as a renewable
energy user
this also means that black sleeping in
new hampshire means that businesses that
have installed their own solar rays
cannot claim to be solar-powered unless
they are
to go to the time and expense of
registering and claiming rex it takes
money to
like and the idea that notice or is
going to cure this problem or that
people can just register and it's okay i
do not think it's correct
say is that my time's up
do you still have 20 seconds okay
okay if uh
because you have to spend money to order
to prevent the property being taken that
is a big problem in my mind that
just
and you should not have to spend money
in order to keep a property interest
that you created and that you're the
original owner of in order to be able to
claim that you are renewable energy use
and and not face a legal action from the
federal government for saying that
okay thank you time's up appreciate your
uh uh
insights um
representative
murray you have a question
um well i maybe perhaps it's better put
as a point of order i see representative
kranzien is back and i was her
substitute so am i dismissed here
or am i still substituting for someone
else or am i gone because i was
substituting for her i see she's back
well
the way i understand the rules of the
house work
is if you have been dismissed for the
day
dismissed from a committee you are
dismissed for the day
so representative christian
may be allowed to listen in to the
session but she cannot participate you
representative murray are the
representative who is
assigned to the committee for today
thank you for clearing that for me
mr chairman i i i would agree with you
that's what i've heard too
okay thank you
all right so
uh representative callie pitts you're
recognized for a question
don't forget to unmute
you did thank you for testifying and for
drafting
past legislation and i'm assuming this
one as well or parts of it
my question to you is
do you believe that this is a
constitutional question
and shouldn't that constitutional
question be in court
um
this is was i believe that all the
rules we make or the rsas we write are
screened by ols that's their job however
some things do get through
and again i would ask don't you believe
that this sweeping issue
belongs in court
and not in the legislature whether it's
constitution to decide constitutionality
so one for um can you hear me oh am i
muted no i can hear you okay good
so
yes this is something that could be
brought to a court i think that
representative oxford may have
got mixed on the question before that
someone could bring a constitution
provide the person who had stayed so
they will one of the people being
deprived of property rights i believe
they could bring a constitutional action
however that does not
mean the legislature can't act on its
own to use its own constitutional powers
to draft and pass new legislation to
repeal an unconstitutional provision
and in many ways there i think are
advantages that go into legislative food
if possible it avoids the time and
expense of litigation that can drag on
for years
it and
that as of also policy leasing is
independent of the constitutional issue
to
change it but just because it's a
constitutional problem does not mean the
legislature ha have signed the
legislature has to wait for court to say
there is
so yes it could be brought to court but
i don't think that means that it
shouldn't be considered by the
legislature
thank you
okay
representative thompson do you have a
question
yes thank you mr uh chairman and thank
you uh mr oxenham for coming to testify
however
when it comes to any kind of legal
action
as we just heard from ms crampton
the utilities don't actually identify
who they're sweeping from by name
so you know if i knew that they were
taking my property
i could say hey you're taking my
property i'm gonna go to court
i can't say that because it's anonymous
so i guess the only way you could do
that would be some class action by a
number of people who are being swept
assuming that we assume they are
because you don't you can't identify the
person who is the victim here
i'm not sure that's entirely correct i
don't want to get into
giving a legal advice to the individuals
here but
my uh
my view is that
as i read the statute
anyone who is not registered for rex is
being deprived of their renewable energy
attributes automatically and so anyone
who is not registered for x can claim to
be the victim on that basis
that is my reading of it i i don't want
to get into especially because you are a
person that who has a solo situation
yourself i want to
avoid inadvertently creating a trinity
client relationship so i don't want to
get into the details of legal advice on
how the litigation might proceed
[Music]
okay thank you uh mr excellent uh
representative samson remember we're not
supposed to debate here we're just
supposed to ask questions
all right so representative you're
recognized for a question thank you mr
chairman and thank you uh attorney
oxenoum for taking my question
um
my question goes back to a point that i
raised with an earlier speaker on this
same bill and that is one of um
the depression of the wreck market
because i think where the legislative
body probably has um
you know the
maybe the obligation to act here is to
intercede in that the
the rps and the wreck market might not
be functioning properly if a large
segment of the wrecks are
are not being priced
and the and and still being included so
basically that value is being is
diluting the market and depressing the
market at least that's the way i'm i'm
just trying to figure out if that's an
accurate way of looking at this because
i think
the skirting actually ends up hurting
the whole system
and so that's what since you said that
you have energy uh regulatory and legal
background i was wondering if you could
speak to that so you could clarify it
more for the for the committee
yes your understanding is broadly
collect i just want to preface this by
saying that
though of all that is definitely a
policy issue that by itself is not a
constitutional issue so for my legal for
the constitutional argument that that's
a separate issue and it's not one of
constitutional magnitude i think it's
definitely a legitimate policy concern
but i would like to stress that even
apart from that issue there's a i
believe a serious constitutional issue
with that said they go directly to your
question
you are correct that
as karen crampton mentioned
when you
but lex sleeping effectively reduces the
demand for
electric utilities to release demand for
rex in the rps compliance market that
means utilities don't have to buy as
many wrecks that means there's less
demand for x
it
if you hold supply equal and demand
decreases economics 101 tells you the
price is going to go down and that has
been observed in the actual market so
yes
we have a situation as a result of rex
sweeping
silver uh class two wreck prices in
particular have gone down though i can't
tell you offside my head by how much and
there's also been less need to make
alternative compliance payments in lieu
of x because
the small amount so there's also
probably been less money going to
renewable energy fund
right so it's a cascading problem
yes
okay thank you very much
seeing uh
no further questions i'll recognize the
next speaker
and the final speaker
who is
uh john gage
representing
organization that he represents
consumer alliance or something like that
i forget the exact name so mr gage you
have the floor for two minutes
okay thank you chairman buzz um first i
don't know why you're having trouble
remembering the name of citizens climate
lobby
but it's a citizen's grassroots group
with over 200 000 members worldwide
mostly in the us
and
500 of them are in new hampshire
we are all not paid
volunteers and we're trying to educate
our energy policy leaders
about carbon pricing
in particular cash back carbon pricing
which is where the money collected from
fossil fuel producers is returned to all
american households on equal basis each
month
the reason we prefer this is it protects
households from the purchasing power or
it protects household purchasing power
um and actually most americans come out
ahead so it's citizens climate lobby or
if it's easier ccl
will suffice thank you for taking my um
comments i'm all in favor of this i've
heard of this rec sweeping for years
um
didn't sound like a good idea ever
for the intent of these the purpose of
rex
to
make sure that our energy providers are
using a good balance and working toward
increasing clean energy um in the mix
and collecting money to provide
investments in energy efficiency and and
other things that will help our state
um
last week when this topic came up one of
my friends said how do i get these
energy wrecks
and i just like to give my comments
about this stuff as a
citizen this is really complicated stuff
and
most people that install
solar in their homes have to learn a
real life
and
so i think you
ought to
allow citizens to automatically get this
money the state should actually help
people sign up for these wrecks um there
needs to be information about it right
now eversource seems to be taking
advantage of a hole in the legislation
so i favor this bill thank
you okay thank you mr gage
uh
seeing no further speakers on this topic
and seeing no one having any questions
to ask
i will now close
the
public hearing on hb 396 and report that
82 people signed in in support of this
legislation zero people signed in in
opposition some of the people who signed
in included
an elected official iv van
an elected official joseph cubit
elected official maria perez
senator david waters
representative sherry frost
and
representative
daniel wolf
those folks all signed in
on the bill
so with that we closed
the public hearing on
and reopen the public hearing on
399. we do have as i said before
four speakers in addition to the prime
sponsor
i'll now turn it over to the prime
sponsor michael harrington
representative harrington to introduce
the bill you're on mike
thank you mr chairman um i'll make this
real easy for on everybody hopefully
this was a bill that came up
last session i put it in at the request
of the governor's people and
it kind of got died in the second year
turmoil of the covet and everything
and i've i've been having discussions
with uh
mike fitzgerald from des on this as well
as the governor's people
and make a long story short uh the bill
is no longer necessary the
uh i'd claim mr fitzgerald the
greenhouse gas emission goal is is on
target
and uh i recommend we just itl the bill
okay thank you uh representative callie
pitts you're recognized for a question
oh i'm sorry i didn't mean to have my
hand up i'm done
i'm good
thank you thank you does anybody else
have a question for representative
harrington
anybody in the room here
seeing none i will now uh
call on
fitzgerald of des moines mike
you're
recognized to speak
good afternoon mr chairman thank you for
the opportunity uh
uh representative harrington i think
characterized everything correctly we uh
we've had some discussions with him and
uh
uh we support retaining this goal as it
is and um i thank representative
harrington for uh
for uh being willing to listen to us and
given his request to itl i don't think
we need to go into any extensive
testimony
okay thank you does anyone have a
question i think representative sampson
might have a question
yeah thank you mr chairman actually it's
not a question but uh you you may know
that i submitted an amendment to this
bill which i will withdraw because if
it's itl there's no reason for it
correct thank you for that reminder
um
see no other questions for
whoops
there's a late question from
representative mcgee go ahead
representative
yes thank you mr chair i'm sorry uh i
don't know where to fit this in but
you've been giving us the numbers of
foreign against for each of the bills
and i was wondering if we could have
that for 172 because i think you skipped
that one
no we didn't but
i have them in front of me if that would
help you
yep representative
mirner has those numbers 296 in support
13 opposed to neutral
okay thank you very much
okay no questions for mr fitzgerald uh
mr scotland do you want to testify on
this bill
yes they typically are together
mr scotland do you have anything to say
i'm sorry mr chairman i failed to hit
the unmute button uh nope i was merely
here in support of
mike fitzgerald so i yield our time
okay thank you very much
and the last
speaker
is karen luther
ms luther you are
given the floor to speak
um i i apologize what's itl mean
itl means inexpedient to legislate and
it's a fancy term that means the bill
will be
killed essentially there's no need to
testify
okay well thank you very much for being
here
we appreciate you taking the time to
to come out to testify and i think you
submitted written testimony on this bill
as well so i did
we appreciate you doing that thank you
very much
okay
all right so we uh
we have no more folks who want to
testify on this bill are there any
other questions about the bill
which we're going to probably uh looks
like itl
well seeing none
seeing that i think we will close the
public hearing on hb 399 there were
nine people who support who signed in
and supported the bill 73 signed in to
oppose it into the neutral
so we will
now close the public hearing on hb 399
and i will
and i will now uh open a
exec session on hb 3
three ninety nine
and i would obtain obtain uh rather uh
entertain a motion
on the bill
representative thomas
thank you mr i moved to italy
three yeah 399.
is there a second
representative gregny seconds the motion
to itl
hb 399.
is there any further discussion on the
bill
seeing none i asked the clerk to
call the roll
on hp on the motion to itl hp 399.
motion is itl right
representative thomas made the itl
motion and representative regime
seconded the motion
all righty i'm all set
i'm on the bill 399 a motion of itl
representative thomas
yes
representative harrington yes
representative narner
representative mirna yes
representative fomula yes
representative bresni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative kimbrells
yes
representative pleasure
representative white yes
representative samsich
yes
representative kelly pitts yes
representative meehan
yes
representative oxenham
representative vincent
yes
representative mcgee
representative mcwilliams
yes representative murray
yes
representative pimentel
representative
partial
yes
and the chair
care about yes
20 a's and one not voting
so
a vote of 20 to nothing
for the motion of itl
the bill
is itl and without
submit this
bill to the consent calendar
no objections
okay this bill will go to the consent
calendar
representative thomas will write the
um
majority report
so i now close the exact session
on hb 399
and i'll open an exec session on hb 487
and i'll look for a motion on hd 487
freshman make a motion to ipl house bill
it's been moved to itl hb
487 is there a second
it's been moved and seconded that we itl
hb487
is there any discussion on the motion
tell us what the topic of the bill is
hb 487 was the bill that we heard this
morning about establishing an
information technology supply chain risk
authority
thank you
any further discussion
see none i asked the
clerk if he's when he gets ready to call
the role
okay
on bill 487 the motion of itl
representative thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representative nada
representative merna yes representative
holmolah
yes
representative bresny yes
representative bernardi yes
representative kimbrells yes
representative please
yes representative white yes
representative sausage yeah
representative callie pitts
what does yes
mean yes
representative oxenham
yes
representative vincent
representative mcgee
yes
representative mc williams
represent
representative maury
yes
representative pimentel
representative
yes
in the chair chair votes yes
okay
20 to nothing
by a vote of 20 to nothing
hb 487 is itl
without objection we'll send this to the
consent calendar any objection
seeing none this bill will go to
consent and representative reggie you
will write the
majority report
okay so i'll now close the exact session
on hb 487
and i will open an exec session
on house bill 3
5 1.
representative thomas do you have a
motion to make on hb 351
yes mr chair uh on hb 351 i uh motioned
to ocp
it's been moved to
otp hb three five one is there a sec
representative homeless seconds the the
motion
so
uh we have
a motion on the floor to
render
hb 351 is ought to pass is there any
discussion
looks like representative mcgee would
like to discuss
thank you mr chair
um i am looking back at the testimony
that we received unheard on the bill
and my understanding i don't have the
numbers in front of me for the numbers
for and against but i know that the
consumer advocate was very concerned
asking that we itl the bill because the
changes in the language would
severely curb
any monies being collected for
energy efficiency so our primary source
for funding energy efficiency efforts
which are a four to one payback which
was also what we heard
uh in that testimony and so
since i we have very little chance to do
anything once you put these motions on
the floor i would like people to
consider the fact that this is uh going
to severely severely curb the ability
for
low-income folks to get money for
energy efficiency and also for the
investments that that program is
designed to support
which help all of us by creating
permanent cuts in the energy demands
that we have
so i uh
i realize we have a motion on the floor
for ought to pass but i ask people to
consider their vote to just going along
with this because this will have severe
implications in terms of the programs as
conceived by the states basically our
vote against the state
uh being able to offer energy efficiency
to the citizens thank you
thank you uh representative harrington
is
recognized for
a comment uh thank you mr chairman uh
first let's uh clarify a few things this
has no effect on programs for low-income
customers there's been no change to that
in the bill whatsoever
uh it exactly stays the same that it's
been it's read it out as may include
programs for low-income customers
in energy efficiency programs what it
does is it does not change the total
funding at all it just says that energy
efficiency programs whose main purpose
is to reduce the consumption of
electricity and not some other form of
energy and if you look at the uh actual
reports on this oh are you going to deal
with my dog here for a second
easy wagon
um
you can see that
for the the last year we have figures
here which is uh 2019
90 of the kilowatt hour savings uh took
48 of the costs 52 of the cost resulted
in only 10 percent of the savings and
that's because
the when we spend money on insulating
houses we're doing very very little to
reduce the overall consumption of
electricity
and
what we're talking about here is the
system benefits charge which means it
should benefit the system and insulating
somebody's house has a very very minor
amount of help at
reducing the amount of electricity used
and hence benefiting the system so this
does nothing to affect low-income
customers it does nothing to affect the
total amount of money spent it just says
let's spend more money when we get the
biggest bang for our buck and like i
said 60
of the um
dollars spent saved 14 of the kilowatt
hours
and we should instead of spending it on
thermal insulation we should spend it on
the
things that actually work at reducing
electric consumption where we get a much
higher bang for the buck and that's
where for 48 of the total cost we
received 90 percent of the kilowatt hour
savings let's put all the money into
that category and really save some money
save some kilowatt hours and make it be
a system benefit charge
okay thank you representative next up is
representatives callie fitz
the question i had basically was
i would ask the chair
when we go through these bills if you
could
just uh give the date that they were
heard
or a brief introduction of the bill and
i we got that through the discussion but
it would be very helpful
uh not having
been prepared ahead of time and i admit
that
okay thank you for that comment i
apologize to you for not uh
reading the uh the title of the bill but
uh
first reason my copy of the bill is no
longer in my notebook
well
joy
thank you i'm glad i'm not the only one
so
uh next step would be uh
representative occident
yes
we're now in discussion mode are we not
i don't have to ask a question
with reference to uh representative
harrington's remarks if you
weatherizing a house makes a very big
difference if you have a heat pump
so that
the his distinction about whether the
system weatherization helps with
electricity costs yes it does and as
more and more people are moving away
from fossil fuel use to heat pumps that
is going to be a larger larger
percentage
thank you
you're welcome next step would be
representative pimentel
don't forget to unmute representative
clementel
thank you mr chairman i apologize for
that all sources of uh
heating use a certain amount of
electricity
um or almost all maybe a wood stove
doesn't but um
i mean we we had people even small
electric companies like new hampshire
electric co-op who
were opposed to this bill
and
the reason is that
basically the insulation
leaking of homes
is a very popular use of the
svc
and this pretty much
eliminates it
unless
somebody is also willing
to
change their heating system over to a
an uh a heat pump system which runs on
electricity but since the
main beneficiary
of this uh of this
thermal uh use of
the sbc are low-income people insulating
their homes
reducing their
their uh
yearly cost for their for energy in
general
um
i am opposed to this
uh carving out of electrical use only
as
the prerequisite for using the sbc fund
thank you
thank you next step is representative
man
thank you mr chairman uh it seems to me
that the preference for saving kilowatt
hours and not even care at all
about other forms of energy or other
expenses by low income or anybody
it's totally arbitrary there's
absolutely nothing that i know of in
prior legislation or anything
that would justify this
and clearly um
i would also add that anybody that has
uh saving energy on
on uh saving kerosene or saving heating
fluid fuel is going to have some money
left over
so that the impact of the electric bill
won't be as bad
so uh i just don't understand
uh the justification for this bill and i
don't think it should uh
i don't think it should be passed
it's basically
arbitrary okay thank you uh
representative mann next up is
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
um it is good to go back and look at
this stuff because we can't remember it
all in our heads we had some compelling
testimony by a couple of different
groups that i thought would be important
here because i think all of us did not
have all of the points in our minds and
one of those
pieces of testimony was from unitil
who said that the legislation seeks to
subject the system benefits charge to
legislative or fiscal committee approval
for the filed plan that runs in 2021 to
as outlined above we believe that the
current process is inclusive open to the
public and provides a level of
administrative efficiency that may be
difficult to duplicate in either the
legislature or through approval by
another body ultimately this has the
potential to be detrimental to the
program's continuity and efficient
administration and could diminish the
benefits of that the three-year plan
seeks to deliver to our customers so
again it on it it helps to undermine
that three-year uh continuity plan that
we have for how
energy efficiency is going to be
administered which i think is one of the
big detriments that we should consider
before we vote to move this along this
is a bill that could be retained and
could be worked on and people have
offered to do that the new hampshire
electric co-op has offered to work with
us on that and then there's also
uh the conclusion of the clean energy
new hampshire
testimony which brings in another point
which again i wouldn't be able to pull
at the ready unless i was looking at it
which is uh the language of the bill
says such benefits as approved by
regulators may include but not
necessarily be limited to
programs for low-income customers energy
efficiency programs and then the bolded
languages whose main purpose is to
reduce the consumption of electricity
and not
some other forms of energy
and it says clean energy new hampshire
supports a diverse range of energy
efficiency programs that benefit new
hampshire residences and businesses
and includes fuel neutral weatherization
which significantly reduces energy
burdens and improves public health clean
energy new hampshire would like to
highlight that all system benefits
charge dollars spent on energy
efficiency programs are evaluated with
puc oversight by astringent cost benefit
analysis to ensure that even
non-participants benefit dollars spent
on low income weatherizations or other
programs not all of which focus on
reducing electricity alone are
authorized under statute rsa 374 f colon
3.
no less than 20 of the portion of the
funds collected for energy efficiency
shall be expended on low energy income
efficiency programs so i go back to what
i was sort of trying to say
parenthetically at the beginning which
is that
passing this bill is going to undo the
purposes that we had for planning and
working through the public utilities
commission where there is an outlined
public process for them to decide
whether this stuff is actually cost
effective we're arbitrarily saying not
effective let's do away with it when
that is not what we have in evidence and
i would ask people to consider that when
they vote i think we should either i
tell it or retain it and try and make it
better thank you
thank you and next up is representative
michael harrington
i just make sure i'm unmuted yes i am
okay uh let me just reiterate a couple
of things on what was said previously
i'm trying to undo this here but not too
much luck uh you can hear me i guess
here we go
i think the last speaker missed a comma
because it says such benefits as
approved by regulators may include
programs for low-income customers karma
energy efficiency programs whose main
purpose is to reduce the consumption of
electricity not some other form of
energy so it has no effect
on that second
whose main purpose does not affect
low-income customers and if you look to
later on in the bill you will see that
the
that's what still remains in the law is
provided that however no less than
twenty percent of the portions of the
funds collective energy efficiency shall
be expended on low income energy
efficiency programs that has not changed
so the idea that somehow we're taking
this away from low-income people for any
purpose is is uh just erroneous they can
still insulate low-income people's
houses what it says is i'll get back to
is the efficiency of it
the more money we spend on the programs
that actually reduce electric use is
what the purpose of the system benefit
charges if people think we have a need
to subsidize insulating other than
low-income housing then put a tax on oil
put a tax on natural gas uh put a tax on
wood if you want to be transparent then
let those people be attacked that's what
it is let's not bury this tax inside of
our electric rates where no one even
knows they're paying to insulate houses
if you went down and asked the average
person said oh do you know part of your
electric bill goes to insulate someone's
old farmhouse that they bought for three
quarters of a million dollars they'd say
what are you talking about i don't pay
for that well you do
and that's that's the problem and i
think all this says is system benefit
charge should benefit the system and
insulating houses doesn't do it
at all a very very tiny amount and if
you do have a
heat electric driven heat pump and you
can show that the main purpose of that
energy efficiency uh
improvement is to reduce the consumption
of electricity then it would qualify
under this
as far as the authorization goes again
this does not prevent the puc from
having hearings or from making
recommendations or doing studies all
sorts of departments do that the bottom
line is if you want to increase the
system benefit charge the puc or any
other group should come to the
legislature and say here's all the
reasons we want to increase or the
system benefit charge and then the
legislature would make the decision on
that we're not saying the legislature is
going to go out and do the study and do
the analysis someone would bring it to
us but because it's a charge
non-bipassable charge for every electric
customer in the state i think the
legislature should retain the authority
to say if that's going to be increased
or not increased
thank you
next step is representatives
thank you mr chairman uh
um
so
i would first like to point out to
everyone that uh the the blue sheet the
people that uh
signed in to say how much they support
this bill we had 46 who said no
and three who said yes
the
insulation issue is an interesting one
because
in fact uh insulation helps all energy
sources uh be more efficient
so uh
it's the electricity benefits from this
too
in fact as a good example i uh last year
i visited uh former representative
richardson's home in uh
up up in the north country
and uh
he lives in a trailer park
and guess what he heats with electric
heaters
and he cools with
air conditioners
his face his trailer could benefit
greatly from insulation and that would
impact his electricity use
the
other thing is we had testimony from
from our consumer advocate don crease
who adamantly suggested that this would
affect the energy efficiency programs
here in in in our state uh in a dramatic
way
uh we heard testimony from liberty
utilities who said they were opposed to
this bill
and and finally uh
the idea that the legislature would be
in charge of adjusting the sbc
is not a good idea because we are not
equipped to do that the puc is the best
equipped entity to do this so i think in
in a lot of areas here
this is not a good bill we don't need it
and the uh testimony
overwhelmingly opposed it thank you very
much
thank you representative representative
mcgee
thank you mr chairman
um i understand we don't want to go back
back and forth back and forth back and
forth but um i myself and representative
thomas were just appointed by the
speaker of the house to the easy board
over at the public utilities commission
for energy efficiency and as i think
many of us know
on this committee
um a three-year plan was just recently
put up
at the public utilities commission after
a long stakeholder process that included
the utilities who agreed to what their
energy efficiency three-year plan would
be which was to provide stability to the
markets and an understanding of how the
system benefits charge and other aspects
of energy efficiency in new hampshire
would go forward over the next three
years this bill really
puts a roadblock in the way
of that being able to happen so it what
it does is it inserts the legislature
into a process that is at its conclusion
and agreed by all parties including the
utilities and says if we don't like it
we're going to ace it and and that and
so i take real exception to it because i
think it was representative man who used
the word arbitrary and i think that the
legislature should not be responsible
for arbitrary decisions when it comes to
energy because it affects so many people
downstream
and that's how i view this bill i think
it's not well conceived
and if it has a specific objective
other than
taking the authority away from the
agency we've given authority to make
these decisions
then i would like to understand what it
is because i don't i don't think this
legislation achieves anything that
benefits the ratepayers of new hampshire
and so i would like to see us
entertain retaining it and working on it
with the input of the utilities like
unitil offered
and like the new hampshire electric
co-op offered because the bill is not
ready for prime time it's too disruptive
to
practices that are already underway
okay thank you uh representative man
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
chairman uh yeah i just wanted to
repeat that and you know point out that
energy electric electricity is used in
any form of energy it's converted to
light or heat
or
it runs pumps to
move
fluids and so on
i can't think of any uh
exclusively energy or electric
uh use of electricity that isn't
converted or associated with other
sources of energy fuels and so on
except perhaps the electric chair so i i
think this whole thing is a
focus on electric
savings and nothing else is
ridiculous thank you
thank you representative man
representative thomas
thank you as a chair
in light of the discussion
and maybe uh
perhaps just a little more time might
need it i would request i would uh
request that i withdraw my motion from
the otp
at this time
okay representative thomas has withdrawn
his motion for
otp
and representative
representative representative
otp
and given the late hour i think i will
recess this executive session
so i encourage you all to take a ten
minute break and then come back at two
o'clock
and i will just alert you to the fact
that
there are
so 21 people signed up to speak on hb
and uh
it's going to be a very hectic
public hearing so
gather your
energy and resources and get ready to go
at 10 o'clock thank you
should i bring down some chocolate
[Music]
chocolate
i'll bring down some chocolate
what is that we're all sliding over here
over chocolate
c
i don't remember everybody's mood
i don't know if can anyone hear me
because i can't hear anybody else
i'm here can you hear me
i can hear you john thank you i can hear
you we're all muted the room was muted i
apologize for that i didn't realize it
had been muted
okay so we're back on
uh for hp 103
and we have a list of 21 speakers but
we're asking michael harrington the
sponsor of the bill to introduce the
bill go ahead thank you mr chairman uh
this bill uh does a couple of things the
most important thing it does is it
eliminates the archaic
provision that we have in here for the
old wood-burning plants
right now it says uh we have to buy
eight percent of our electricity has to
come from plants that basically no
longer exists we've been told for years
and years that the i don't know how many
the total number is now there was six or
seven or whatever
and we've been told this by senators and
by representatives of the business that
not only the hundreds of millions of
dollars in subsidies that they've
received over the years at above market
rates going back to
the old qf days
that wasn't enough they needed more and
there's been bill after bill after bill
to give their additional subsidies to
these plants
and most of those have failed and if we
believe the people that testified on
those bills they're all going to close
if they haven't already
but the fact remains that the law says
we have to get eight percent of our
electricity from these plants that were
put online and i don't remember what the
year is now prior to
2002 or something like that a long time
ago so no new plant can be built no new
wood burning plant can be built no
matter how efficient that could
uh take the place of the class three
wrecks
so it's time we've got rid of this
provision i've lowered it down to one
percent so that the uh
it includes methane gas providers the
ones that are still uh in operation
could still get uh get wrecks but
there'd be no requirement
uh otherwise because the way it's going
to be with these plants closing or
closed the utilities would have to go
out and buy alternate compliance
payments up to eight percent of their
total sales
and that was never the intent of the
renewable portfolio standard it wasn't
to force the utilities to buy
electricity that you can't purchase and
like i said not only can't you purchase
it because these plants are closed even
if new plants opened up they don't fill
that gap because this is a talk about
super special interest group this is it
says only can be bought by these plants
that were built and went online years
ago
so that would eliminate that um
that super subsidy because it's no
longer necessary because we've been told
these plants simply can't run not only
with this subsidy but they need millions
of dollars of more subsidies which we've
repeatedly refused to pass
so i mean they had a good run and i
guess they're going to all close if they
haven't
the other part about this is on getting
rid of what called useful thermal energy
which is been put in here which has
nothing to do with electricity
whatsoever
again that the renewable portfolio
standard was supposedly to
uh force people to buy
uh electricity that they wouldn't
otherwise buy
meaning renewal from renewable sources
and i say force because when i was on
the commission
some of you may or may not know there's
a bill in new hampshire that says the
utilities must provide up to a hundred
percent renewal energy to any customer
that asks for it but there was a out in
the bill if not enough people
uh asked for that
such that the administrative cost was so
high the utilities could come to the puc
and ask for relief they did that
and when they came we found that the
people who were voluntarily willing
to pay extra money for renewable energy
was somewhere a little bit less than 0.1
so because of that the puc granted
relief
to the utilities and no longer had them
have to offer this program because it
was costing a lot of money
administratively and let's face it
nobody wanted it
i asked representatives of the utilities
well what have you done to get this
across they said we've done bill folders
we've done advertising we've gone on a
website and says why is it and they go
well people just don't want to pay more
for electricity than they have to
and
that's part of the basic premise of this
this whole bill but
we don't need to get into that so much
today so the useful thermal energy has
nothing to do with electricity shouldn't
be subsidized by the electric users
there's been some companies that make a
particular product that are very good at
lobbying and it they it passed get this
bill passed so they can make a lot of
money at the expense of the rate payers
one of the changes i'll be making i'll
be putting an amendment into the bill on
this is that and it's kind of an
oversight at my part that's been brought
to my attention by a number of people is
that
regardless of whether it's a good idea
or a bad idea we told people they could
get thermo uh
useful thermal energy wrecks and they
invested money accordingly and it's not
fair to pull the rug out from under them
so i'll be changing the bill to say this
is a going forward bill and any project
that's been grandfathered in will
continue to get their wrecks just out of
the uh
out of fairness and
that's about
it so i'm glad to take any questions
okay thank you representative harrington
any uh questions for representative
harrington
looking around the room here
see any hands up
yes mr chairman i've got my hand up
no i was talking about in the room
[Music]
sorry uh so the first step i guess is uh
representative partial
i uh thank you for considering an
amendment to well consider uh
excuse me i can barely hear you
oh well let me see if i can fix that is
that better much better thank you i
apologize and thank you for answering my
question
um
i appreciate your considering an
amendment to grandfather those in that
made installations and depending upon
those racks to make those installations
cost efficient
um we are speaking mostly of pellet
stoves and the like of which my local
small
has uh installed
would you consider something like that
uh specific technology moving forward in
your amendment as well
um
again what i'm trying to do here is
you might have got a theme here from
some of my bills and the theme is that
let's not
bury subsidies in the electric bills
let's make sure we're open and
transparent about it so if we want to
turn around and give a subsidy for
something let's go out and put it put a
tax on something or take it out of the
general fund or whatever
but the electric rate pays should not be
burdened with paying subsidies for
basically
you know because some town puts in wood
chips or whatever and like i said we're
not going to it's not going to be
retroactive whoever's put one of those
wood chip boilers in will continue to
get their wrecks but if someone wants to
put one in after the enactment of this
law if it's enacted they're going to
have to do it because it was energy
efficient and cost effective without the
subsidy
okay thank you well you're very welcome
okay and next up is representative
murray
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative harrington um i have the
legal definition in front of me of
useful thermal energy
can you kind of give me your perspective
of your layman's view of what useful
thermal energy means examples of it um
how you define it thank you
thank you for your question i've
i'll only how it's defined in the law
and useful thermal energy could simply
means for the most part for an example
would be
a as the previous speaker spoke uh a
school system for example replaces an
oil fired burner for their heating
system with a wood chip one
right now they'd be able to get uh
credits for that and they'd be they'd be
getting they would get the subsidy from
the rate payers for it
my point is that
that has nothing to do with electric
rate payers and electric rate pay should
not be the source of that money it
shouldn't be buried in the in the
electric rates where no one even knows
they're paying for it if we want to
subsidize the conversion of oil to wood
if you think that's a good idea
then we should have a new tax or bring
it out of the general fund and let
everybody know what we're actually doing
and useful thermal energy is not it's
not the point in my bill it's the thing
the point is however you define it it
doesn't have to do with saving
electricity which uh or using greener
electricity
and that's the point of the renewable
portfolio standard is to push people to
use force people to buy more renewable
electric energy not necessarily thermal
energy or other types of energy
follow-up
so your wood chip is an example of
useful thermal energy
it's useful to the people that install
it sure i think it's useful it's
certainly not unusual it just has
nothing to do with electric rates and it
has nothing to do with
the point of the renewable portfolio
standard which is to force people to buy
certain types of electricity the fact
that someone puts in a wood chip
furnace has nothing to do with what type
of electricity everybody buys but
nevertheless the electric rate payers
have to pay a subsidy to that wood chip
boiler under existing law
thank you i was just looking for the
definition
okay next step is representative sanchez
some sich
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative harrington for taking my
question
um
actually uh i got uh uh
two questions for you uh the
are you aware of the fact that the
rockingham county
complex just put in
a
i believe it put in a
furnace a wood furnace system
and um
part of its financing is dependent on
these kind of subsidies but i think they
may have done it to be both clean as
well as more domestic source of energy
they could have switched from something
else and that could have been
electricity
okay thank you for your question uh i'm
not i'm not aware of specifics there but
again if they've already done this under
what my proposed amendment they would be
grandfathered in so uh that's that's not
going to be an issue the fact that
they're they've they've chose to go with
uh would i assume some kind of wood
boiler you're talking about that's
that's fine if it's especially i think
what i've seen uh we will there's a lot
of places where wood's very competitive
with oil without a subsidy so i have no
problem with doing that i'm just saying
that we shouldn't be burying the
subsidies for these projects in the
electric race if you think it's a good
idea then come out and propose a tax
propose taking out of the general fund
but don't we're supposed to be
transparent here let's not bury these
these subsidy costs in electric rates
where no one can even find out what they
are
uh follow-up mr chair hello
oh thank you uh so uh looking at your
bill uh
um
i'm i'm kind of shocked by the impact of
your bill on the rps
as we know the rps is kind of a goal
setting standard for us for renewable
energy sources
so if i look at your bill um
we originally had in 2015
the total amount for the rps renewal
manager was 15.8 percent
and that was that was night 2015 it was
scheduled to go to
a dramatic 18.2
in 10 years in 2025.
the result of your bill today is to
reduce the total amount down to 8.8
percent
don't you think that's a really dramatic
crop and and how do we make that up
thank you for your question i mean i
guess it comes down to your basic
position on your opinion of the
intelligence of the public of the state
of new hampshire um
i i believe that the people of new
hampshire are smart enough to make a
decision on what type of electricity
they need or want to buy
and we've certainly been inundated with
all sorts of information on global
warming and
since uh earth day of 1970 with dire
predictions that most of which don't
come true but
everybody should be able to make the
decision for themselves i would prefer
that all the renewable energy companies
rather than spend their time and money
coming to concord and lobbying and i'm
sure we're going to hear from people
here lobbyists who've been paid tens of
thousands of maybe hundreds of thousands
of dollars over the year to lobby for
their particular special interest group
i would rather have them use it like
most products do or used to do in the
united states anyway and use advertising
and education as a reason for people to
buy their product if the renewable
energy products are even half as good as
they claim they are they won't have to
force anybody to buy them so going
forward we've certainly like i said
everybody's aware of the of the climate
issues everyone's heard of they can make
their own decisions and if people want
to go out they can go to the puc website
you can look at companies there i
haven't looked in the last couple of
months but there were ones there 100
percent wind 100
renewables if people want renewable
energy they can get it and if they want
more of it the market will be there for
it i just don't believe that the
government should turn around and say
you people of new hampshire are either
too stupid or too ignorant to make a
decision on what type of electricity to
buy so we're going to tell you what you
have to buy i believe the people in new
hampshire are smart enough to make that
decision for themselves
okay thank you next step is
representative callie bits
don't forget to unmute
the big j
uh the problem i'm looking at the bill
and i'm not understanding
uh the part about methane and the source
will this bill
besides impacting jobs
will this bill impact unh
thank you for your question uh
representative and
the specific it has it allows the one
percent for the methane gas which i was
told is about the amount of the total
production so it will have no effect on
the
rochester landfill methane gas provided
to
unh at all that's why that's why the one
percent exception was left on the bill
and as far as jobs go you bring up the
subject we have to note everybody always
talks about the jobs that are created
when the government collects a pile of
money and they you know you collect uh
ten thousand dollars
a thousand dollars from a hundred up
from a hundred thousand people you got a
lot of money and then you show up and
say look at the jobs we created but all
the those millions of dollars that are
taken out of the economy are jobs that
weren't created that companies that say
the electric rates are too high in new
hampshire so i'm not going to expand
here there's other things that aren't
done investments that aren't done
people don't take the money and people
say well it's only you know five dollars
a month whatever they don't take the
five dollars a month and bury it in
their backyard they go out and spend it
on other things that as they determine
best so this this idea of job losses i
think you can look towards uh
spain in the in the last uh few decades
ago where they went heavily into
renewable energy and they found for
every job was created from renewable
energy jobs which were visible in the
long term they lost three
so we never hear about the jobs that
weren't created the jobs that were lost
because the electric rates go up this
concept that only the government can
create jobs i don't agree with
whatsoever i think the most efficient
way of creating jobs is leaving the
hands of the money in the hands of the
people who earned it and let them decide
how to spend it because they have they
have skin in the game and i can tell you
as a former puc commissioner when we
approve projects we all do the best we
can but if one of those projects didn't
work out it didn't cost me any money i
wasn't getting fired no one at the puc
was but if i had done that where i
worked and when i worked in private
industry and i pushed a project and it
failed i probably would have lost my job
so that's a big difference this whole
concept of jobs you always miss the jobs
that aren't created because the money
stayed in circulation with the people
who earned it
i follow
follow up
the follow-up is that i remember the
discussions well and they were to
help the north country in particular
with development and all the industry
and everything that surrounds
the
plant i want to go back to this
particular
lines in this bill and make sure
that where it says from a source of
sources which began prior to 2006
will that exempt
so we will not allow any new or will not
subsidize
any new methane plants which is another
way
to use the landfills and
was rochester created
before
2006.
i don't know
well thank you for your question
representative that
my proposed changes to the law has no
effect on that whatsoever it doesn't
change it that whatever was in effect
there is still an effect
what is that
it doesn't
what i'm proposing is a change in law
has no effect on
that portion
well
i see a new part excuse me i see a new
part that says from methane gas so i'm
i'm just a little concerned thank you
thank you i'd remind people members that
we're not here to debate we're here to
ask questions
and gather information
so seeing no other questions for
representatives harrington i will call
on the next speaker
and i would remind everyone that we have
40 minutes to go in this public hearing
and about 20 speakers left
so the next person on
the docket is hunter carby a member of
the public representative representative
representing himself
and mr carvey the floor is yours for two
minutes
can you hear me now
yes
thank you and thank you for listening to
me um i was very interested in
representative
harrington's uh talk so i'm hunter
carvey i'm in the private sector i've
been in the forest industry for over 40
years
and i've watched it change over those 40
um
i guess i have to say that you know when
we talk about jobs
um and money staying within the economy
um the wood payments that go out to
these companies is local money that
stays right in our state economy
and it is highly beneficial these jobs
are dependent on the rps
and
not only that
is there's great risk
of what could happen in the future
to our forest in terms of health
productivity we have insects we have
emerald ash borer issues that we've
tried to take care of there's other
threats out there in 1998
we had a massive ice storm that went
across our state the northern part
we had two paper mills then plus biomass
plants and they could barely handle the
cleanup of that wood which took years
we are at a high risk now forest fire
dangers in the future so
there's much more implications that
could happen by
eliminating these wood racks whether
it's thermal and the biomass glands the
biomass plants also are the foundation
of the entire forest industry 30 seconds
so there's you know two-thirds of our
forest is mostly low-grade and so that's
forcing
the companies now that are struggling to
survive
to cut the best and leave the rest we're
not able to do the good forestry
i'd want to give plenty of time for
other speakers thank you for for
listening
thank you mr carby we appreciate it
i will now uh
are there any questions for mr carvey
seeing none i will now call on our next
speaker
who is howard kellett or calais
a member of the public who is
representing the rye energy committee mr
uh
you're on
thank you uh chair uh mr chairman
um i not only represent the rye energy
committee but our select board
and representative jackie grody from our
local state representative
is also on board with our request
uh we're very concerned about the rps
goal being reduced
new england
is well ahead
of where new hampshire is on rps and we
just keep falling further and further
behind which is a concern
we're just charting a very different
course
and uh that concerns us in a big way
um
another item
we are now having solar proposal on
board
for approval for our local school system
and we feel that by going backwards on
this standard it not only teaches our
students
and our parents the wrong goal the wrong
mission in which way we should be going
we think this these projects could be
jeopardized
so we're very concerned about this uh
proposed bill
well thank you uh for that testimony uh
are there any questions for mr khaled
representative harrington
yes and thank you for taking my question
i guess i'd go back to what i previously
said so you don't believe that given the
ability to choose what type of
electricity to buy that the people of
new hampshire will buy the right type mr
chairman i don't believe that
representative harrington has the right
to question anyone
i'm asking a question i'm asking i know
but you are the sponsor of this bill sir
oh okay you're right peter i'm sorry i'm
sorry you're correct i'm sorry my my bad
you're right
and my bad as well i've i've
forgot that representative aaron didn't
was not allowed to ask questions
is there anybody else who would like to
ask a question of this
representative or this testifier
looks like
there is no one there so next we'll call
on
hopefully if i can find her
a lot of people who apparently signed up
to speak we're not actually here so
it's difficult to uh
get this rolling along
well here's somebody i know who's on the
listings here so i'm going to recognize
next charles needling mr nibbling that
has testified many times before this
committee mr maybelline you have the
floor for three minutes
thank you very much mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
charles niebling
i am a partner with the consulting firm
innovative natural resource solutions
which is a forest
forestry
forest economic development and
renewable energy consulting firm
headquartered in new hampshire um
i'm i'm speaking today in opposition to
house bill 213 in its entirety
i thought
it probably would be most appropriate
with the time i have to focus on the
thermal or the proposal to repeal the
class one
useful thermal carve out
i have some
knowledge of the history of the
enactment of of
this amendment to the rps which dates to
and the passage of senate bill 218 that
year which incidentally
uh passed the house 275 to six
the senate 23 to nothing and the
committee of conference report
was adopted by the house 292 to 52 and
the senate 23 to nothing
so it had very broad support and it made
a number of changes to the rps but
probably the most substantive was the
decision
by the general court to expand the scope
of the rps to encompass more than just
electricity
it's true and it's a
fair statement on the part of of the
sponsor
that the electric rate payer is being
asked to
underwrite the cost of incentives for
thermal renewable energy in the state of
new hampshire
and that issue was debated by the
general court in
2012 quite extensively
and uh notwithstanding statements
of of various people with different
perspectives the decision of the general
court was to adopt
the addition of thermal to the rps
quite overwhelmingly i would add that
new hampshire has been recognized as a
national leader
for its decision to expand the scope of
its rps to include thermal
and 11 other states have now followed
new hampshire's lead including most
recently the state of maine
massachusetts vermont now has a
comprehensive thermal provision
and a number of other states as well so
little new hampshire has
shown the way
um
other people will speak to the impacts
that repeal this provision will have
on their projects many of which were
financed with the expectation of revenue
from the sale of thermal wrecks 30
seconds
thank you very much mr chairman there
are 58 projects in the state that now
now qualify
uh a number of them are public and
non-profit institutions as well as
businesses
opposed to thank you mr chairman i would
be opposed to the sponsors amendment
because it forecloses on the opportunity
for others
to
invest in in a new direction for the
state of new hampshire displacing our
dependence on
imported and non-renewable fossil
heating fuels
with fuels and technologies that we
control here in the state of new
hampshire
well thank you i would i would be
delighted to answer any questions and
serve as a resource to the committee as
you determine the fate of this bill
thank you mr chairman
thank you and representative
uh
is recognized for a question
yes uh thank you mr chairman
um so my my first question to you mr
niebling and thank you for taking my
question is
um do you consider uh wood fuel a
renewable energy source
absolutely
okay and follow up mr chairman yes go
ahead
and i i i looking into the thermal rex
class 1 and thermal
class 2
i got to say i was a bit confused about
what they meant
and i understand that those wrecks are
not equivalent can you explain the
difference between class 1 thermal
wrecks and class 2 thermal uh class 2
biomass wrecks
i think you're referring to class 3
biomass racks and sorry yeah those are
that class 3 recognizing recognizes
existing biomass electric generation
class 1 thermal represents biomass
geothermal and solar thermal
technologies
but on are are the rex equivalent that's
what i'm asking um
so when class one was created it was
carved out of the pre-existing class one
electric obligation
so it effectively reduced the utilities
class 1 renewable electric purchase
obligation by an equivalent percentage
it did not add any additional obligation
to the on the part of the utilities
to purchase anything beyond what was
originally enacted in 2008
and importantly and i think uh this
another very important part of the
history of this
it was carved out and
and the ceiling price on class 1 thermal
wrecks was set at 25
so the percentage that was carved out of
existing class 1 electric at 55 ceiling
price or acp was reduced significantly
to 25 the effect of that change of law
and i think one of the reasons
the legislation passed with such
overwhelming bipartisan support was to
very significantly reduce the overall
compliance cost of the rps
simultaneously expanding its scope to
include heat energy in the state which
is
in fact we consume more heat energy in
new hampshire than we do electric energy
so
another important piece of history that
i think that the committee needs to be
aware of
thank you thank you
okay thank you very much
see no further questions for mr needling
i will call on the next speaker who is
michael o'leary a member of the public
to represent him representing himself mr
o'leary
can you hear me
yes you have the floor for two minutes
okay thank you chairman bose honorable
members of the committee for the record
my name is michael o'leary i am the
asset manager of bridgewater power
company 15 megawatt biomass fire
generating station located in
bridgewater new hampshire
i come before the committee today
opposed to 213 and strongly encourage
the committee to vote the bill in
expediental legislate
title of the bill states the bill
eliminates useful thermal energy portion
of the rps
the bill goes beyond that to also
eliminate biomass and thus our facility
entirely from the rps by deleting
biomass
from eligibility in class 3.
i have testified many times before the
committee and i'll attempt to be concise
in recapping some of the history of new
hampshire small biomass plants for the
benefit of the new committee members and
to refresh the memory of those of you
who have been here for many many years
while i only represent bridgewater
virtually all these facts pertain to the
other small biomass facilities in the
state
biomass power plants are a critical
partner with the timber industry for the
management of new hampshire's forests as
we are the primary market for low-grade
wood
by a way of background
biomass plants were built in the late
1980s and had 20-year contracts to power
the contracts were based on the
projections of utility powerful power
costs forecast into the future by new
hampshire's regulated utilities and they
were approved by the new hampshire
public utilities commission
contrary to the sponsors
characterization
these contracts were not a carve out for
biomass nor were they subsidies in fact
any form of energy that met a certain
efficiency or used a renewable resource
could qualify
hence in many parts of the country these
types of contracts were given to
facilities firing fuels
other like natural gas and coal
in 2007
new hampshire passed the bipartisan
renewable portfolio standard law
15 seconds and we are dependent on this
for our operation
these wrecks are critical to our supply
the pro the sponsor also discussed the
purchase requirements of class 3
if plants weren't operating this is an
unwarranted concern because under
current law the public utilities
commission can adjust
the purchase requirement
any in any given year and has done so
many many times
thank you and i'd be happy to answer any
questions
okay thank you very much we appreciate
your testimony appreciate you being here
again
uh representative samsich did you have a
question or is your hand left over from
last time
no mr chairman i did have a question
go right ahead
okay so uh thank you mr o'leary for
coming to testify
uh can you give us a little bit of a an
overview of the economic impact that the
biomass plants have here in new
hampshire
i can i mean there's been multiple
studies
done conducted by
plymouth state university conducted by
the university of new hampshire
um there's the direct benefit from is
254 million dollars was the last one i
think that
jason stock from timberland owners
association will also speak to this in
the case of bridgewater alone
since since our since our inception
we've purchased more than 160 million
dollars of wood fiber from the state of
new hampshire we've paid out more than
55 million dollars in direct wages and
benefits to our employees that have
stayed right here in the state of new
hampshire
we have 20 employees every one of our
employees owns their own home
these are good jobs that would be lost
if our facility was closed and many of
them have been closed and are trying
desperately to reopen
thank you for the question
representative uh oxenum you're
recognized for a question
i believe it was answered thank you very
much
thank you
uh
all right
no other questions for
mr murray so next up will be
karen
burrell
a member of the public representing
herself this girl you have before for
two
hi minutes my name is karen burrell and
i am the co-owner of accurate tree
service located in hooksett new
hampshire
accurate tree is a residential tree
removal company that my brother and i
started in 2007.
we currently employ on average 35 men
and women i also have been the office
manager for burl land clearing since
2004 which employs on average an
additional 22 men and women
burling clearing is a commercial tree
removal operation also based in hooksett
new hampshire i am speaking today in
opposition to house bill 213
the local wood chip plants are a
necessity to our business accurate tree
provides services for hazardous trees
storm damage trees clearing around power
lines
and general tree removal for 11 new
hampshire municipalities to include
hooksett auburn londonderry nashua derry
barnstead beau dunbarton kellum atkinson
and pembroke also
numerous cemeteries throughout the state
and the new hampshire department of
transportation
acuratree also services over 200 2 000
homeowners and businesses throughout the
year in hillsboro merrimack rockingham
stratford and belknap county
this work that we do generates on
average
90 tons of wood chips per week
and on average 4 600 tons per year which
is equivalent to 153 tractor trailer
loads that are trucked to our local wood
chip burning power plants on the
commercial end of things borough land
clearing clears over 300 house lots at
least 30 miles of road in addition to
widening roads like we just recently
completed for interstate 93 and route
106.
this operation also mobilizes into
numerous town transfer stations
including bedford dairy newington
londonderry mount vernon moultonborough
alton and salem to dispose of all the
unwanted debris brush stumps and
leftover christmas trees that homeowners
bring in
and converts a wood chip that can be
used to generate power
burling
on average
generates 900 tons of wood chips per
week equivalent to
1 500 tractor trailer loads per year
seconds
if we lose the wood chip market we'll be
faced to with coming up with an
alternative to using the product for
something good
if just two small tree companies like
mine can generate such a large quantity
of material imagine the amount of tree
waste that is generated from numerous
other tree services throughout the state
right now this law allows for the
convenient safe proper disposal of this
product our business municipalities our
state and the homeowners critically rely
on this power plant market for the
proper disposal of free waste thank you
we appreciate your testimony thank you
does anyone have any uh questions from
this girl
seeing none i'll recognize the next
speaker who is
nick
krakoff
good afternoon honorable chairman and
members of the committee are you able to
hear me
yes
yes krakow i'm testifying today on
behalf of the conservation law
foundation um clf is a non-profit
environmental advocacy organization
working in new hampshire for healthy
communities in a healthy environment
including advancing clean energy
policies that reduce pollution and
strengthen strengthen the state's
economy hb 213 is extremely concerning
given its implications regarding public
health the climate crisis and the
development of a renewable energy
industry in new hampshire
increasing the use of renewable energy
in new hampshire has numerous public
health benefits such as reduced
pollution from fossil fuels
which contribute to or exacerbate asthma
other respiratory problems and heart
disease
increased renewables use is also
important for addressing the impacts
from climate change that new hampshire
is already experiencing including
increased coastal flooding
severe heat waves and mild winters
to address the public health and climate
change impacts of fossil fuel use it is
critical
that we reduce our reliance on fossil
fuels for generating electricity today
new hampshire's current rps law
encourages new hampshire to transition
away from fossil fuel generated
electricity to renewable sources
electricity by requiring utilities to
produce a certain percentage of power
from renewables each year
the rps has helped new hampshire begin
making progress on transitioning to
renewables
it has also contributed to the
development of renewable energy industry
in new hampshire
hp 213 is a massive step in the wrong
direction
all of new hampshire's neighbors have
passed laws mandating rps targets that
are more ambitious than new hampshires
and these targets are continually
increasing
however hp 213
would move in the opposite direction and
severely water down new hampshire's
already limited rps target
hb213 would cause new hampshire to lose
out on the development of the renewable
energy industry
while our neighbors reap the benefits
the current rps has considerable
economic benefit for new hampshire
the rps supports increased investments
and renewables in new hampshire and
brings local renewable energy jobs to
new hampshire
as you begin as you begin exploring the
possibility of citing offshore wind in
the gulf of maine
decreasing new hampshire's rps
requirements risks shifting offshore
wind investments in the gulf of maine to
maine and massachusetts
decreasing new hampshire's rps also
risks encouraging solar developers to
invest in other states with higher rps
targets instead of new hampshire
in conclusion new hampshire's current
rps is necessary to protect public
health and address climate change and is
good for the economy of new hampshire
clf urges the committee to reject h.b
213 and vote in expedient to legislate
thank you for your time
thank you very much mr frick brickoff
any questions for mr krakoff
uh representative partial
yes i have a question as far as um
[Music]
what the impact of the uh well um
by managing our forests are we not um
minimizing the impact of invasive
species to our climate change
and if that's the case uh would this
uh if this bill passes would be we be
less effective in managing our forest
resources in your opinion
yeah absolutely thank you for the
question um
you know it's without a doubt that
climate change is affecting the health
of our forests i mean the longer we wait
to address climate change
you know the greater the impact is going
to be to our forest health and so
you know were we to weaken this you know
is going to make it that much more
difficult to address the health impacts
to our forests from climate change so
this is
a step in the wrong direction
and yeah you know answer your question
yes i think it will
um
you know negatively impact our forest
health
thank you for your answer representative
pimentel recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman
you mentioned that
the reduction in rps in new hampshire
was a detriment to
uh the location of commercial power
plants in this
state uh renewable power plants in the
state could you explain how that works
sure um i mean you know the rps as
representative harrington acknowledged
you know essentially works as a subsidy
you know so by by having that sort of
subsidy in place
um you know you encourage investments
and renewables whether solar wind
so you know already in our you know our
neighbors you know you're seeing a lot
of investments in maine massachusetts
vermont you know in solar
and wind and you know the rps um
helps encourage
these industries you know when their
inception
you know and already you're kind of
seeing um
you know where these industries are cost
competitive with other
energy sources but you know especially
what at the beginning of the um the
growth of these industries you know that
subsidy really helps their development
without that subsidy
um
you know it's basically just going to
encourage
you know investors and renewables to
locate elsewhere
okay
thank you for that answer
so you know further questions for the
speaker
i will call on the next speaker
is
mr tom
christensen
a member of the public who is speaking
for himself mr christensen you have the
floor for two minutes thank you mr
chairman thank you committee members
i'm a tree farmer my wife and i are
managing the tree found them in line bro
in new hampshire 900 acres
and we're kind of ground zero i'll give
you an example two years ago
we had hybrid brothers come and do a
timber harvest
and about
a lot of the wood was low-grade wood
and they're going to the power plants
and about
60 percent of the wood was cut and then
all of a sudden
joey hardwick says i got no place to
send my wood
the the power plants are full up and
they're shutting down
and i just called them this year and i
said is the market getting any better it
isn't getting any better the landowners
have no option to get rid of their
low-grade wood and a low-grade wood is a
vast majority of our wood so what are
they going to do all you can get is
somebody who wants to high-grade your
wood lot okay
forget about electric rates it's sound
government policy to have a place where
where low-grade wood the quality of our
forest is enhanced
by getting a market for this low-grade
wood and and especially
local wood
all the jobs that are created i don't
care about what the electric rate is but
if you take a californian example where
they had poor forest management
what happened to california last year
they sent billions of dollars fighting
massive fires okay
we haven't got that point but this is
this is going to destroy
these
landowners to to manage their forest
the state government should be
encouraging good forest management not
things to destroy it
thank you very much i'd entertain your
questions and uh i find i hope you find
this bill inexpedient to legislate
thank you sir
okay any questions for mr christensen
uh representative samsich
uh thank you mr chairman thank you mr
christensen for um coming to testify
can you tell us a little bit about how
long you've been in this business and
managing your forest
us we bought our first parcel of
woodland in 1973.
and we've grown to over a thousand acres
of announce cut back to 900 acres
okay thank you
uh
seeing no other questions for mr
christensen i'll call on the next
question
i got a question
oh excuse me i didn't see that i thought
you left your hand up from the last
question you had representative pimentel
thank you mr chairman um
and thank you for being here to uh
testify
i guess i have a question and and you
kind of
skirted on this a little bit
um that
if if we don't have this
this subsidy which
adds value to
uh sixty percent of the wood harvested
essentially
um it's gonna it has no market what is
the implications to that for the rope
the local rate payer
how how is
that affecting them
well
because of the lack of markets for the
wood low grade wood the rate payer
may have a lower electric rate but
they're going to have a heck of a lot
higher rate and government services to
example to to prevent forest fires
to manage the wood that you have to
aside from electric rates
the money's going to have to come from
somewheres to manage the forest
and the way it works now it's good
because it it hits it right at the
beginning
if we're going to wait till
we get a disaster
uh that's aside from the rate
the
taxpayers are going to pay anyways
they're going to pay more
california is a good example
okay
um
so
uh
the the additional cost i i guess uh the
other question i'm wondering is
not not only are we going to pay
in some other way to to deal with the
this uh
the uh use of the force but
if we're coming in afterwards
um
what is is there any value left in what
what's been
uh left in the forest
well if we have forest fires you go down
to zero value plus you spend all the
money to fight the fires and the forest
land owners left with nothing i'd hate
to see all the forest land owners in
california
that have gone out of business because
the the land was
to get a permit in california is so
expensive they they basically
are
not letting anybody work in the woods
and that they're just
the landowners are giving up okay
so then
what happens you get the big disaster
then the tax payers got to pay for the
disaster
thank you very much
thank you very much representative mcgee
is recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
christensen for coming in to speak with
us today
um it
what i'm what i'm hearing you say i
guess what i'm what i want to understand
is
um i am hearing testimony that what
we're attempting to do is remove
subsidies
because people are smart enough to
choose their right energy sources but
what i'm hearing you say is that the
incentives that the state government was
putting in place were actually incenting
behavior that is desirable
for us
as well as for
uh the type of state that we are which
is that we have all this forest that we
wouldn't otherwise be able to pay to
maintain so
uh maybe you could speak to that because
i've heard you allude to that but i
think that that's a really important
point to make here today before very
important point for example
our our woods roads are all gated we
don't allow cars under the tree found
but we have hikers come here every day
to enjoy the forest
they love the forest we try to do a good
job we try to find markets for a
low-grade wood which is becoming almost
impossible
and
it makes it difficult for the forest
landowner to maintain their forest if we
don't if we don't have a market for a
low grade wood
and it's good government policy
that we were going to destroy by
accepting this bill
thank you
thank you uh representative thomas
representative thomas is recognized for
a question
uh thank you mr sherman thank you uh mr
richardson for taking my question
um
i i tend to agree with you on on the
health of the frs but my question is
my understanding is that the subsidies
that are currently being paid to the
biomass plants are
pretty much paid for by
only certain ratepayers because of the
location that that they're in so
therefore
only certain ratepayers are paying these
subsidies
uh but the farmers can benefit everyone
uh
do you think it would be a lot better
and add more value to everybody in the
state if the methodology for helping to
keep the forest healthy were paid for by
everybody in the state through some
other means other than only certain a
certain rate class maybe through our
maybe to a state budget or some other
method where
everybody contributes instead of just a
few
possibly but you got to work it out you
can't just eliminate one
sausage source of support and just hope
that something is going to come in in
its place
[Music]
see no further questions for
sorry
representative presley's recognized for
a question uh thank you mr chairman and
thank you mr christensen for your
testimony i have a simple question i
don't know if you can answer this but
why can't uh power company afford to
burn the low grade wood without the
subsidies do you know why what the
technical reasons are or
i am i'm just a landowner
i sell wood low grade good quality wood
and i don't know what the economics
beyond that but i do know that that
currently we have good forest policy and
it's being degraded by the eliminating
of this what this bill would create
thank you
thank you okay thank you
the price of the wood to take it out for
out of the north country and i have two
huge huge larger companies that surround
my place
uh they wouldn't log this spring and it
looks like an atomic
and
the consequence of this
i'll try to be quick uh kids when they
can't in the summer they ended up having
a 50 acre fire
because
the price they were getting for the low
grade wood went from a thousand dollars
where trucks go down to 25 of charcoal
now these guys can't do the labor the
gas and everything else to get this wood
out below great wood so we are seeing
major problems in the last year since a
lot of these biomass plates have closed
um i don't know what the answer is i
agree with um
representative harrington i mean we just
can't put it on the back of the rate
page but something has to be addressed
with these problems maybe not in our
committee but it is a growing problem
that uh
mr christensen saw it's impossible for
these guys to block these places right
now they're just taking the good within
the 60 percent it just looks like a bomb
went off it's laying everywhere take a
walk up the north country it's a mess in
the last year so
that's why
okay thank you representative murder
representative jackie kelly pitts is
recognized for a question
don't forget to unmute
my question is um does anybody we talk
about subsidies and rates
does anybody know what this particular
portion
of
the subsidy
return back if we if we eliminate it to
the customer's bill
is it pennies a day
pennies a month
ten dollars a year
do we know or do we have that figure
anywhere
and who are you asking that question of
i'm asking that question of the last
speaker or anybody else who might want
to take a stab at it we keep talking
about this lowering the rates
but by how much
i mean it's not like you're going to
take a electric bill and cut it in half
so i'd really like to know does anybody
know that
and if not i would like to ask the
chairman if there's a way that he could
get that information
thank you
mr chairman i think uh chris goglin from
des is still here with us maybe he could
answer something i don't know
i can't see who's there
i'll tell you what
i will send email to
if she could find that information for
us how would that be
thank you very much
okay
well we're
uh running up against our
the end of our hour for the public
hearing on this bill
and the next bill is a bill that a lot
of people are extremely interested in so
i'm reluctant to start that hearing late
so i'm going to recess this hearing
i'm hearing on hb 213
and we will resume this hearing
at a future date
i don't know exactly what that date will
be probably february 22nd because it has
to be noticed in the calendar there has
to be a time certain for the
resuming of a recessed hearing
so
those of you who have not yet testified
who want to testify
i urge you to keep your eye on the
calendar
so that we can
so that you can return with us
when we resume
the public hearing on hb 213 but for now
this public hearing is recessed
and that will give us an opportunity
to
open the public hearing on hb 315.
we have 26 people who have signed up to
speak on this bill
we can uh
continue this public hearing until five
o'clock so that gives us two hours to
discuss this bill
[Music]
i am the prime sponsor of the bill so i
will introduce it
but before i do that
i have to turn the
public hearing over to the vice chairman
because he's the prime sponsor of the
bill i can't
chair the public hearing
so
representative thomas
[Music]
on the last bill if i could
i guess he called a point of order i was
wondering if you could get the uh blue
uh sheet tabulations for the last spell
is that possible
308 opposed and one support
thank you so much
can the chair sit in the chair and not
share the knee
if there's a mic problem
representative thomas
yes representatives
if there's a microphone problem can't
the chair sit in the chair but not share
the meeting
that's all
that's true but uh
easy excel right now to talk so
oh they're getting my okay
i just thought that would be a simple
solution thank you
whenever you're ready just uh you can
start
okay
thank you everyone
i'm here to introduce
hb
which is a bill that attempts to
address some issues
regarding
the aggregation of
electricity customers
it specifically addresses
rsa 53 e
which was amended in 2019
after
a bill passed in the senate sb 286 the
bill was admitted to the house and
introduced some language into the
statute
that has proved to be a stumbling block
for the development of rules to
implement
community aggregation
community aggregation is
the pulling together of electricity
customers to give them group buying
power
the overall intent of that is to lower
the cost of electricity it's a good
concept
it's a concept that ought to work and
it's a concept that a lot of people
favor a lot of people are interested in
but when the bill was
modified in 2019
some additional
provisions were added
to try to include something called
community power
community power is a set of services
that could be provided
by a
utility
such as demand response management
energy efficiency programs metering load
settlement billing customer service et
cetera et cetera
but community power is uh
as desirable as as those services may be
they are not
critical to
creating community aggregation and as a
result they've resulted in a
an impasse
in developing rules for the
implementation of rsa 53-e
so sp i mean hp 315
we're introducing to try to simplify
h rsa 55-e
53-e
so that
community aggregation can actually be
implemented and actually go
forward i had intended uh this today to
introduce an amendment because there
were several
issues with the bill as originally
drafted that turned out to be uh less
than ideal so i had intended to
introduce an amendment today
but i submitted the amendment language
to ols yesterday
in the morning and when i got back the
amendment in the afternoon
they had inadvertently
missed a couple of sections because it
was a it was a space in the word
document
and when they got to that space they
thought that was the end of the
amendment language
but there was actually a couple of pages
after that that they didn't see so as a
result i do not have the amendment
drafted
correctly that i can introduce to the
committee here today
but i think what's more important for
today's session because we have 26
speakers lined up is to hear just
exactly what the issues are that people
have with this bill
there's a lot of people who are in
support of it but there are also a lot
of people who are opposed to it
just a little while ago
i received a letter
from
the
governor's office
and that letter
which is hard to read on a phone
[Music]
that letter basically says that the
governor thinks that going forward with
community aggregation is an important uh
energy policy for the state he wants to
see it succeed and so he wants us to do
everything we can to
make changes in the existing law that
will allow community aggregation to be
successful
this is a bill that a lot of people
think
is important and therefore we have to
get it right
in order to make sure
that
it's implementable down the road
i know there's a lot of opposition to
the bill because some people think that
it shuts down community aggregation
well thank you very much appreciate that
15 seconds our interpretation is that it
does not shut down community aggregation
it may separate community aggregation
from community power which is
uh
a real an unrelated set of services but
the two don't need to go together you
can do community aggregation without
doing community power and you can do
community power without doing
aggregation
so
they're kind of two separate
uh concepts
and they don't need to be lumped
together
but a lot of people seem to think that
if you do
put them together
the end result is better
but
what the
experience with rsa
53-e shows that it is not necessarily
better
i would like to read the governor's
letter now that i have a copy in front
of me that i can read
it says dear chairman rose and members
of the sde committee committee community
aggregation provides a unique
opportunity for municipalities to lower
energy costs and to provide options for
their citizens
in 2019 i signed senate bill 286 into
law with the hope that enhancing
community aggregation would lead to
increased local control and lower
electric bills for rate payers
especially for seniors and those of
lower incomes
unfortunately unintended unanticipated
complications and technical
uncertainties have kept this policy
change from moving forward as quickly as
it should these difficulties threaten to
bog down the implementation of policy
changes to community aggregation for a
long time to come
i urge you to use house bill 315 as of
ended to clarify uncertainties remove
barriers to compromise and to bring our
communities swiftly
to bring
to our community swift access rather to
these policy changes
the key for the long-term success of
community aggregation
will be the stakeholders engaging in
constructive dialogue to reach
achievable policy goals the worst result
would be to never advance community
aggregation because of technical
disputes and overreach
together we can ensure that state energy
policy
is sustainable responsible and
accountable to our rate payers
and that's signed by governor chris
sununu
so because that i don't have the um
the amendment to share with you i will
point out a couple of things that uh the
amendment will do
one thing is it implements a purchase of
receivables program
current law doesn't include a
por so-called por
and uh
it may not be viewed as necessary but a
lot by a lot of people but it's offered
as a way to help true community
aggregation be established more quickly
i have some text here that goes through
some of the
some of the sections of the event that
are added by the amendment
but i think it would be too long to to
go through them without having access to
the amendment itself so i'm going to
forego doing that
and
cut off my testimony at this point and
encourage people to ask questions and
then we can proceed from there so thanks
very much
you need to get closer to your mic doug
i can't hardly hear you
yes
that's much better
right representative is that what it is
oh representative you're recognized for
a question go ahead thank you uh and
thank you representative both taking my
question
it seems as if we've got a situation
here where the lard is presently written
doesn't work but everyone wants to fix
it to make it work including the
governor
what would you recommend he he talked
about getting the different parties
together going forward to work this out
to get a solution that i think everybody
wants what would you recommend as a the
best method of doing that
well i think the first step is this
public hearing let's hear from everybody
let's hear what everybody has to say
let's hear what their objections are
let's hear what their solutions are
from there we can go forward and craft
an amendment
to get the job done now we may not be
able to get it done
right away i would like to get it done
right away if possible but
there just may not be enough time
if that should be the case we might have
to retain the bill and work on it over
the summer and the fall to get it right
but
depending on
whether or not this discussion leads to
any kind of consensus
we may be able to do something this
spring in time for
this legislature to act on it uh before
the end of
this first year of the biennium
and follow up
go ahead
and so to be clear on this because i
think i was wrong this is not a second
committee bill so what's the date we
have to act on this bill
this is not a second committee bill
you're you are correct about that
the
uh
house calendar deadline i believe for
action on all
committee bills is march 11th
so we would have roughly a month
to try to get something hammered out and
put together
on this bill
by the deadline
thank you
representative representative sampson
you have a question
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative votes for taking my
question
um
i i i
i sympathize actually with
the situation of our new hampshire
utilities
after the
deregulation of the uh utility market
based on
uh integrated services
those those utilities cannot really make
money on just transporting electrons
anymore so the that leaves them with a
couple of options including providing
various types of services to their
customers on which they can make some uh
profits
however it's also true that there are
lots of companies out there that want to
compete for those services
and i can see how utilities are trying
to protect their turf by saying we don't
want all these other companies competing
with us on these services
so it's a dilemma i i see for them
but the answer is not to shut off
competition
it's to figure out a way that uh that
competition could be made beneficial for
all all residents in new hampshire
so i want to kind of follow up on the on
the question that was just asked
how do you envision the role of the
utilities in this community power uh
situation where they don't feel
threatened on the one hand and on the
other hand that residents can have an
opportunity
to aggregate and bid for services that
they are not getting right now
thank you for that question
representative samsich
i guess my answer would be to that
question that
the utilities have been parties
to the informal rulemaking discussions
that have been ongoing since the passage
of senate bill 286 in 2019
and
amongst the parties there has been broad
disagreement about
what
the rules should look like and how the
behavior of these aggregation
entities should
should
go forward with
so the utilities have a stake in
approving whatever rules get written to
protect their own
financial interests
they want to prevent for example
any kind of activity aggregation
activity that could shift costs to
non-aggregation rate payers
especially if they couldn't recover
those costs in their rates so because
that would be a violation of the takings
clause of the constitution so there are
there are issues here that the utilities
uh object to because they
not only want
could it affect their ability to provide
services to customers but it could
actually cost their existing customers
money and they want to avoid that
so
the parties have to come together and
figure out a way to do this
without
imposing unnecessary financial risks on
anybody and it's without shifting costs
to anybody else
uh follow-up mr chairman
one follow-up
okay
so um would you agree with me that
considering that this is a um
a uh
a um an act labeled community power
the last thing we want to do is dampen
the enthusiasm and engagement of local
towns and municipalities to try to do
something to control their own energy
costs
no i wouldn't agree with you about that
because i think the problem here is the
conflation of
community aggregation and community
power the two are two different things
and
they don't have to go together
and attempts to
make them go together
have just
muddied the waters with regard to how to
make the aggregation piece work
so
i think the essence of hp 315 is to try
to remove
community power from community
aggregation and to focus strictly on
community aggregation so that that piece
can get done because community power can
be done independently of aggregation it
could also be done in conjunction with
aggregation but it doesn't have to be
uh representative mcgee you have your
hand up for a question
yes thank you mr vice chairman and thank
you mr chairman for taking my question
um i am happy to see the governor's
letter um that you know supporting local
control and also supporting a
stakeholder process
and i think that they're from what i've
seen of the
copious testimony that we've received
from various experts in the
community power
sector it appears that we have people
with great expertise who are very
interested in how this moves forward
here in new hampshire so my question is
who was involved in the crafting
of
the definitions in this bill and its
amendment on
what true community aggregation is
uh
i'm not sure exactly who was involved
the utilities uh asked me to file this
bill on their behalf
uh i can't say for sure
who the parties were that
all three regulated utilities
that was my understanding yes
okay so you weren't involved in it you
were just it was given to you
yes
correct
because i think that that is probably
why you're seeing so many people
speaking up is that the people who are
most affected by this weren't really
involved in the crafting of it and i
think the governor's letter also sort of
indicates that that would
that would be the process that would get
us where we need to go in terms of who's
defining what is needed
rather than just one segment of the
industry
defining it especially the attributes of
another segment of the industry that's
how i see it i'm sorry i'm always
trying to make connections and it just
appears to me that the bill is being
filed by one competitor versus another
set of competitors and that's why
it's uh
maybe not inclusive of all the things it
needs to be a good bill
okay uh next uh with his hand up is
represent next with his hands up is
representative
pimentel
for
question
thank you mr chairman thank you chairman
votes for taking my questions
my question involves timelines
and you made a statement that
this bill was removing barriers to
compromise
and
i i have a sense that
it is actually putting up barriers
preventing compromise
and i guess my question on timelines is
uh
one of the you said that you wanted to
do this so that we could move forward
and i understand that i would like us to
move forward
and i guess
what are the what is the timeline now
that you see
just allowing the the parties
to continue with their negotiating to
find a solution
and
what do you think the timeline would be
if we rush this bill through
um and
essentially
uh
here only one
have only one side of the um
the parties basically write the bill
thank you
okay thank you for that question
so the way to answer that question is
this
we know that the process has been
stalled at the public utilities
commission because they haven't even
gotten to formal rulemaking yet the
informal rulemaking process
was
taking very very long and
not being particularly
productive so the utilities decided to
put a proposal on the table
hb 315 is a proposal it's on the table
it's open for discussion
so
this public hearing will give people a
chance to respond to the proposal on the
table
and we'll see if it has enough merit to
go forward with some changes
or if it needs to be scrapped
and
[Music]
a
so that the process can start anew
the bill that was passed in 2019 and
signed into law
is already uh like 18 months
from implementation
18 months away from
having been
an attempt being made to make it
implementable and it it hasn't gotten
there yet so this is an attempt to see
if we can put something on the table to
move it forward
and the response we'll get today i think
will tell us whether or not that's
possible
okay uh
representative
no
bernardi is next not first
representative do you have a question
thank you uh
uh
just to get a
scope of this issue do you have a
feeling or is there an understanding
from
excuse me can this be a little louder we
can barely hear you
mike i'm sorry
approximately how many communities are
interested in community aggregation and
how many communities are interested in
community power do you have a sense for
that at all
that is a good question and my sense is
from uh
the research that i've done that there
may be
a few communities who are interested in
aggregation
and a very few who might be interested
in community power
representative
you have a question
uh thank you mr chair
representative vols
in the discussion of 315
you mentioned
two separate issues
so there is no
problem per se with the idea of
community
communities
municipalities
providing aggregated
power to customers
is that correct that should be as the
governor says
sure i think a lot of people think it's
a good idea yes okay now
is it possible that municipalities
can also produce and provide power this
is a separate now not combined
would there be a problem with that
know if they can figure out how to do it
um
there's no no issues there either a
follow-up
third question mr chair
yes one follow-up please
so if community uh municipality
can aggregate and wants to got a plan
and that same
municipality
has a
energy production for electricity
providing electricity
is there a
problem you would see
from them
to use
that municipality's
provided power in for the aggregates
well i think that's one of the issues
under dispute here is is how would that
happen
uh
and
is there any rule making that would be
necessary to allow that to happen
and that's kind of part of the impasse
that i think
we're trying to address by putting this
proposal on the table
to get people to talk about
whether or not
this is a an acceptable way to try to
solve this problem
thank you
representative man i see you have your
hand up for a question
yes i do thank you very much mr chairman
i'm going to confess to being having
having read the the bill and so on
uh and everything i can but i'm very
confused as to what the
objectives are it's a very complex
system seems to me if why does a town or
a municipality want to take over
solving all the problems
in in all the houses in the municipality
related to electricity
when the
the utilities have a tremendous amount
of expertise
that is not i don't i'm not objecting to
the idea
of aggregation but i don't understand it
well enough to understand what the point
of it is
what are the advantages to a town other
than
perhaps having some generation of their
own and adding it to it
and
where does these savings come from when
when
you know you aggregate all the customers
in lebanon say
and um somebody has got to deal with all
that complexity
and what is the role of
the utility in a
in this whole situation so i think
maybe it's i mean i'm not afraid to say
i have no idea
um i just can't get a handle on the the
how this thing is is something that's
useful to try
or that even is reasonable to try to
operate
so that's that's a pretty
general question but
i can easily i can easily just drop out
and just listen but um
i thought that might be a useful
question to ask frankly
that is the
the crucial question and that's what i
started with
by explaining that there is a difference
between aggregation and community
aggregation and community power
and mixing the two together
can lead to a lot of confusion and
that's what we're
we're
trying to find a solution for
by putting this proposal on the table
and getting reaction to it
might i suggest at this point that we
let uh
some of the other 26 people who want to
testify on this bill
so that
other perspectives can be
can be heard
representative kelly pitts i see every
hand up uh
is it up or did you put it down it's up
the question i had was a a technical
question i think i was i'm 53e says
in the in the revised from 315 that
the utilities would be the
administrators of the program but i i
would like to know if somebody
anybody can tell me
if the
process leading up to rule making in the
rule making process
is available anywhere if you can see it
or read
read discussion or testimony
that's what i was interested in and i
couldn't find it anywhere
that's uh because formal rule making has
not begun yet the only rule making
discussions that have happened so far
have been informal discussions
and apparently they haven't been able to
achieve enough consensus to proceed to
formal rule making
there is some question about whether
that may start imminently
but it has not started yet
thank you
thank you chairman rose i see no other
questions so i think we'll move on to
our next speaker which i believe on the
list is a
mr
shelby lyndon ketty kitty from the
edison electric institute
and i apologize for it's a different
computer so i'm not quite sure how to
promote him she will come on
standby
hello can can the committee hear me and
i apologize
but i am a sheen out of here
quite soft
okay
is this better
much better all right
um good afternoon chairman bose vice
chairman thomas and the rest of the
committee
my name is shelby ketty and i am senior
director of state regulatory policy for
the edison electric institute
uh we respectfully submit these comments
to the house science technology and
energy committee in support of the house
bill 315
we appreciate the opportunity to comment
on this piece of legislation that's
designed to enhance that electric
aggregation and through this process
consider other suggestions to strengthen
the bill which would open the state's
retail market while providing more
options and functionality for customers
eei is the association that represents
all u.s investor owned electric
companies our members provide
electricity for more than 220 million
americans and operate in all 50 states
as well as the district of columbia
eei's members include all investor-owned
electric companies that serve customers
in new hampshire
retail electric choice and the ability
for customers to actively choose from
whom they want to receive electric
generation is nothing new for the state
of new hampshire
in fact the ability for customers to
make an affirmative choice has been in
effect for over two decades
as with other restructured electric
states new hampshire both through
legislative and regulatory proposals
periodically considers refinements
designed to enhance the retail electric
market such as house bill 315
it's with this desire for new
hampshire's customers to have more
options and greater functionality that
eei submits comments regarding this bill
community aggregation which is what you
just heard which is available if in a
handful of states including new
hampshire
is a program that allows localities and
municipalities to procure power from
alternative suppliers while still
retaining their local energy company for
distribution transmission and other
associated regulated functions including
billing electric assistance and net
metering
house bill 315 is an important piece of
legislation because it ensures that
these customer protections remain intact
in addition to the bill that's before
you we do have some suggestions to
strengthen the bill's impact for
customers
the first would be more guidance around
the procurement timeline and the amount
of load associated with aggregations to
better coordinate and avoid stranded
costs for default service
while the aggregation program is
contemplated must have commission review
house bill 315 is silent as to the
interplay width or overlap of default
service procurements
in order to resolve this absence and to
better protect customers and energy
companies from procuring power that they
may not ultimately need the commission
should be given the authority to
determine whether aggregation enrollment
should conform to default service
schedules
the second is the creation of a purchase
of receivables program
under this construct the local electric
company would purchase the receivables
of suppliers minus a discount rate
that's approved by the commission
these programs are common in
long-standing and other restructured
states such as connecticut maryland
massachusetts pennsylvania and new york
when these programs are in place there's
both more shopping and more customer
satisfaction
thank you for the opportunity to provide
public comment on these issues
eei remains available going forward to
work with the house science technology
and energy committee as it builds on its
experience and refines its retail
electric market programs of policy for
the state we look forward to working
with both the committee and other
interested stakeholders as you set a
pathway for access to the retail
electric market the benefit that's all
of new hampshire's citizens
i know you have a lot of other people
but at this time i'm happy to take
questions um if there are any
i just i just had one question do you
have a written testimony with your
proposals in it sent to us already um we
do not um i i but we will be following
up um we understand from listening to
the chair's testimony that there's going
to be an amendment so if possible uh we
were hoping to wait to see the amendment
and then submit something electronically
to the full committee
okay um the sure and better thank you
okay thank you
yes i'm good for a while
um i need your list
uh
number three is uh mr uh or the
honorable mark from
from uh himself
thank you junior
yes go ahead
all right well thank you very much for
the opportunity to uh
uh appear before you today uh my name is
uh bart from and uh as representative
thomas or the chairman thomas i should
say i mentioned i i served uh
two terms in the uh the state house from
2014 to 2018.
i am also the chief operating officer of
freedom energy logistics
we are a consulting energy consulting
firm here in the state of new hampshire
and i was very much involved
in
the progress and eventual passage of sb
which was the enabling legislation for
community choice aggregation and
i come before you today because i'm in
opposition to hb 315
as it is currently
written
now i am open and hopeful for some
changes that can
help to move this market forward
um i have been an active participant uh
in the informal process that's taking
place at the puc surrounding the uh the
rule rules promulgation
one thing i can assure you through that
process
is that we would have active ccas in
place right now in the state of new
hampshire but there is a disagreement
between
many of us stakeholders in eversource in
terms of whether or not they would be in
violation
of utility privatization statutes uh in
terms of furnishing account level
information which is needed uh by
aggregators to move forward uh with a
community choice aggregation so that
that's really been the the crux or the
largest hold up we've had so far
uh now in terms of what's in hb 315 uh
that that we are so opposed to uh
there's it breaks down on three
different levels
so in terms of how the bill was
introduced and some of the language that
was put forward
first is the puc oversight proposal
puc oversight is utilized by our
neighbors to the south of massachusetts
and that process can take upwards of a
year in terms of hearings and reviews uh
of these plans before they get final
approval
uh now eversource has asked uh or or has
put this forward uh i would ascertain
because of their their long-standing
request at the informal puc process
that each uh aggregation start and stop
uh in line with the standard offer
cycles uh eversource and the other
utilities have asked us to agree in the
rules uh that any community that wanted
to move forward with cca uh would have
to essentially
uh agree to uh sending out their price
notifications
and um
opt-out notifications to their uh
to their communities uh four or five
months prior to when a standard offer
cycle begins
the problem with this and why this is
completely unworkable from from our
vantage point is because you're asking
community leaders to take significant
risk by moving forward on offering a
price to their constituencies without
knowing what the price to compare is
going to be
the other issue that we have with this
is the fact that by getting on and off
during the standard offer cycles it
takes away one of the greatest
advantages
for a successful cca in any marketplace
and that is the ability to
to move forward and to contract based
upon market signals
one of the big issues with the standard
offer procurements that we have in the
state is that they start and stop at
predetermined times irregardless of what
the market is doing at that point
if we take that away from these ccas uh
that will be a a huge burden in terms of
them being able to be price competitive
with the utilities
to answer one of representative mann's
questions
the other issue is that some of the
wording that they put in the bill is
rather sneaky in terms of how they've
said that they wanted to work with us
and find compromise and that this bill
was presented to chairman vos and others
in the context of how can we move
forward if you take a look at the bill
eversource puts in a strict prohibition
on any incidental cost
to be borne by the tax base of any
community even in the investigation of
moving forward with the cca so when they
put forward uh the proposal that the puc
review
these
cca plans a community
based upon this law if it were to pass
as written would not even be able to
hire council to represent them during
the puc process because all costs have
to be born out of the cca program itself
[Music]
that needs to be uh to be dealt with
uh on another issue is that 286 was
enabling legislation for opt-out
aggregation we've had opt-in aggregation
on the books for quite some time opt-in
aggregation is basically when the
customer comes and makes an affirmative
decision signs a contract and says yes
i'd like to be part of your plan
opt out is when a notice is sent out to
the entire community and the community
is given 30 days to respond if they do
not respond they've deemed to have
accepted the program this has
significant benefit in that it reduces
costs for customer acquisition and
really puts us on par as an alternative
default supplier if you will or
alternative standard offer one of the
problems presented by hp 315 is that as
written today it calls on communities to
use public records to send out those
notifications rather than any
cooperation by the utilities well the
problem with that is even we send out
the notifications through our tax rolls
or other mechanisms we don't have any
account level data that was necessary to
a price that customer or b enroll that
customer in the program
data that's needed
that's judd
hi chad
yucky
uh thank you for testimony any questions
for mr promo
yes uh representative pimento pimento
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
your testimony
um
i'm glad you're
someone who is actually
uh sitting at the table
uh as far as trying to figure this out
and uh the previous uh
first person who testified ms linton
ketty said that there are
quite a few states that are already
doing this community
aggregation
and that it's they're doing it
and
you know i'm a person that don't look
doesn't like reinventing the wheel have
has your group
spent much time
looking at how they are doing it
and
trying to use
those things as a template for what we
do in this state
uh yeah thank you for the question
representative and yes we we have taken
a look at how this is um this has been
brought forth in other states i can tell
you uh that by looking at every other
state that has an active cca marketplace
no other state requires their ccas to
start and stop on the standard offer
cycle uh that that requirement is is
nowhere to be found in the united states
in the the eight active markets that
currently exist
thank you um
representative harrington do you have a
question
get unmuted here uh yes thank you and
thank you uh uh mr chairman or vice
chair uh
mr falmouth uh my question is uh
no one's been mentioning the thing about
meters on this thing which is kind of
like a
little pain in my butt on this because
we've had a lot of discussion on it
with other people and
we have to you know if you're going to
go to the community aggregators then you
someone has to have the meter on the
house and i don't think the utilities
are going to allow the community
aggregators to have a meter there unless
it undergoes the
multiple pages of regulations that the
puc requires a utility meter
uh so there's a possibility of double
meters but so how would you what what's
the solution to the meter issue
well i i thought there was a a rather
elegant solution in the current law
under sb286 so that that calls for
either community owned meters to be uh
jointly applied with uh or a second
meter if you will to be put on top of
the utility meter uh or or co-ownership
with with the utility it it gives the
communities an opportunity uh to invest
themselves or invest with the utilities
um the bill also called for a review
process by the puc
um which was helpful in that regard to
make sure that um that the me the meters
were uh
the quality uh that they they needed to
be
one thing that's really important uh
from a community choice aggregation and
one of the things that was a kind of a
big success i thought from 286 was
it allows through this additional
metering upgrade opportunity uh to bring
opportunities such as demand side
management to the residential uh user
that's something right now that all of
our c i customers in the state have an
opportunity to partake in because they
have specialized time of use meters uh
time abuse seaters will tell you
obviously when you use your power and
that's helpful uh for these these um
these demand curtailments which can not
only help the individual user in terms
of their capacity obligations but can be
a net benefit to all regional
transmission costs and that's a big
reason why eversource unitil and liberty
support them and have their own
individual demand side management
programs but again unfortunately those
are only offered to commercial
industrial customers so in keeping uh
with the the uh the mission of 286
bringing these opportunities finally to
the residential and small commercial
customer metering is a is a big
component of that and i i think you know
without the metering language staying in
there we won't have that opportunity
a follow-up mr chairman
yeah i i guess i'm trying to get down
more basic is uh the meter on the side
if you have a community aggregated uh uh
house so who owns the meter on the side
of the house and if it's the community
aggregator to what standards that they
have to calibrate that to and so forth i
just it's going to be an issue
i think because the utilities are not
going to go along with any
meter results that don't meet their own
standards so i'm just trying to think
how would you resolve that issue
well we see that actually again somewhat
right now in terms of these demand
response programs and outside vendors
are hired to implement these programs
and uh they have approved revenue grade
meters that they install on any building
that participates in these programs
specifically the iso new england uh
programs uh um and and so i would expect
that would that would unfold in a very
similar fashion uh for the residential
customer and and again if you take a
look at the original language in 286 it
enables
the community to go and take on that
cost uh while working with the utilities
and with puc approval in order to get
there so i i think we we do have that
covered it's not as though a community
or an aggregate
act sorry aggregator can just go and
throw on a meter and hope for the best
there is significant oversight already
built into 286. thank you
thank you
next
representative dodder had her hand up
please for a question thank you mr
chairman and hey judd can you hear me i
can hear you
it's good to see you um
who would pay for these extra meters
so a great question and and uh so as
part of the puc process uh there can be
an agreement between uh the utilities in
the community where they share payment
uh again they both have to meet uh
mutually acceptable terms the community
can also offer to pay for the meters
outright and one thing that we see in
other jurisdictions that have community
choice aggregation is that they'll
typically go and put that cost uh for
the cost of those meter upgrades into
the base rate for that community choice
aggregation plan so when i hear some of
you mention the fact that you don't want
anybody not involved in the aggregation
to bear the costs of these programs this
is a great solve for that because only
people that will be involved in the
community choice aggregation will be
paying for those meter costs thank you
thank you uh riverside pitcher handed up
for a question
yes one thank you one of the things that
really bothers me is the data mining
i
ha once the data leaves
the utility
what are the protections from for the
customer that it is not going to go
elsewhere and are there any
that i i can tell you representative
kelly pitts i i am not an expert in that
and i'd be the wrong person to answer
that question um there might be a few
people behind me that that could answer
that one for you okay we'll leave that
on the table thank you
representative samsic you're next on the
question
oh thank you very much
mr chairman and thank you mr forma for
taking my question
since since it was mentioned a couple
times
in passing
it sounded like people were saying
aggregation is already happening now
would i be correct in assuming that in
fact i as a resident if i am able to
pick my power supplier which i can now
that's kind of a form of aggregation of
one you know i i chose to select the
supplier
that's the price i chose that
uh and the same is true for for
businesses however businesses are
dramatically
involved in commercial and industrial
are already
involved dramatically in getting their
own source of power i think it's
something like 80 percent of them have
chosen not the default rate
while only 18 percent of residents
choose it
so is that in fact kind of the model for
aggregation where now a town can get
together and say i want to do the same
as a business that goes out to bid
and and that that is not happening right
now i mean i i don't think it's
happening right now is it
well as you pointed out your numbers are
accurate yes it's about 18 of
residential customers are taking
advantage of the current competitive
marketplace the commercial industrial
numbers are probably a little bit closer
to 90 in terms of who are choosing
third-party suppliers a big reason for
that is because of the fact that
on the residential side everything is is
largely take it or leave it there's no
negotiating there's no uh there's
there's no differentiation of contracts
uh there's kind of a mass market offer
and if you like it great take it if not
uh you know stay with standard offer one
of the the the big benefits of of
aggregating lots of users like yourself
and going through the community leaders
uh that are making the decision to move
forward with community choice
aggregation is that the overall load
that they represent is on par with some
of the largest users that we have on the
commercial industrial side in this state
so your buying power and your
negotiating power your leverage if you
will is much more significant than the
average resident on their own so there
there's a lot of benefit in that
uh follow up mr chairman
yes go ahead
so
um
because i mean
well i hear from a lot of constituents
of mine when i mentioned that they could
choose their own power supplier one of
the biggest things
reservations they have is they're not
sure about this system can i depend on
this can i get is this fraudulent or
whatever and it seems to me and i don't
know if you would agree with this that
aggregating in a municipality would give
a lot of people more confidence that
this is a process that they can trust
i i would agree with the fact that
there's a lot more oversight and again
leverage to get better contractual terms
so when i hear a lot of people complain
about how the residential marketplace
has unfolded over the last uh 10 years
or so the biggest issue is that people
sign up for one rate it looked good at
the time they were doing better than
ever source 12 months went by and next
thing i know uh their bill doubled on
them with the community choice program
that that's not going to happen because
of the fact that the community elders
are the ones negotiating the contracts
they're not going to let the contract
lapse they're going to have provisions
in there to either return to the utility
at the end of the deal or seek out a new
vendor
thank you very much
thank you representative do i have any
other hands left for questions for uh
mr falmouth
anybody at all
anybody here in the spring
okay
next on the list is mr
clifton baylo
from lebanon
mr bilo uh you're on
okay
it
had to reset me
good afternoon
members of the committee um i want to
thank the uh sponsors for their good
intentions i appreciate the fact that uh
they see that they're trying to help
move this along um and they're certainly
some a couple good things about this
bill including the por language um
but overall i think there's a lot of
problems in this bill um let me back up
um i am the assistant mayor of the city
of lebanon and i am here testifying on
behalf of the city of lebanon
i have provided you fairly uh very
extensive detailed critique of the bill
as well as a couple of suggested
amendments that you should all have um i
would strongly urge you to take the time
to review that i i know it's it's dense
and complicated subject but it is um
uh
you know there's a lot of important
details to get right here um and i'm
certainly open to working with the
sponsors um the utilities the poc other
parties uh to um
see if we can find some common ground
that will actually help move this
forward um but i gotta say at this point
that you know i think just the
introduction of the bill is the thing
that has held up the puc uh moving ahead
with formal rulemaking i'm just
speculating i have no knowledge of that
except that uh back before the end of
the year they expected uh to be
proposing um doing the initial rule
proposal fairly soon and quite honestly
i i thought we were about 90 95 of the
way on the rules uh in the informal
process um
you know there was certainly an openness
for the utilities and any stakeholder to
propose a rural language
and um we you know we just didn't see
the rule language that that you know
would perhaps close the gap uh if you
will
um
the the um
we've probably been at the city of
lebanon four and a half years ago
designated our lebanon electric
aggregation committee um our energy
advisory committee as its electric
aggregation committee and um
that was in the context of the uh
development of new net metering tariffs
where the city proposed in its testimony
that we actually pilot um using
real-time prices as a mechanism with
regard to net metering uh both for
buying and selling electricity at the
retail level uh translating the
wholesale market price directly to
customers new hampshire's that law has
actually called for that since 1996 in
the restructuring statute uh that says
customers should have choices such as
access to real-time pricing
generally that's just not an option for
smaller customers because they don't
have the metering capacity for that um
the bill does not the current law does
not change a lot of things about the way
anything that the utilities work
without a process that would have the
puc um a finding that it's for the
public good whether it's regard with
regard to metering or billing or
anything else of that nature um and in
fact the bill actually repeals or
modifies quite a bit of language from
the original statute going back to 1996.
it does just it doesn't simply undo
things uh from two years ago um
and i i i do want to say i think it's
important to recognize that
i don't i don't see any difference
between the terms municipal and county
aggregation
uh community aggregation
uh community or community power or
community choice aggregation those those
are all terms that are interchangeable
um and they're simply about what um
uh the law
attempts to enable and what it i think
at its core attempts to enable is
a more market-based approach to our
energy supply uh one that um
gives small customers the similar
opportunities that large customers have
today in the competitive market um and
that allows for innovation and adaption
to local conditions um
and a lot of what this bill would undo
would would get rid of those things it
would get rid of a lot of the
opportunities to provide value added uh
benefits to both local customers and the
grid as a whole i would argue um
uh
i know you've got a lot of folks who
want to testify i do want to
i could go ahead and address
representative kelly pitts one of her
concerns about customer data the current
law very expressly says that um uh um
municipal and county aggregations and
and i use the term community power just
as a shorthand for that um uh
you know have the same obligations that
utilities have as a service provider
because they would be uh
serving people's electricity supply
needs
as the utilities to protect customer
data and it goes a step further and also
says that that any of that data is not
subject to disclosure under 91a just
because there's a historic court case
that said
information about cni customers would
have to be disclosed if it's held by the
puc for instance so we want to make
clear that this would all still be
protected confidential data
you mr phil
thank you
happy happy to work with the committee
um
yeah representative oxenham you
recognize your question
thank you very much uh mr bilo could you
go back for a moment to your uh
statement that community aggregation and
community's choice and
there was a third term that they all
actually referred to the same thing
could you just flesh that out for us
please
i will say the term community power came
very in the early days of of our
committee talking about this and say
what would we call it um
and we you know played around with
lebanon light and power there's a cape
light in power
um
you know cca is kind of obscure lebanon
municipal aggregation didn't sound good
so we just said let's call it lebanon
community power because we would be
supplying the power uh to our customers
that's what aggregation is the
aggregation is the responsible entity
for providing the power supply not
delivering it and and um
so that's why i don't really think
there's a distinction um
we did discover that that
municipalities cannot reserve trade
names so we we wrote into the law that
communities could reserve the term
lebanon or plainfield or nashua
community power just so that people
could have a name that they could use
reliably and consistently
uh follow-up
mr chair
okay i'll take the follow-up um could
could you explain
why when we were presented with this
bill by the sponsor we were told there
are two separate things and it's
possible for community aggregation to go
forward and we should not be held up by
all these other issues that are
holding things up
well i'm afraid the bill is introduced
and i'm sure this was not the intent of
the sponsors but but um
the effect of some of the language that
was provided to them by eversource
was to make basically
community aggregation municipal and
county aggregation impossible to do um
uh you might as well repeal the whole
statute and if you wonder why you just
you need to read through my detailed uh
explanation of this in my written
comments um
uh
i guess that's it
but well i i i have read all of your
comments twice
yes
i really had your follow-up excuse me
okay i'll go on to representative mcgee
please for a question
yes sir thank you mr vice chair and
thank you mr vilo for coming here today
um i i did read through um your notes
and
but i wanted to refer to when you were
testifying you mentioned that there's
already an existing process through
which the puc oversees the billing the
metering um
the pieces of the process that seem to
be um redefined in the bill
language and i was just curious if you
could say a little bit more about that
so that we could understand that piece
better
well
um you know the bill would strike for
instance some of the authority that has
existed since 1996
for
a municipal aggregation
to provide customer service or meter
reading or other related services
or conservation and decide demand side
management um it takes those first the
the last two i just mentioned and says
you can only do it through the utility
or ice on new england programs which
makes no sense because today
third party providers do all kinds of
demand side management i point to one
that freedom energy logistics has helped
the city save tens and tens of thousands
of dollars we'd like to be able to
continue to do that in working with
these uh vendors um you know even meter
reading it you know right now there's
two forms of meter reading that
third-party vendors can do uh you have
your independent monitors for reading
the production meters for wreck
production that is something we would
like to be able to offer to smaller
customers
this would a language would prohibit
that
all suppliers competitive suppliers many
of them provide their own customer
service when customers have questions
about their supply
why wouldn't a community power
aggregation be able to provide customer
service particularly if we're doing
something innovative like offering
customers access to real-time pricing
utility may not know anything about our
real-time pricing program we should be
the ones who are able to answer customer
questions about that not apparently have
to contract oh we couldn't even contract
with utility because it wouldn't even
allow us to contract with anybody for
customer service so we just couldn't do
customer service
there's just many things about what the
bill does that i just don't understand
why and and when you look at the bill
itself they're not obvious because many
sections of the bill are a repeal and
reenactment and so that is why i've
provided you attachment a which goes
through the entire rsa 53e and shows how
it would be changed and you can also go
back to my attachment c and see how it
changed two years ago including detailed
explanation for the why of each of those
changes well thank you i would like to
thank you for all the work that you did
because it is really difficult you do
need a decoder to figure out changes um
and to that end i think you know it
brings me back to the question of the
objectives which i think for us as
policy makers
we should probably have clear a clear
understanding of what we're trying to
achieve
with changes and start there and then
understand whether the changes that
we're making achieve those objectives
and i don't see that clearly laid out
here either i think it's
um really hard for us to
say sure go do this when it it has uh
such significant implications apparently
uh to people's planning
but thank you i appreciate your wealth
and knowledge
thank you
thank you uh
if i may remind the members to please
request a follow-up
instead of just talking please thank you
i'm going to recognize representative
resny right now for a question
uh thank you chairman and thank you mr
villa for your testimony you mentioned
meter reading and customer service as
some of the services that community
power would offer can you
explain any other services that
community power would would provide to
the resident to the ratepayers
and also how that
squares with
it being duplicate services that the uh
that the utilities can also provide or
how the committee power can provide
those better
or more efficiently thank you
sorry i muted myself um i think a basic
um sort of criteria in terms of thinking
about these things is
are these natural monopolies that should
only be provided by
the electric distribution utility or are
these things that can be or should be
open to competition and market options
customer choice and community choice
and
so there's a whole range of
possibilities
on
you know
there is a piece of this that
wants we want to be enabled to provide
customers with interval metering so that
they can access temporal price signals
um i think
that that's kind of long overdue in new
hampshire um unitil and the co-op have
already have that kind of metering in
place our utility is moving in that
direction we've been engaged in dialogue
with liberty as to how we could do that
and one option that just was a natural
is we pay for the additional cost to
upgrade the meters they have meter
options uh to provide an upgraded meter
that could do this once you do that then
the customer there's this thing called
capacity tag and that is part of the
underlying charge in energy electricity
supply it's it's it's based on each
customers theoretically their share of
the coincident peak demand for the
highest demand hour of the entire year
and right now
people get their
capacity tagged based on their class
average load shape unless they have
interval metering
so for the city we only have two
accounts our two largest accounts about
40 of the totals city electricity
consumption uh our water treatment and
our wastewater treatment plants so we
had fairly high capacity tags for those
and working with freedom energy
logistics we put them on a first of we
put them on a real-time pricing product
which is saving money just in and of
itself and then they also helped us do
load management outside of any utility
program
to say okay we think there's going to be
a coincident peace demand between three
and six o'clock this coming you know
tomorrow try to curtail your load so we
have done that for three years in a row
this year because we had some fairly
modest sized solar systems that mostly
served the load behind those plants the
plant operators had gotten pretty
sophisticated about how they could turn
down the power consumption at those
large industrial size loads
and we managed to zero out our capacity
tags for next year between the hour and
five and six
five and six pm on a july afternoon
we reduced our energy consumption at our
water treatment and wastewater treatment
plants so that we were serving 100
of that load by our on-site solar that
late in the afternoon and we're
exporting power to the grid that
benefits everyone because it means we
don't have to buy as much capacity in
the future to meet peak demand and the
whole grid has to be sized to meet the
highest load so if we can shave the peak
take some of that load off peak it
actually means we're spreading the cost
over fewer costs over more kilowatt
hours and help lower the price for
everyone we want to be able to do that
for smaller customers who don't have
access to that now but but the way the
bill's written it wouldn't even allow us
to do it for the large customers our own
city account so
if if you hear some frustration from me
it is because i have been down in the
weeds on these issues for a quarter of a
century and
there's so much opportunity to produce
value and savings you know just an
example of that is is is helping
customers think about battery storage
for the same kind of purpose and and we
see this as an opportunity to make
communities and the citizens of those
communities real partners with the
distribution utilities in terms of
timing doing the kinds of grid
modernization and the kind of new
options for customers that can actually
produce value and savings for the whole
system um so
rational question uh thank you very much
i'm going to move on now to uh
representative has a question he just
answered on the
question i was going to ask himself who
was paying for the customer service and
the meter reading that he talked about
he has given the answer in his last
little spiel okay thank you uh see no
other hands raised
anywhere around
uh thank you for your testimony mr
barrow thank you
and we'll move on to the next speaker
which would be uh
mr don price for our office of consumer
advocate mr
chris you're on
good afternoon members of the committee
uh thank you for the opportunity to
testify
uh as you all know i
am the head of the office of the
consumer advocate i represent
residential rate payers
i'm not going to take up very much of
your time
i agree with everything i heard
uh assistant mayor belo and before him
mr frohmath of freedom energy logistics
say
i oppose house bill 315
i think the most sensible thing to do
with the bill is to retain it because i
agree that there are certain discussions
that ought to take place that would lead
to
perhaps the refinement of community
power aggregation as a concept it's very
gratified to hear
assistant mayor below say that he
doesn't understand or recognize a
distinction between community power uh
or community aggregation and community
power because i don't think i understand
or discern any distinction between those
two things either
either in law or in fact
i want to use my limited time to ask you
to think and i i suggested this in my
written testimony about what the real
purpose of electric industry
restructuring was in 1996 and what it
remains today the question that i think
the legislature needs to ask itself is
do you want to protect default service
or do you want to protect and help
consumers if you want to protect and
help default service and make sure that
residential customers are perpetually
tethered to default service as provided
by the utilities then you really
shouldn't like community power
aggregation because it really does posit
or present itself as a legitimate rival
to default service and it really does
have the potential to cause lots and
lots of residential customers to migrate
away from total dependence on
on the utility
into combining their demand with their
neighbors
and
being part of a
very potent and compelling alternative
to default service but as i suggested uh
even the new hampshire supreme court has
misunderstood the purpose of the
restructuring act as essentially
protecting default service and trying to
make sure that default service is as
cheap as it possibly can be
i will deem restructuring to have been
successful when i see residential
customers migrating away from default
service in droves so that they can rely
on the non-regulated market
to get them the best deals that they can
and that would tend to cause default
service to wither on the vine i actually
think that's a sign of success of
restructuring and so for those reasons i
urge you not to nurture default service
i urge you to nurture community power
aggregation i think that's uh all i'm
going to say because i'm sure there are
lots of witnesses who have more
substantive and useful things to say
than i than i do
thank you mr chris i see your
representative santosh has been signed
up for a question
representative
yes sorry
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
mr crease for taking my question my
question is pretty simple
why do you think that the industrial and
commercial users have migrated away from
default service and ordinary residents
have not
uh thank you representative samsit for
that question i think the answer is
pretty obvious um commercial and
industrial customers are bigger than
residential customers and so if you are
a major manufacturer or a major employer
or a major business entity you are far
more attractive to competitive suppliers
than you or i are as individual
residential customers so
uh so and and you know we've seen this
in every state i think that is
restructured the cni the commercial and
industrial customers they sought
restructuring because they knew they
would benefit they have benefited and
the benefits have not yet accrued to
residential customers here in new
hampshire
in fact if anything they have fared
worse because
uh
the
uh the
non-regulated competitive providers that
have
reached out to residential customers
tend to be the bottom feeding entities
that like to take advantage of people
thank you very much
uh i don't see any other hands up
anybody have a question for mr crease
seeing none
thank you miss chris for your testimony
appreciate it we'll move on to the
speaker
which is
mr james
dunches
from nashville
mr dunches you're on
[Music]
that mayor dontress mr
mcdonough is not on the list anymore
okay
[Music]
yeah yes okay his emails there
moving on
uh
that national mayor is that we're
talking
yes
uh mr chair i wasn't able to get in i
was on but i didn't get the unmute
button so here i am thank you very much
for hearing us
i want to say that nashua is one of a
whole series of communities and counties
that are interested in community power
or aggregation
we are actively working with
cheshire county rockingham county
lebanon hanover
and other communities and uh formally
and talking with cities across the state
about
this opportunity
uh so there are a lot of people
interested in this and as is already
stated the underlying purpose is to
promote
competition
now the
i want to we're second what you've heard
from i think mr from the consumer
advocate mr bilo that
the i the concept of separating
community power from community
aggregation
is creating more confusion
than help and is causing delay
uh not moving the the matter forward
there we don't see the difference
there are it is the same thing
uh certainly different little
bells and whistles could be included
within aggregation community power but
there is no distinction between the two
uh second i i want a second when mr
below said that 315 if you pass all and
even the amended version
at least the way we look at this you
pass that and you might as well just
you know
eradicate uh the the all the efforts
have been made in the past because this
will essentially
uh kill community power
or aggregation both of them same thing
so
i have been on these calls with the puc
i'm not an expert in this
you know
uh and have just been mostly listening
to the discussion
but there are i think several main
issues which seem to be stumbling blocks
number one as you've already heard the
window when
community power
organizations
wish can buy power
the
aggregators community power
organizations the communities want to be
able to buy power when it is best in the
market
i think the utilities eversource has
taken the position that
they want to require that we go into the
market at the same time they do now of
course that would have the effect of
you know basically uh you know undermine
the competitive aspect of allowing us to
be nimble and try to get power at the
cheapest possible price
number two there's this issue of the
the billing
uh we need um
we anybody who's going to embark on
aggregation is going to need customer
information from
the utility
and of course that the confidentiality
of that confidentiality of that would be
protected
uh just like the utility protects it but
we're going to need it to
figure out who the customers even are
and
determine uh you know who would be in
the program
for example there are apartment
complexes with hundreds of residents we
have no idea who's who lives there the
city doesn't have a record of who lives
in apartment 203 we might know who the
owner of the complex is but
not not the individual residents
and even if we were required to for
single-family homes to require to to
rely on
tax information that's possible but
still far more difficult than just
getting
detailed information from the utilities
and third
um the
the uh
opt-in opt-out
uh
issue which mr from
uh discussed is very important
uh if you have an opt-in
the if you change this system from opt
out
in other words community power comes
customers have to opt out if you change
that to opt-in then you
greatly reduce the
ability of the
aggregation
organization community power aggregator
to
attract customers because of course
residential customers would be skeptical
about any change and
we need the opt out
approach that's already been adopted by
the legislature that's what has been
enacted already that's the approach that
means makes the most sense
i think those are the major issues but
i'm just trying to give the
committee a little more perspective of
kind of a lay lay person's
understanding of all this because uh mr
bilo mr from uh the consumer advocate
have far more technical knowledge than
than i do
mr chair and if you have questions of
course i'd be glad to answer them
uh
i call i see uh representative kerry
puts his hand up for a question
yes ma'am man don't just thank you for
taking my question would your program is
as you're thinking about
community power aggregation
would your program be exclusive or would
you exclude
customers perhaps who had
uh
late bill pays or hadn't paid their
bills or
would it be anybody in the community who
wants to get into the program
well again um
my
let me start by saying that
the city's energy manager whose name is
doria brown is on this call as well and
is lined up to testify later
okay on technical issues you know very
detailed issues such as the one you've
raised i think you need to i think the
questions are better directed to those
who are very enmeshed in the in the
details of
exactly how billing would take place and
that kind of thing
so
i'm more trying to just advance the idea
of competition and
making trying to offer alternatives to
residents and
also give communities the opportunity to
buy green power
if they wish
can i follow up i don't know who i'm
asked
what mayor the the opportunity to buy
green power and to choose a supplier
right now is out there
and what it doesn't have is enough
i think stability because customers have
been burned in the past
so
do you think perhaps an education
program about what's out there would be
very important
i think i think unity power aggregation
would be much more effective i mean uh
because
as has already been
testified to
uh the aggregation itself creates the
bargaining power necessary to uh
create many more options in terms of
price and mix
uh and
uh number one number two i just know as
a consumer that when you get these
solicitations you're on your own you're
you know you you don't know who this is
you're dealing with you know who is this
is this a scam you know who knows right
so
um the so i think customers who uh would
be
confident in a an aggregation program
a county a city
would be more much more comfortable in
working with this alternative than
people would be trying to deal with the
issue on their own thank you
okay thank you very much
um
question from representative president
thank you mr chairman and thank you
mayor for
testimony you mentioned that you support
an opt-out and also
having access to the customer list
would you agree that if it was an opt-in
program then as customers sign up for it
you would also get the customer list
so that would solve both of those
problems
but the problem that it would create is
let's face it i mean the reality is
most customers
are are not going to really make a
opt-in out opt-out decision most will
just go with what they're given because
they're not going to understand they're
not going to know they're not
so they get a letter in the mail they
don't really you know i mean i've gotten
these letters i you know what do they
mean i you know i
so
if you have opt in
if you have an opt-out system as the
legislature has already adopted then
most people will end up in community
power just by just because
they're already there
and then if they are dissatisfied they
can opt out
if it's an opt in program then most
people will never opt in because
you know you know
you it's it's just would be very hard
you know to just
people will just go what with the the
the path of least resistance which is
just to stay with what you have
so the whole point of opting out is to
introduce people to community power to
show them the advent you know to
firsthand not try to persuade them but
to demonstrate the advantages through
lower prices through
maybe a different mix of energy
and then
uh when
you know if they find that it is
unsatisfactory we don't deliver on the
promise the price goes up or whatever
they can opt out and go back to uh the
utility
i
believe i see a representative
representative oxenham's hand is up for
a question
yes thank you very much and thank you mr
mayor for taking my question you're the
first speaker who's spoken about green
energy or a different mix of energy
when i first encountered community power
aggregation that was the advantage that
caught my eye that you know we weren't
going to be dealing with
large stodgy utilities who just keep
doing things the way they've always done
them this is you said was going to be a
more nimble organization that could make
you know make choices that were locally
advantageous
in your dissertation
do you have a question
it makes it way harder when you
interrupt and i have to listen to your
question and figure out what my answer
is because now
i
i was talking about green energy in a
different energy mix well i think that i
think the point was that you're i'm
sorry mr mayor you you you're ahead of
me go ahead and answer the question i
think i understand the the intent of the
question
i mean a community is much more
experienced
in
reaching out to citizens and getting
input i mean we do that all the time
like right now the city of nashua is
doing a master planning exercise
we're getting the input of people as to
what they'd like to see
so in addition to developing
alternatives i think an advantage of
community
power aggregation
is that
we could
seek
a consensus
of customers
as to you know what mix of these
different alternatives you know these
different ideas do you like
do you would you rather us to go just as
cheap as we can would you rather us to
introduce green power or maybe a mix
um it would also potentially be possible
to maybe offer
several
um
oh dear
what happened
some bargaining power
here's a portfolio with the less green
energy that costs less but here's the
one that caught you know more green
energy costs maybe a little more
and people could select i mean we could
work with our residents to come up with
these alternatives that
and give them the kind of uh input and
involvement which really is not
realistic when you're dealing with
a you know
a national publicly traded utility
thank you very much
thank you uh
i see a hand raised by uh representative
samson police for a question
yes thank you mr chairman uh nice to
hear from you jim this is peter samsich
hi peter
um so um
number one i it was mentioned before
that
uh there was not a really big demand by
a lot of people in this state for
community power and aggregation you
listed a whole bunch of towns and cities
that you you thought were involved in
serious interest in this uh how would
you assess how big the demand is right
now that you know of
well so we've been working uh
closely with kesher county rockingham
county
hanover
and mr bilo could give you the more
details but hanover lebanon
and i think other communities
uh formally
seeking to
actually formalize an agreement between
between us as to how to
service customers if this thing ever
gets off the ground things like that
the
but i've been talking with other
communities that are certainly
interested as they begin to learn about
it for example
i had a conversation this is just one
example but with the
uh mayor of dover and we've i've
discussed this we've discussed this on a
call with mayors from about 10 cities
all at the same time but in the
follow-up
i talked with the mayor of dober whose
name bob carrier and he says you know
that sounds pretty good i would like you
to we have an energy advisory committee
here in dover and you know this is
pretty technical could you get together
with you know virtually of course with
our energy committee and
brief them on this so that they can they
can give me their their thoughts on
whether this makes sense for dover
and
uh we're we've got that kind of in the
works um and we've had other similar
discussions with other communities who i
think as they learn more about it uh
become more and more interested
uh follow up mr chair
yes from last follow
uh and uh jim uh the uh as i understood
it for a standard from what nashua is
involved with right now with their hydro
dams and so forth
how would your capability of providing
your local
uh city uh power
as part of this program how does that
integrate into this community power
equation was taken home
i think we would need to get um i i
think we need to get someone with more
technical knowledge than me to answer
that question okay but that does remind
me of another issue which is that under
the default utility would retain all
solar customers meaning people
residential uh
solar uh users soda
solar panels on their roof even those
that went solar after the convert after
the switchover
and that doesn't seem like it makes
sense either so that's another issue
with 315.
thank you
we've spent a long time and we have a
lot more people to speak on the interest
of moving on i'm going to thank uh mary
dodges for his testimony and the
questions and i will call on a member of
the public a uh an amy farhan if she's
on uh
a member of the public yeah iran
all right thank you thanks for taking my
call thank you um to all of you
especially who are staying home and
staying safe
i am one of those people that has solar
on my home um you were just talking to
the mayor about
and
i um my my family wants to be a part of
this community power
but under hb 315
we would not have the ability to do that
so
315 eliminates
you know the ability for my solar power
to participate in the community power
aggregation
so that's an issue for me personally um
you know i was able to afford a solar
array
not a lot of people can
and that's you know that's been an issue
it's not
accessible to everyone
and another problem with hp 315 is that
it prevents
low to moderate income folks from
receiving
the benefit of solar power
and from participating in community
power so
you know the governor's letter is saying
sure that he's
he's very interested in helping low to
moderate income families but
the truth is
315 is is not going to allow them to
to
be part of this so
um you know
i i'll also work on an energy committee
in exeter um we've worked with
mr bilo and mr herndon
and our energy committee has been very
excited about this project and
we've formed committees we've we've
worked we've spent a lot of hours on it
and so i guess just from
their point of view from our point of
view it's disappointing because it feels
like
hb 315 is just basically crushing that
for us
um
and that's going on with a lot of town
so
i hope we're seeing this for what it is
you know the idea that um
that eversource was coming in to sort of
clean up the language here
i
i think that's a
mischaracterization i think
they recognized a sort of lull in
progress and
and jumped in and said here's what we
want instead
so i hope
i hope everyone today can can see that
thank you
um
thank you very much for your testimony i
don't see any
hands raised anywhere in the room or
on the screen so thank you very much for
testimony we appreciate it moving on to
the next
speaker we are going to recognize mr
donaghy from eversource
donna iran
thank you very much good afternoon um i
am donna gamache director of
governmental affairs for eversource and
i have matthew fossum uh with me today
who's intimately engaged at the puc on
this issue and is available to answer
your questions after
we support house bill 315 especially
with the amendment that's been talked
about it's important to note that we
have worked with many communities in
other states to successfully implement
community aggregation over the past
several years for example in
massachusetts eversource has worked with
approximately 70 different communities
to get aggregation programs on the
ground of the 70 10 have just completed
the regulatory review of the programs by
the massachusetts version of the public
utilities commission and they should be
on the ground very soon
as you have already heard there's a
difference between community aggregation
and community power although they can be
combined house bill 315 ends the hold up
of rolling out community aggregation
upon passage we support the bill and the
amendment because not only does it
finally unlock aggregation but it
actually ensures that
some of the risks to aggregators that
exist today are removed and it makes
sure that they recognize that new
hampshire is serious on this issue
unlike the open discussion that's taking
place right now about this bill and what
this bill might or might not do
and the upcoming amendment unfortunately
in 2019 there were a number of last
minute amendments added to a bill where
the language was vague and confusing
and there was no public input there was
no review there was no public hearing
there are always unintended consequences
when such complex and sweeping language
does not have stakeholder input or
review so as a result the lack of
understanding and disagreement from a
variety of interests over what the
existing law means has resulted in rules
being stalled at the public utilities
commission a year and a half after the
bill passed no progress has been made
we're also seeing a number of bills that
have already been introduced this
session by other legislators and
supported by different energy interests
aimed at trying to clarify the law so it
is clear that a fix is necessary let's
get down to the current problems during
rule making discussions at the puc
several issues have come to light
specific to community power plans
including
um problems with infrastructure and
system changes that the utilities would
need to implement
you know in order to implement some of
these billing requirements it includes
potentially converting our meters to ami
meters or what we call smart meters that
shares two-way information
and also
also changes to our customer information
system
so between in
changes to our customer information
system and in the potential for
widespread or we don't really know how
much uh new smart meters
we don't actually know what the cost
would be for it because we haven't been
told what the scope is yet but we are on
record in a specific puc docket about
the cost to convert to those meters and
that is it on record in excess of 200
million dollars
given limited time to testify today we
want you to recognize that there are
many many other issues that are
potentially costly and complex i will
submit written testimony that goes into
further detail on all of those issues
but there is one particular issue that
is concerning that i want to raise today
the lack of clarity in existing law
about what is and is not included has
led to claims that communities who
undertake community power plans should
or must have a view of our distribution
grid to support plans that they may
potentially develop in the future
theoretical now because the law is
unclear there is an interpretation of
that language that would require a
prototype for a brand new platform
allowing a town employee employees or
some contractor perhaps to have a view
into this grid into the distribution
grid
let me be clear there is nothing on the
shelf that would enable this and
therefore no idea on the overall cost
and who would pay for this set the cost
aside how would these communities ensure
security of the grid every single week
we receive more than one million hits on
our system mainly by bad characters in
other countries to shut down our system
we have a highly sophisticated security
system and as you can imagine we're
heavily regulated to make sure that we
are always more than adequately securing
the system these issues are outside of
typical aggregation policies in place in
most states and make this law extremely
complicated and expensive to implement
so in
closing i just wanted to reiterate that
we support implementing a law that
allows a community aggregation to move
forward but we also support still
studying all those other issues all the
concerns that we just raised so that we
can find a way to move forward if it
makes sense if if our customers want it
and if we everybody can afford it
they're very complex and we want to make
sure that if there are going to be major
investments and major ratepayer
contributions that it gets the it gets
the light of day and it gets fully
studied so we believe house bill 13 315
allows all of that to happen and so with
that i just wanted to make sure that you
knew that matthew was here and matthew
can respond to your questions because of
his um in-depth involvement at the buc
thank you
thank you from squash thank you for your
testimony uh questions
i see uh
i see uh representative samsung's hand
up for a question
yes thank you mr chairman
uh and thank you donna for taking my
question
um i'm not surprised that eversource is
really enjoying this bill because they
wrote the bill
so
that's not a surprise to me but i want
to say to begin with that uh
i congratulate every source for
all the accolades they've been getting
as one of the best
utilities in the country for energy
efficiency and even renewable energy
efforts unfortunately those efforts have
not happened in new hampshire and that
is a problem and this bill is maybe
reflective of what's happening to them
here in new hampshire representative
thompson
my question is don't you agree with me
that it would be better for eversource
to be leading the charge for community
power than opposing it
well i am going to let uh matthew speak
to that but i want to say that we would
be happy to lead the charge on any clean
energy programs community power programs
as long as we know what the costs are
going to be that they're going to be
secure and who's going to pay the bill
but i can pass that off to um matthew if
you want to add yeah thank you very much
uh representative uh brazilian for
questions please uh thank you mr
chairman and thank you donna gamache for
your testimony
uh is it true that uh municipal solar
power would not be allowed to be
generated and sold to aggregated
customers that i absolutely have to pass
off to matthew can you take that matthew
please
is he there
well if matthew can't for some reason
respond here's what i'm going to say i i
have not heard that i i've not heard
anywhere that anybody if you if if a
local community there's net metering um
if a local community wants to have their
own power they want to build their own
solar they can do all of that today they
do not need house bill 315 they don't
need to kill house bill 315 to make that
happen so um i don't know where that
comes from but i do wish that we could
get matthew to give a little more
clarity to that
i see that matthew has come on so uh
matthew go ahead you're on
uh can you hear me now
yes
okay uh i'll just
uh for tuesday my name is matthew fossum
i'm an attorney with eversource focusing
primarily almost exclusively on on new
hampshire regulatory issues
in response to uh the question as i
understand it which has to do with
whether
solar could be included in a community
aggregation
if 315 was to pass
i believe that it can and i it's not
clear to me what provision or provisions
would seem to indicate
otherwise
i can only speculate that perhaps
there's a view toward
one of the proposed amendments that's in
um that strikes out a reference to the
plan
uh to an aggregation plan covering uh
net metering
but that's not to eliminate net metering
or solar generation
those would stay
the intent as i understand it there is
basically to leave those things more or
less as they are today
not to
eliminate them or
make make them go away
thank you um
i see uh representative camola has a
question please
sorry
that's right
thank you
um uh thank you i just had a quick
question can things like net metering
and energy efficiency programs be done
separately from aggregation
yes they can uh in fact i mean there is
there is a statute um that exists and
has existed
for a number of years now in rsa 37
i'm sorry rsa53f
that allows for the establishment of
energy efficiency in clean energy
districts um obviously 315 doesn't touch
that
that statute at all and it allows
certain activities to occur
uh there so that that could be done
before can be done after
um and so there we don't
see anything about 315 that would impede
uh the creation of districts that would
do that sort of thing
thank you thank you uh representative
mcgee you have your hand up
i do thank you
uh and thank you mr fossum for taking my
question or miss gamache whoever um
prefers to answer it
i'm curious about um whether eversource
has uh ami or smart meters in other
states that they're serving in other
than new hampshire
uh we do not
so you don't have you don't have smart
meters anywhere that you provide service
so our service territory in the broader
company covers connecticut massachusetts
and new hampshire and in all of those
states we employ an
amr an advance
automated meter reading system
um
so that's that's the metering that we
have in place across our entire service
territory
and can you explain to us how
that's different in terms of smart like
what what's missing
certainly and and you know i'll i'll
note in this that at least in new
hampshire i know there's an additional
difficulty that um that requires an
opt-in uh for for smart meters but
that issue aside um the difference is is
not
so a an amr system functions much the
same way as the older systems do they
generally speaking they take a
a single reading
actually take multiple readings but that
reading is is collected one time per
month
um and then that is the value that is
used for uh determining the bill
uh that's rendered to the customer
so on our current system that's done by
a drive-by system
the the meters
a
vehicle drives by and remotely collects
that information
and then that's brought back into our
secure meter data management system and
used for billing
an ami system
sort of at the basic level eliminates
that drive by and has that meter data
sent by
wireline or wireless technology
back to the utility
uh so that's
sort of the
the one big difference operationally
beyond that uh
depending on the type of ami system that
is installed then you can have meters
that can do
more than
a once a month reading they can
send out as mr beelow referred to as
interval meters they can read and report
information
much more frequently than once a month
perhaps as far down as within 15 minute
intervals
they would allow the
utility company to
send a signal to that meter to test it
uh to make sure that it's it's
functioning
um and those kinds of things
um
theoretically some of these can be can
do even more advanced things but that's
in broad strokes those are the big
differences between them thank you and
may i have a follow up
well representative you've already had
your follow-up you took it i didn't give
it to you but you took it uh you had two
questions so thank you very much for
that
um we have to move on we have many other
uh speakers
uh i don't see any other oh i'm sorry i
see uh representative
minardi has to stand up for a question
please
mr christ said that hb 315 preserves
default service to the detriment of
aggregation in the ratepayers do you see
that as true
uh
i don't suppose it will surprise you to
say i do not um
as as ms gamache said it um
we have no
desire or intent to impede the roll out
of community aggregation and by that we
mean the
um the grouping together of customers to
give them
greater buying power and the ability to
set their own priorities for an energy
mix
that that's not something we have any
desire to stop or slow down and we
recognize that having customers served
that way will have an impact on default
service
and that is an impact that can be dealt
with
if it's done in a relatively orderly
fashion
uh i think where our disagreement may
lie is in some of the issues you've
heard talked about uh for instance the
timing
for these aggregations to begin
and the impact that would have on
default service
our concern there is that
in the intent to achieve the best price
possible for that aggregation
it may have a large number of customers
leave or return
to default service at inopportune times
and that could lead to increased cost
for
any customers remaining on default
service
and so that that's our concern there
but ultimately if if aggregation was to
spread and cover virtually every
community
and default service would remain only
for a tiny minority
then that's what will happen and i don't
think that we have any problem with that
happening
our concerns aren't with uh with that
kind of issue
thank you thank you
um
in the interest uh we're trying to get
one more uh testifier in here before the
end of the day and so um
i will move on to our next uh speaker
who is mr mark brown mark brown you are
on uh the last speaker for the day
thank you can you hear me
okay can you hear me
yes yes
okay hi
um
chairman vel's the members of the
committee for the record my name is
mark brown i'm the executive director of
new england for consumer energy alliance
or cea
cea is a nationwide association made up
of both energy consumers and producers
working to advance an all-of-the-above
energy policy that will lower energy
costs for every american
cea supports actions that thoughtfully
advance our nation towards a cleaner or
environmentally more environmentally
responsible future
on behalf of cea i want to thank you for
the opportunity to testify today in
support of hb 315 sponsored by chairman
vos
the section of hp 315 which we're most
interested in is the section that
actually referenced
representative from mention about
incidental costs
the inclusion of incidental costs to
non-participants
who choose to opt out of a community
choice aggregation program it's
problematic
incentive costs are neither well defined
nor restricted in any way under the
current statute
could it include startup costs ongoing
operational costs
there is one potential cost to
non-participants that concerns us more
than any other and that is the potential
for an exit fee charged to customers who
choose to opt out of a cca program
after its implementation
while this may seem unlikely exit fees
have been proposed and enacted in other
states
in california for example a power charge
in different amount
which is essentially an exit fee on
customers leaving standard offer servers
to two cca programs
was authorized by the public utilities
commission of california to account for
lost load and other legacy costs there
maryland recently had a cca bill
which was introduced in 2020
it ended up dying due to you know due to
cove probably
but it included language that gave the
public service commission in maryland
oversight over any exit fees
now whether or not these exit fees are
necessary is debatable
but the common denominator of commission
oversight in each of these scenarios
isn't guaranteed under the current
community choice aggregation statute
um as mayor don just referenced you know
we can all agree that a great many
consumers including low and fixed
customers won't initially be aware that
they are now receiving their power by
community aggregation
we should protect consumer choice by
ensuring that those customers and those
who choose to opt out aren't charged
excessive fees or become responsible for
other poorly defined
and unrestrained
incidental costs
to be clear cea is not opposed to
community choice segregation in new
hampshire but current law opens a
pandora's box to potential costs that
could hold consumers captive to cca
programs and restrict their ability to
choose their electricity supply 30
seconds
hb 15 hp 315 would eliminate that
possibility and for that reason on
behalf of cea i urge you to recommend
ought to pass
thank you and with that i'll take any
questions regarding the bill
thank you mr brown for your testimony
well appreciated
mike mike chair you're mike sutton
thank you
for your testimony well appreciated
uh i keep forgetting that i gotta leave
the button alone instead of holding it
down but
uh moving on i see a hand up by uh
represent
kelly pitts for a question please
one question i have is we keep repre
we keep uh referencing community power
and i guess i want a definition of
community power
and aggregation how large can these
systems become
can they be you know a town a city a
region
a county
uh does anybody have any parameters on
that
um i i don't think it's limited i think
you know
i think if
a network communities want to sign up
they can they can do that i don't think
there's any restrictions there not to my
understanding anyway
man fella
yes
in in in your experience in other
communities or other states
up to people um
do areas join in other words portsmouth
greenland
pitterie
can we get together and do all this
i'm not sure you could do it across
state lines um and i and i'm not saying
you can't i'm just i'm not sure how that
would work okay
i i i doubt you could but um yeah it's
you know in california communities have
joined together to purchase you know
characters
the right to join community aggregation
programs so thank you
thank you before we move on to
representative uh
i'm sorry
did you submit written testimony i will
thank you okay thank you very much
uh representative sam please you have a
question please
oh yes thank you mr chairman and thank
you mr brown for sending my question
first of all mr brown i'm not familiar
with the organization you represent can
you uh tell me what the name of that is
again consumer energy alliance i emailed
the committee um i think earlier in the
week it's a national organization um
we have over 300 business and you know
members um you have the list of members
in an email that i sent you
um
okay i gave a brief explanation to what
we who we are in in my introduction
follow up mr chairman
uh so mr brown uh is that is a list of
your supporters available publicly
absolutely so let me give you an example
of some of our members the u.s chamber
of commerce national association
national association of manufacturers
energy companies
we as i mentioned you know we are a
mixture of producers and consumers
so
did you send us will you send us that
list
i did and i sent you a link with both
the members and the board of directors
thank you very much you're
welcome representative mckee her
question please
yes thank you uh mr chairman i i just
wanted to mention that i i think we're
at five o'clock and i just wanted to
mention there's a lot of people left so
are we gonna have additional time for
this hearing or how is that going to
work are we going to continue now
because i know we usually stop right at
five because there's people that want to
leave the building
yes um i will uh
hazard a guess from the chair that we
will be recessing this
this hearing and picking it up at a
later date
if i can get a concurrence from
chairman votes
yes
yes we can do that certainly this is
exact words
thank you oh with that being said and
well i see one i'll take one more
question from representative uh partial
please
yes uh that's very quickly could you get
the count on the blue sheets on this yes
that's right
support
i didn't hear that at all yeah yeah was
that again
411 opposed
nights what
was that 111
[Music]
the calendar
and now i will turn the remainder of the
uh
meeting over to uh chairman votes
can we thank representative homula for
her work on our committee these past
weeks
yes
yes absolutely we will thank her
and welcome representative plet back on
uh
next friday we will have our next series
of public hearings next friday then we
will have our final public hearing
on monday the 22nd we will also probably
continue
the two
public hearings that we recessed today
on that date
and then we will probably have to
schedule another meeting
after that to finish our executive
sessions on all the remaining bills
that's the way things are looking right
now
i hope you all have a wonderful weekend
and a happy valentine's day
and we'll see you all later this meeting
is officially concluded for today thank
you thank you representative